AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND ADHERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSAR ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. OUR
MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATORS STERN IN
AMBERG WELCOME SENATOR STERN
AND IF YOU HAVE STAFF WITH YOU
TODAY WILL YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY
THEM NOW. YEAH YES- SENATOR
HENRY STERN OF MY DISTRICT
OFFICE HERE WITH MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR JEREMY WOLFE. GOOD
MORNING TO YOU BOTH AND- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SENATOR
NUMBER WILL BE JOINING US
SHORTLY BUT THAT HE IS NOT. A
PRESENT REMOTELY AT THIS POINT
IN TIME WHEN HE DOES BECOME
AVAILABLE WE WILL MAKE THE SAME
INQUIRY OF HIM AT THAT TIME.
SENATORS AS A REMINDER PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK WHICH CAN BE QUITE
BRUTAL. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE YOU
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. AND
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKESURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN. THEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE JOINING US
REMOTELY SENATORS STERN IN ON
BURKE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
TO THE PUBLIC OF THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. ARE ALLOWED AND
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFIED TODAY.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
PARTICIPANTS- THE
PARTICIPATION. TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW AND WILL
REPEAT IT- ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS. DURING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING BECAUSE WE
WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THE NUMBER TODAY
IS ONE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
944-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE EIGHT ONE.
1-599-381-6999 FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE. THENZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY PLEASE
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT AND ON OCCASION A
LINK TO YOUR WEIGHT SO PLEASE
BE PATIENT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON YOU
DID AND YOU ARE THEN READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. SO WE WILL NOW BEGIN OUR
HEARING WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS.
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY. SIX OF
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHORS AND- THE
EXTRAORDINARY STAFF- THAT IS
PART OF OUR JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR EXTRAORDINARILY-
EXCELLENT WORK IN A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT COVERT CIRCUMSTANCE.
THOSE BILLS ARE. I BEFORE I GET
TO THEM I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOU
KNOW THAT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. AB TWENTY FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR WE WILL
NOT BE HEARING THAT BILL TODAY.
BUT WE WILL BE CONSIDERING THE
CONSENT- CALENDAR.WE HAVE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAU THAT THE SIMPLY EXTENDS
THE- A LENGTH OF TIME IN WHICH
EMPLOYERS- WILL BE NEGOTIATING
WITH EMPLOYEES OVER ACCESS TO
PRIVATE INFORMATION- THAT IS
FILE ITEM TO FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYMENT DISPUTE. WHICH IS
JUST A TWEAK AT THE REQUEST OF
THE GOVERNOR ON A MEASURE THAT
WAS PASSED LAST YEAR. WE ALSO
HAVE A FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY TWO- BY THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY THAT
ADDRESSES THE STATE BAR OPEN
MEETINGS A DISCIPLINE ATTORNEYS
AND- ANNUAL LICENSE FEES AMONG
OTHER ISSUES THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AS WELL. WE
HAVE THE JUDICIARY OMNIBUS BILL
AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR BY
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY
WHICH IS ALSO A CONSENT ITEM.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AC ARE ONE SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION STUDIES
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR. INTO
THAT NOW AND WILL NOTE THAT
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WILL BE MOVING
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AT FOR PURPOSES
OF ESTABLISHING A QUORUM PLEASE
SENATORS TURN YOUR MICROPHONES
ON JACKSON HERE. JACKSON HERE.
BORJAS RESIDENT. BORDERS
PRESENT DATA SO. GONZALEZ HERE
GONZALEZ HERE MELENDEZ HERE
MELINDA'S HERE MINING HERE
MONNING HERE STERN EARLIER.
STERN HERE NUMBER. WHY CASCADE
NEAR WHERE CASKEY HERE READ
CHAIR YOU HAVE A QUORUM VERY
GOOD A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR Y.
KOWSKI ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BEFORE THE WITH OUR
REGION. IN MY CASE. AND IF YOU.
OKAY. I DIDN'T FOLLOW MY SCRIPT
SO IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME HERE-
SO THAT WE HAVE THAT CLARITY-
WE DO HAVE- AS I MENTIONED THE
TWO OF FOUR SIX ITEMS ON
CONSENT THE ONE I DID NOT
MENTION- IS FILE ITEM THREE
WHICH IS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
SANTIAGO BECAUSE THE BILL WAS
RECENTLY GUTTED AND AMENDED I
WANT TO I WANT TO GIVE A
DESCRIPTION OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS- THE BILL WILL NOW
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMITTEE. BY
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO DELIVER TO THE
LEGISLATURE A STUDY REGARDING
ELECTRONIC WILLS THIS IS A CASE
STUDY ON A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE
BUT THIS OF A STUDY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. WILL ADDRESS HOW
ELECTRONIC WILLS ARE ADDRESSED
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS. AND BY
THE UNIFORM LAW COMMISSION TO
CASE STUDIES. A WILL BE
PRESENTED AND COMMON ISSUES
RELATED TO ELECTRONIC WILLS
WILL BE INCLUDED THE STUDY MUST
PROPOSE A STATUTORY SCHEME FOR
RECOGNIZING ELECTRONIC WILLS IF
THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION COMMISSION
DETERMINES THAT IT IS PRUDENT
AND DOES NOT POSE UNNECESSARY
RISKS OF FRAUD. THAT IS OF
COURSE THE KEY ISSUE OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRACIOUSLY
AGREED TO PUT THIS INTO A STUDY
AND AS SUCH IT IS- CONSENT
ELIGIBLE AND WILL BE AMONG THE
SIX ITEMS- THAT WE VOTE ON THE
SCHOOL AGAIN FILE ITEM. TWO
THREE SIX ELEVEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN OR THE CONSENT ITEMS
TO MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS. ARTICULATED THANK YOU
SENATOR Y. CASKEY WITH THAT-
MADAMCONSULTANT WOULD YOU CALL
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WORLD YES
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. JACK'S HI
JACKSON I BORDERS RIGHT FORGES
I DID A CELL. GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESPITE MONNING AYE MONNING AYE
STERN. STERN I AM BURKE. WHY
CAL SKI HI. WHY CASKEY I. AT
SEVEN RIGHT WE WILL- THIS SEVEN
TO ZERO WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THEN- AT THIS POINT WE WILL. A
START WITH OUR HEARING TODAY WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM ONE AB SIX
SIXTY- THEN BECAUSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHA IS UNABLE TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM FOR. A. B. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE WILL PRESENT THAT
BILL FOR HIM. AFTER THAT WE
HAVE FILE ITEM EIGHT. AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO THEN WE WILL
GO BACK INTO FILE ORDER WITH
SENATOR MORNING PRESENTING FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE AND FILE ITEM NINE AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO. BOTH BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS WHO IS
ALSO UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA WILL BE
THE LAST WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN WHICH IS AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT. PART OF THE
REASON FOR- IDENTIFYING THE-
THE FORM FOR TODAY IS THAT IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY ON ANY OF THOSE BILLS
PLEASE TAKE NOTE OF THE ORDER
THAT WE WILL BE HEARING THE
BILLS TODAY. SO WITH THAT. LET
US NOW A START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SIX SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT LEVINE GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
THE FLOOR'S YOURS GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR LET ME FIRST BEGIN
BY EXTENDING MY BEST WISHES THE
SENATOR- BURKE AND HIS FAMILY
TODAY I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR SERVICE IN
THE LEGISLATURE- IT'S BEEN.
WONDERFUL TIME TO MAKE LAWS
WITH YOU- YOUR LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COMMITTEE- AND ON SO MANY
ISSUES HAVE BEEN INSPIRING FOR
ME AS A LAWMAKER I ALSO HAVE
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOUR
STAFF- DURING YOUR TIME HERE
AND IT'S A REFLECTION OF THE
HARD WORK- THAT YOU PURSUE AND
ALSO THE JUST LAWS ARE THAT WE
ALL I PURSUE AS OUR GOALS HERE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU. EIGHT YEAH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB SIX
SIXTY WOULD PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROMPARTICIPATING
IN CO THAT NINETEEN RELATED
CONTACT TRACING. AND PLACE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ON DATA
COLLECTED THROUGH CONTACT
TRACING PROGRAMS. AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL INCLUDE
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS. AND
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED TO
THE COMMITTEE BY THE COMMITTEE
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO DATE
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN FIVE.
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
CONFIRMED CASES OF COVERT
NINETEEN AND OVER TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE DIED FROM
THIS VIRUS NATIONALLY OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND AMERICANS HAVE DIED
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS AN
INTEGRAL PART. OF COMBATING
COVE IN NINETEEN WILL BE THE
USE OF CONTACT TRACING WHICH
IDENTIFIES CODE NINETEEN
POSITIVE INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE
WHO HAVEBEEN IN CLOSE CONTACT
WITH THEM. UNTIL A VACCINE IS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC CONTACT
TRACING IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND CONTAINS SPREAD. OF
THE CORONAVIRUS SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF CONTACT
TRACING WILL REQUIRE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN THE ACTIONS TAKEN
BY FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. CALIFORNIA IS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE OVER ELEVEN
MILLION IMMIGRANTS INCLUDING AN
ESTIMATED TWO MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS THAT
CALL THE GOLDEN STATE HOME.
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE INTEREST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COAL NINETEEN. YET ARE LESS
LIKELY TO SEEK MEDICAL AID OR
PARTICIPATE IN CONTACT TRACING
PROGRAMS CONDUCTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BECAUSE OF THEIR
IN PATIENT STATUS. ONE FORTY AS
A- FONG. TO PROTECT ME THROUGH
HOW. YET THE DEPLOYMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL TO
CONDUCT CONTACT TRACING IS NOT.
AN APPROPRIATE USE OF LIMITED
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND IT IS IN
FACT AN IMPEDIMENT TO EFFECTIVE
CONTACT TRACING. EIGHTY SIX
SIXTY BUILT UPON THE WORK OF
OUR STATE TO RESPECT AND
PROTECT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
BY PROHIBITING CONTACT TRACING
ACTIVITIES BY A STATE OR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND
ENSURING. SENSITIVE INFORMATION
COLLECTED THROUGH CONTACT
TRACING IS NOT SHARED WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS
EIGHTY SIX SIXTY PROVIDES
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR
PERSONAL DATA. BUILDS TRUST AND
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE AND
ENCOURAGES ALL COMMUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN ONE OF THE
PROVEN PROGRAMS AND LIMIT THE
SPREAD OF KOBE NINETEEN.
PROVIDING TESTIMONY TODAY IS
LINDA NORWAY WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE- TO- ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IF INDICATED
YOUR MAIN WITNESS. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND THE CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. ARE MAIN WITNESSES
IN UPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE LIMITED- GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO- HERE AND
CONSENT TO A NUMBER OF THESE
BILLS I'M GOING TO INDICATE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW. FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL- TO EACH SIDE TO
BE SPENT TO AS THE WITNESSES SO
CHOOSE- SO A YEAR I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ONE MAIN WITNESS SHE WILL
BE GIVEN. UP TO FOUR MINUTES-
TO SPEAK AND THEN OF COURSE THE
OPPOSITION WILL ALSO BE GIVEN
FOUR MINUTES- FOR THE MAIN
WITNESSES SO- AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- I WOULD LIKE YOU TO GO
AHEAD AND HAVE YOUR- MAIN
WITNESS- TESTIFIED. OF THOSE
WHO ARE- GOING TO INDICATE-
THEIR SUPPORT WE SOMETIMES FOR
THEM IS ME TOO- IT WILL BE
RELEGATED TO SIMPLY PROVIDING
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL. OF AT
THIS POINT WE ARE THOSE SEEKING
ONLY THOSE IN SUPPORT TO PLEASE
OUR LINE UP IN THE QUEUE. AND
WE WILL START WITH YOUR MAIN
WITNESS SHE HAS UP TO FOUR
MINUTES. THANK YOU. BUT SHE
DOESN'T HAVE TO TAKE OFF IT'S
JUST THAT SHE WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO WORK. MADAM MODERATOR MR
MODERATE OR NOT SURE WHAT WE
HAVE TODAY BUT APPARENTLY A
LINDA IT HAS NOT- CALLED INTO
THE WITNESS LINE WOULD YOU
CHECK TO SEE IF SHE MIGHT BE ON
THE GENERAL PUBLIC LINE. OKAY
I'M GOING TO CHECK RIGHT NOW BE
JUST ONE MOMENT WHILE I CHECK.
THANK YOU. OKAY I BELIEVE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IT LINDA IS IT
PRONOUNCED NINE
ARE ON THE CALL YOU CAN PRESS
STAR THEN ZERO SO THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY YOUR LINE AGAIN WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE RIGHT AND LINDA
AND IT G. U. Y. A LINDA IF YOU
HAPPEN TO BE ON THE CALL ON THE
PHONE. IF YOU CAN PRESS STAR
ZERO SO THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY
YOUR LINE. THIS NEVER HAPPENS.
YEAH. I AM NOT GETTING A
RESPONSE SO FAR ON THE PHONE.
APPARENTLY SHE'S CALLING IN
RIGHT NOW AND IT WILL TAKE A
MINUTE OR TWO COULD YOU TELL US
MATTER MODERATE OR HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE HAVE ON THE PUBLIC
LINE AT THIS POINT. WE HAVE
FOUR PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE AND
THE PUBLIC LINE. WHY DON'T WE
GO AHEAD AND HIT AND LET THE
PUBLIC INDIVIDUALS TESTIFIED
PLEASE IF YOU WOULD PROVIDE US
WITH YOUR NAME. AFFILIATION AND
INDICATING YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
MEASURE. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SIX ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO PICK UP
THE HANDSET- NOW I BELIEVE I
SHE MIGHT HAVE JUST CALLED AND-
BRIAN GOOD MORNING. MY YOU CAN
HEAR ME ON OUR TO DO WE HAVE A
NOW THIS IS THE BEAUTY OF
TECHNOLOGY- IS THIS LINDA NIGH
OR IS IT A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
MIDLAND AWAY WITH VERY GOOD
HEAD ON MON PART SO IF THOSE
OTHER FOUR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IF YOU JUST HOLD ON- IS
NOW YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES
TO PRESENT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
USE IT ALL BUT YOU DO HAVE FOUR
MINUTES IF YOU CHOOSE. THE
FORESHORES. GREAT THANK YOU AND
AGAIN MY APOLOGIES WENT AWAY
WITH ELECTION TEN ONLINE COPY
FOR YOU CAN SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX
SIXTY EIGHT. WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS FROM ENGAGING IN
CONTRACT. CONTRACT TREATING. TO
BE USED ONLY FOR CONTRACT
TRADING PURPOSES. CONJECTURE
YOU THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO LIMIT THE CREDIT CODE
NINETEEN ANY MOST AFFECTED WITH
COMPLETE DATA PROVIDED. TRUSTED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LIKE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE COMMUNITY
WORKERS ARE THE BEST COLLECTORS
THE FIFTY THAT. ACTUALLY THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE ALREADY
OVER CLEAN. THE COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING OF AT THE VERY
COMMUNITY. IMPACT BY THE- OUR
LIKELY TO INTERACT. TO
WILLINGLY INTERACT WE LAW OR
OFFICIALS. IN THE CURRENT ANTI
IMMIGRANT CLIMATE WE HEAR
REGULARLY FROM ARE LEGALLY
PARTNERS. AND ARE ALREADY
AFRAID TO SPEAK HEALTHCARE
ENROLLMENT PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS OR OTHERWISE BE
CONSISTENT MILLER LEAD MANY
PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE
EXPERIENCED NEGATIVE
INTERACTIONS WITH POLICE EVEN
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S
CALLED THE HELP. WELL YOU FOR
THE NINE TO COME THINK WE'LL
USE ONLY THOSE COMMUNITY
WORKERS THAT ALREADY TRACKED IT
TO LIMIT THE VIRUS SPREAD TO
FACT THAT CONTRACT ANYTHING AND
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL HEALTH DATA.
WE URGE RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT NOW LET US
GO MADAM MODERATOR TO THE
PUBLIC MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX SIX ZERO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO GET INTO THE
PHONE QUEUE AGAIN THAT IS ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE LINE ET FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN LINE FOR. I'M NOT BE IN
THE WRONG QUEUE BECAUSE I'M NOT
FOR THIS. PICULET ONE ENTRY
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO.
ALLOCATING YOU I WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY ONE THAT'S LINE FOR
ONE THE LINE IS OPEN. BECKONED
CREAMER NOT AROUND THE HOUSE
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. EIGHTY SIX
POINT EIGHTY SIX WE HAVE A LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. CORBIN WITH
CORNING HI THERE. RIGHT RIGHTS
CLEARING ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. OR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX SIX ZERO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ARE THERE ANY OTHER ONE
ON THE CERES NO ONE ELSE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE.
VERY GOOD A FEW CHECK ONE MORE
TIME AND WHILE YOU'RE DOING
THAT I'D LIKE TO INDICATE THAT
AND WELCOME SENATOR ON BURKE
WHO HAS NOW JOINED US REMOTELY.
A GOOD MORNING SENATOR UMBERG
AND IF YOU HAVE A STAFF MEMBER.
WITH YOU WOULD YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY THAT PERSON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU CAN HEAR ME-
I AM HERE THE DISTRICT OFFICE
WITH THE DISTRICT DIRECTOR NICK
I'M NOT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELCOME ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE LINE MADAM MODERATOR. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT IN TIME- THE
OPPOSITION IF THERE ARE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I DON'T.
BELIEVE I HAVE IS AN INDICATION
OF ANYONE WHO IS A WITNESS
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. OF
AND BEFORE WE DO THAT MY
APOLOGIES I'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
ANY OF THE ALTERNATIVE ROOMS%
WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE SIR
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
OPPOSITION AND- I BELIEVE WE DO
HAVE A WITNESS HERE. TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION MR MCNEILLY. GOOD
AFRICAN MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR IN BETWEEN THEM I'M
SORRY I ON BEHALF OF. TH
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION THE AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL CAME INTO PRINT
LESS THAN FORTY EIGHT HOURS AGO
AND- IT'S OUT TO OUR MEMBERSHIP
BUT SOME HAVE EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERN WITH THE LANGUAGE- SO
WE WILL. GET IN TOUCH WITH THE
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND OF
COURSE THE AUTHOR STAFF TO
IDENTIFY THOSE ISSUES WE HAVE
NO FORMAL POSITION BUT DID WANT
TO NOTE THOSE CONCERNS WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
KELLY AND I'M SURE THE AUTHOR
CERTAINLY OUR COMMITTEE. WILL
BE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN THOSE
RECOGNIZING THE UNUSUAL NATURE
OF THIS COMPACTED YEAR-
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
POINTING THAT OUT. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN THE
CHAMBER WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
pSEEING NONE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE THIS OR ANYONE IN ONE
TWELFTH THERE'S NOT. WITH THAT-
BETTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY WITH THE NAME.
OF AFFILIATION AND POSITION IN
OPPOSITION TO. FILE ITEM ONE AB
SIX SIXTY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX SIXTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER NINETY EACH
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NINETY THE
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME AND
PUTTING THAT'S REASONABLE
QUALITY AND TURN WITH CHIRLA
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY. RIGHT
THANK YOU THAT WILL BE NOTED WE
ARE AT THIS POINT TIME ASKING
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
SIX SIXTY- WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE MAKE NOTE AND- IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE.
LINED UP TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WOULD GO
AHEAD AND CALL THEM NOW. THANK
YOU LEGAL TO KEEP OUT FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX SIXTY- YOU
ARE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME-
LINE EIGHT FIVE WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU LINE EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING SIR MEMBERS
CAN REACH YOU AT TECHCONNECT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HONOR COMMENTS
AS WELL WITH COMP TIA WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING AND YOU
RECOMMENDED- AND OUR MEMBERSHIP
HAS AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO. WITH
YOUR- THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WE HAVE LINE FOR FIVE LINES
FORTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
SERRA HOPEFUL THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT- I APOLOGIZE FOR A
BIT LATE AND WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION OFFICIAL POSITION. ON
BUT YOU SEE IT CREATE THE
INTENT OF THE CELL AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR AN EFFORT TO
PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY AND
WE'RE STARTING TO GET
CONCERNED. FIELD AT THE MOMENT
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS THAT THE
LANGUAGE LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
DO I RECTIFICATION. AND
CONTAINMENT ACTIVITIES. PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND CONDUCT RESEARCH
YOU CAN EITHER THE IDENTIFY OR
CAN. ADA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION MADAM MODERATOR. THE
LINE EIGHTY NINE LINE EIGHT
NINETY AT THE LINE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COLLIER ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS INSULARITY AND
MADERA COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES WHAT. AND
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
YOU HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WOULD
YOU CHECK ONE MORE TIME TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO IT AB
SIX SIXTY. AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX SIXTY. YOU
MAY ENTER THE QUEUE BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN YOU MAY
JOIN THE PHONE QUEUE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO FOUR OPPOSITION OF
AB SIX SIXTY. IS THERE ANY NO
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SO THANK YOU TO ALL
THOSE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE FLOOR-
I'D LIKE TO CHOOSE THE POINT
OUT THAT IT. AS WE SEE WITH
THIS BILL AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHARLES BILL AFFECTED CONTACT
TRACING IS CRITICAL TO
SUCCESSFULLY BATTLING THIS
PANDEMIC WE NEED O IDENTIFY
AND CONTACT THOSE THAT ARE
INFECTED. FIGURE OUT WHO THEY
MIGHT HAVE EXPOSED AND ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE ALL QUARANTINING
AND SEEKING MEDICAL HELP IS
APPROPRIATE WE DO NOT TAKE THE
STEPS. WE ARE NOT GOING TO GAIN
THE UPPER HAND ON THIS PANDEMIC
I THINK IT IS AS SIMPLE AS
THAT. AND OF COURSE ONE OF THE
PRIMARY FACTORS FOR WHETHER A
METHOD OF CONTACT TRACING WILL
WORK IS THE PARTICIPATION AND
OPENNESS THE WILLINGNESS OF
PEOPLE TO GIVE THAT INFORMATION
MUCH OF IT VERY PERSONAL AND
PRIVATE INFORMATION. AS THE
OXFORD DOCTOR AND RESEARCHER
PUTS IT PUBLIC HEALTH IS ALL
ABOUT BUILDING TRUST. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT LAYING THE FOUNDATION
FOR TRUST IT'S SIMPLE
PROVISIONS ENSURETHE DATA THAT
IS COLLECTED THROUGH CONTACT
TRACING ISSUES FOR JUST THAT.
CONTACT TRACING. CALIFORNIANS
ARE GOING TO BE MORE APT TO
SHARE THIS INFORMATION AND
THEIR ASSOCIATIONS IF THEY KNOW
THAT IT IS SLOWLY BEING USED TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
NOT BE USED TO TARGET THEM OR
TO HELP THEM OR TO BE USED FOR
MATH MEANS THAT DENY THEM THEIR
PRIVACY AND THEIR SENSE OF
PERSONAL SECURITY AND WHILE
THERE MAY BE PRACTICAL DETAILS
TO CONTINUE TO BE WORKED OUT
AND WE HEARD ABOUT SOME OF THEM
HERE AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
THE- AUTHOR AND ARE COMMITTEE
STAFF ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS- THINGS LIKE
CONTACT TRACING IN PRISONS AND
JAILS WHERE WE'VE HAD
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS. I THINK
THE BILL'S A STRONG STEP
FORWARD- FOR PROTECTING OUR
PRIVACY AND ENSURING OUR
COMMUNITIES TRUST THIS CONTACT
TRACING PROCESS AND SO THAT'S
SORT OF WHERE I'M COMING FROM I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
MICROPHONES UP WE'LL START WITH
THE SENATOR BORCHERS THEN
SENATOR MELENDEZ AND THEN
SENATOR Y. CASKEY SENATOR
BORCHERS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE RIVER. YOU'RE
CERTAINLY MAKING A SPLASH. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
THINK I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT A- SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT POSITION I THINK- YOU
QUOTED THAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ABOUT TRUST. I WOULD SUBMIT TO
MY COLLEAGUES INTO THE PUBLIC.
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS ABOUT
RESPONSIBILITY. AND I FIND IT
VERY CHALLENGING TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY. GET EVERYONE TO
AGREE. THAT WE ARE IN A BONA
FIDE EMERGENCY. NOT ONLY IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA IN OUR NATION
BUT GLOBALLY. BUT THEN PUT
FORWARD RULES THAT PRESCRIBE
EXACTLY HOW WE ADAPT TO THE DOT
THE DYNAMIC SITUATION OF THIS
EMERGENCY. WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ADDITIONALLY IS. WE
HAVE AREAS OF THE STATE THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE MEDICAL PERSONNEL.
AND THE PERSON THE PERSONNEL
CORPS. TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
TYPE OF WORK THAT WE DEEM SO
IMPORTANT IN UNDERSERVED AND
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD NEED TO
INVOKE. INACTIVATE OTHER
RESOURCES OF THE STATE
SOMETIMES THAT COULD BE.
INDIVIDUALS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO I THINK I CAN BASED ON
EARLIER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT HAVE COME THROUGH. I
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD NORMALLY
BE CONCERNED ABOUT DISCLOSING
INFORMATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS A
RULE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHAT
WAS IT SB FIFTY FOUR. TWENTY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB FIFTY FOUR
DISALLOWED LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
SHARING INFORMATION- WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SUCH A WAY THAT
IT WOULD- PUT IN JEOPARDY THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS OR DISCLOSE
IT IN THAT IN THAT FASHION. SO
I GUESS IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
TACKLING THIS PANDEMIC. THEN WE
NEED TO ACTIVATE ALL THE
RESOURCES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN YES IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES THAT MAY
INCLUDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES WHERE IT'S TERRIBLY
RELEVANT. IN THEIR RELIED UPON
IN THOSE SITUATIONS. SO FOR
SERIOUS ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS DON'T HANDCUFF. THE
EFFORTS UNDER WAY THAT COULD BE
TERRIBLY USEFUL FOR US
OVERCOMING OUR SITUATION SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY
COLLEAGUES. THIS IS ALREADY
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED IN PRIOR
LEGISLATION. THE IDEA THAT YOU
WOULD STOP LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
PARTICIPATING AS NEEDED. LEAVE
IT UP TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES. THAT IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY WOULD NEED
TO RELY ON LAW ENFORCEMENT LET
THEM DECIDE. THE LEGISLATION
ALREADY EXISTS THAT PROTECTS.
ARE THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE FEARFUL THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. LITERALLY
SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE THAT
PERFECTLY THE WRONG TIME. DO
YOU WISH TO RESPOND TO THAT A
MERGER WAS A QUESTION BUT YOU
HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT- OR
WOULD YOU RATHER RESPOND TO IT
IN YOUR CLOSE OF ORANGE YEAH I
THINK YOUR ATTENTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION I
RESPONDED IN MY CLOTHES THANK
YOU- CENTER MELINDA'S. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE IT'S NICE TO SEE
YOU I. I WANT TO DOVETAIL ON
THE COMMENTS OF SENATOR BOARD
JUST AND I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
YOU. BECAUSE HE- BROUGHT UP A
VERY. GOOD POINT THAT SB FIFTY
FOUR. ALREADY PUT IN PLACE
MEASURES THAT WOULD DISALLOW.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM PART
FROM COMMUNICATING WITH FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR THE
PURPOSES. OF IMMIGRATION SO.
YOU HAVE IN THIS BILL EXCLUDED
THEM- GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
ALREADY. HAVE SOMETHING IN
PLACE TO DISALLOW THAT I'M-
JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHY YOU
SPECIFICALLY. EXCLUDED LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM YOUR BILL. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
ANSWER THAT. I WOULD ADDRESS
FOR MY CLOTHES THANK YOU
ALREADY YEAH NO NO NO NO THIS
S. NOW THIS IS NOT LIKE THIS.
THE FLOOR SESSION WHERE PEOPLE
CAN PRESENT THEIR BILL AND THEN
THE ANSWER SOMETHING OR NOT
ANSWER SOMETHING THEIR CLOTHES
THIS IS A COMMITTEE HEARING OR
WERE DEBATING BILLS AND WE'RE
BETTING THEM SO THAT WE CAN
DECIDE. WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
WORTHY OF MOVING FORWARD FOR
FULL SENATE VOTES ARE WOULD ASK
MADAM CHAIR THAT. THE MEMBER
ANSWER THE QUESTION OTHERWISE
HOW CAN WE POSSIBLY MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON THE BILL-
A POINT WELL TAKEN- THE IF THIS
IS PART OF A COLLOQUY RATHER
THAN A STATEMENT- THAT DOESN'T.
IT THAT ISN'T SEEKING THAT
INTERACTION THEN CERTAINLY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PLEASE ANSWER
PERHAPS THIS WILL LEAD TO SOME
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION AND IT
ISN'T JUST A STATEMENT. I HAVE
SOME EXPERIENCE HERE AND I
DON'T HAVE FAITH THAT THIS WILL
LEAD TO. SOME RABBIT HOLE- I DO
RESPECT THE QUESTION AND SHE'S-ASKING AND I DO INTEND TO
ADDRESS IT. I'M SORRY I MISSED
THE LAST PART OF IT I DO INTEND
TO ADDRESS IT BUT I'D LIKE TO
HEAR FOR EXHAUSTIVE CONCERNED
SO I CAN ADDRESS THEM AND HOLD.
WELL I THINK. AGAIN IT IS. THIS
IS A STRANGE PLACE TO BE
HAVING. A CONVERSATION USUALLY
WE DO IT IN A COMMITTEE ROOM.
AND I THINK A CONVERSATION IS-
IS WARRANTED IF THERE IS A
DESIRE TO- CONTINUE. IN THAT
FASHION AGAIN THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE I SEE AT LEAST.
BETWEEN MAKING A STATEMENT. AND
GOING THROUGH- AN INQUIRY. SURE
THANK YOU OKAY. ME PLEASE ASK
YOUR QUESTION AGAIN. WELL MY
QUESTION IS WHY WAS LAW
ENFORCEMENT SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDED FROM YOUR BILL GIVEN
THE FACT. THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
PASSED A LAW THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THEM FROM
COMMUNICATING AND COOPERATING
WITH FEDERALLAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
IMMIGRATION SURE THIS IS JUST
ONE SLICE OF WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION ATTEMPTS TO DO.
THAT LEGISLATION DOES MUCH MORE
THAN THAT AND PROTECTING DATA
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
UNDERGOING CONTACT TRACING. BUT
WHAT'S THE WHAT THE REAL GOAL
HERE IN CONTACT TRACING HAVING
IS HAVING A ROBUST SYSTEM. WE
HAD VERY FEW RULES OR
GUIDELINES WE'VE NEVER REALLY
DONE THIS BEFORE AT SCALE. AND
WITH THE TYPE OF EMERGENCY THAT
WE ARE UNDER. SO THE GOAL
SHOULD BE TO HAVE AS MUCH
PARTICIPATION. IN CONTACT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE SO WHY NOT
INCLUDE LAW ENFORCEMENT. SOON
THEY'RE NOT THE ONES. THAT WE
NEED TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION
FROM WE NEED TO HAVE
PARTICIPATION FROM THOSE WHO
EITHER HAVE CONTRACTED. OF THE
NINETEEN OR MAY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO COPE AT NINETEEN AND
EVERYTHING SHOWS US THAT THEY
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING IN A CONTACT
TRACING PROGRAM. THAT IS
ENGAGED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OKAY SIR MADAM CHAIR I WON'T
ASK ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE MEMBER I WILL JUST CONTINUE
WITH MY OWN COMMENTS AND I AM
VERY DISTURB FRANKLY THAT. THE
SUGGESTION HAS BEEN MADE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT NEED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN. INMATES
HAVE HAD TO HAVE BEEN RELEASED%
FROM OUR PRISONS BECAUSE OF A
COVERT OUTBREAK AND THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN THOSE INSTITUTIONS
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY AT RISK IMPACT I
WOULD ARGUE MORE SO. THEN SOME
OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
SO I REALLY I'M- I'M SHOCKED
THAT YOU WOULD SUGGEST THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEED NOT
PARTICIPATE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEED NOT BE
PROTECTED. AND THAT THEY ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM BECAUSE YOU THINK THAT
THEY MIGHT USE IT FOR PURPOSES
OF IMMIGRATION WHICH WE'VE
ALREADY SAID YOU CANNOT DO SO I
THINK THAT. WE'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF ALL THE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT'S
WHY WE'RE ALL WEARING MASKS AND
WE'RE SOCIALLY DISTANCING AND I
THINK WE OWE THAT TO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY IS WELL
TO PROTECT THEM TOO BUT TO SAY
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT
EVERY OTHER PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA EXCEPT YOU LAW
ENFORCEMENT I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S A HORRIBLE. MESSAGE TO
SEND AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
SOMETHING THAT I'M GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. UGH NEXT
WITNESS WAS SENATOR Y. CASKEY
AND I'LL HAVE A COMMENT ABOUT
THAT AT SOME POINT BUT CENTER
CASKEY THE FLOOR'S YOURS I KNOW
THAT THERE'S AMENDMENTS AND I
KNOW THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
PRACTICAL DETAILS. I WANT TO
HAVE A QUESTION MADAM CHAIR-
WITH REGARD TO. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS THE EMPLOYER PART OF THE
OBJECTION FOR THE OPPOSITION IS
SAID OKAY I GET IT THAT THE
GOAL SOMEBODY COMES TO THE JAIL
TO GO TO TREE SOUTH WHO THAT.
WHO THAT VISITOR WAS IN THEIR
CONTACTS IN THE PROPONENTS IN
THE- BASIS OF THIS BILLS
PROTECTIVE BUT- PROTECT THOSE
PEOPLE BUT- AS THE EMPLOYER WHO
PRESUMABLY THIS COMMUNITY HAS
BUILT SOME TRUST AMONGST.
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER OR MAYBE NO
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER EMPLOYERS.
WHAT IS THE- M. WELL. IS IT
TRUE THAT THIS WOULD PROHIBIT.
THE SHERIFF SAID THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS EMPLOYERS FROM
CONTACTING EMPLOYEES IN DOING
CONTRACT CONTRACT CREASING HIS
WITHIN THAT EMPLOYMENT.
COMMUNITY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE YES THANK YOU SO THE SO
WE ARE WORKING ON CONCERNS
AROUND THAT ISSUE AS WELL AS-
WITHIN OUR PRISONS IN JAIL SO
THERE THAT THAT IS WORK THAT IS
ONGOING I KNOW THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS WORKING ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THAT I ALSO WANT TO CLEAR UP-
WHAT WAS A CLOSE KNIT CHRISTMAS
REPRESENTS REPRESENTATION OF-
THE BILL- WHICH IS OF COURSE WE
WANT MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO PARTICIPATE IN CONTACT
TRACING IF THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED OR CONTRACTED OCTOBER
NINETEEN. AND THAT IS NOT OKAY
AND THAT IS NOT PART OF THE
BILL AND ALL THE OTHER
PROVISIONS SIXTY DAYS AND THAT
THAT THAT DATA ALL THAT.
APPLIES IT CAN I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS THAT ISSUE THERE WAS
ARTICULATED BY A CENTER
MELINDA'S WAS RAISED IN THE-
ANALYSIS AND THAT WITH AN
INDICATION THAT IS BEING WORKED
UPON. THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. BEING A SOMEONE WHO-
DOES THE CONTACT TRACING IN
GENERAL VERSUS AS AN EMPLOYER
WITH YOUR EMPLOYEES AND I THINK
THAT THAT. IS A LEGITIMATE
CONCERN THAT IS BEING ADDRESSED
BY THE AUTHOR NOW THE ISSUE IS.
MAKING THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE IN GENERAL. BUT FOR OTHER
THAN THEIR OWN NEEDS AS AN
EMPLOYER. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT. THE XP FOR FOUR
DOESN'T. NECESSARILY TAKE CARE
OF THE ISSUE ABOUT THE
INFORMATION BEING MADE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SADLY WE DO
KNOW. THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS TRYING TO
CIRCUMVENT- SB FIFTY FOUR SO
THIS WILL JUST. A TIGHT KNIT
UP. AND FOCUS ON THE ISSUE OF
CONTACT TRACING AND- ALSO THAT
THERE ARE ASSURANCES IN YOUR
CLOSER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU
WOULD COMMENT ON THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY SHERIFFS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS EMPLOYER.
DEALING WITH THE CONTACT
TRACING ISSUE THAT WOULD I
THINK US SOME. CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED WITH THAT
WE HAVE A SENATOR NUMBER DO YOU
HAVE YOUR BLUE HAND UP THERE
FLOOR'S YOURS. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ACT ACTUALLY THE
QUESTIONS NOW BEEN ASKED I
THINK I ANSWERED- ASPECTS OF
THE WHITE HOUSE. AND RESOLVED-
LEAST ABOUT RESOLVED ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
SENATOR STERN'S HAND UP BUT I
DID SEE CENTER GONZALEZ WILL
START WILL HAVE HER SPEAK AND
THEN SENATOR STERN- WILL LET
YOU CLOSE IT OUT. I JUST WANNA
SALAS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND- BEING FROM THE
LATINO CAUCUS AND SERVING A
VERY A LARGE LATINO POPULATION
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THIS. THIS BILL-
ESPECIALLY AS WE KNOW IT'S VERY
CLEARLY STATED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT LATINOS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED. BUT NOT ONLY THAT
WE'RE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND WE
NEED TO HAVE TRUST IN THE
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS ROBUST.
ALSO AS THE CHAIR OF THE
PANDEMIC COMMITTEE WE HAVE
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND CONTACT
TRACERS WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH WE
KNOW WE NEED FORTY THOUSAND
CONTACT TRACERS BUT AGAIN WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD TRUST
IN THESE COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT AFFECT. EFFECTIVELY
AND EFFICIENTLY- MANY OF FOLKS
ARE FEARING RETALIATION OR
RETRIBUTION AND WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
PASSES FOR THAT REASON. AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE YOU- WORKING I
KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO HAVE A ROBUST
SYSTEM AND THAT THERE IS- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRISONS AND
JAILS AND IN THOSE CONGREGATE
FACILITIES WHERE WE KNOW WE'RE
BEING. AFFECTED HERE IN THE
STATES SO JUST WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU MY GRATITUDE FOR
YOUR- FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ AND SENATOR STERN WILL
CLOSE IT OUT WITH YOU. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LONG BEACH
ABOUT THE- CRITICAL NATURE TO
GET SOME GUARDRAILS IN PLACE
AND BUILD TRUST WITH
COMMUNITIES SO WE ACTUALLY. CAN
GET TRACERS ENROLLED- PEOPLE
TRUSTING THE SYSTEM AND
HOPEFULLY NIPPING THESE
OUTBREAKS IN THE BUT BEFORE
THEY GET. MORE DEADLY THAN THEY
NEED TO BE- I DID WANT TO. JUST
GET YOUR CONFIRMATION THAT THE
AMENDMENTS AS I READ THEM- THE
MOST IMPORTANT PROVISION I'VE
SORT OF. KEYED IN ON FROM FROM
WHAT I'VE SEEN IN PRINT HERE IS.
THAT THERE THE BILL NOW DOWN IS
NOT BORROWER- SORT OF INTER
DEPARTMENTAL SHARING FOR
INSTANCE. SO LONG AS THE
CONTACT TRACING IS NOT USED TO
MAINTAIN OR DISCLOSE FOR ANY
PURPOSE OTHER THAN THE CONTACT
TRACING EFFORTS UP I THOUGHT
THAT. THAT CHANGE ACTUALLY PUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT GUARDRAILS
WHICH IS NO ONE'S GONNA USE
YOUR CONTRACT TRADE CONTACT
TRACING DATA FOR SOMETHING
OTHER THAN WHAT IT'S BEEN
COLLECTED FOR- BUT I ALSO I
WANTED TO TRY TO GET YOUR SENSE
WITH YOUR INTENT. TERMS THE
DEFINITION YOU USE FOR CONTACT
TRACING. AND HOW THAT DEALS
WITH THE CURRENT PROHIBITION ON
A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM
ENGAGING. IN CONTACT TRACING-
FIRM HOW I READ IT SAY A
HYPOTHETICAL OF A OF THE UC
CAMPUS- YOU HAVE A ALERT COMES
OUT- AND THERE'S BEEN AN
OUTBREAK AND STUDENTS IN SOME
PARTICULAR DORM ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE- SO
LONG IS THAT. THAT CAN'T POLICE
OFFICER ISN'T THE ONE ACTUALLY
DOING THE IDENTIFICATION AND
THE MONITORING OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AND THAT THAT THAT
IDENTIFICATION MONITORING WORK
IS BEING DONE BY INVEST IN THIS
CASE YOU KNOW THAT THAT
UNIVERSITY- THE BILL DOESN'T
SEEM TO BORROWER- LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM- ACTING FOR
INSTANCE AS AN AGENT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR
ASSISTING IN. STATE EVACUATING
A DORM OR DEALING WITH IT IT
GETS REALLY COMPLEX WHEN YOU
HAE AN OUTBREAK SO I DID I
JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
IT I DON'T READ I DON'T READ
THIS AS AN ALL OUT BAR FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT SORT OF BEING-
PERIPHERALLY ENGAGED WITH THE
ARCHITECTURE BUT BUT NOT. THAT
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE
IDENTIFIER AND THE MONITOR
BECAUSE I DO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING THEM
OUTSIDE OF THEIR OWN SCOPE OF
EMPLOYMENT AND THEIR WARSHIP-
DUTIES- HAVING THAT BE THERE
THERE THEM IS SORT OF THE PRIME
ACTOR HE COULD YOU JUST YOU CAN
DO IT IN YOUR CLOTHES OR OR NOW
BUT I. I WANTED TO GET YOUR
SENSE IN THAT HYPOTHETICAL. DO
YOU INTEND FOR THAT. YOU KNOW
THERE'S NEVER TO DORM CONNECT
POLICE OFFICER GROUP HELP WITH
THAT EFFORT OF IT AS LONG AS
THEY'RE NOT THE MAIN IDENTIFIER
AND MONITOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN AND IF YOU WOULD ADDRESS
THAT THE SINGH NO OTHER- MIKE'S
UP SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE AND ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AS
WELL. WE SHOULD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
FOR YOUR QUESTION THAT
DOVETAILS- YOU MIGHT NOT THINK
IT DOVETAILS WITH DETAILS A
LITTLE BIT IN INTO- THE
CONCERNS I UNDERSTAND AND- I
THAT WERE ALSO RAISED BY
SENATOR PORGES. OF COURSE YOU
WANT TO PRESERVE THE ABILITY
FOR PEACE OFFICERS TO DO THEIR
JOB- AND- I'M VERY GLAD TO HEAR
FROM YOU SEE AND OTHERS- THAT
HER HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO COORDINATE- IN- IN
THE RULES THAT THEY DO- THAT
ALSO PRESERVES THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEY HAVE.
WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE RESOURCES
ARE THERE. FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND SWORN PEACE OFFICERS TO
PLAY THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
THEY PLAY EVERY DAY. THEY ARE.
NECESSARY BUT ALSO EXPENSIVE
RESOURCES. CONTACT TRACING DOES
NOT NEED TO USE THE SAME-
RESOURCES. AND ALSOCAN BENEFIT
FROM- FROM TRUST BUILT OUT. ON
BECAUSE OF. THAT THEY'RE NOT
INVOLVED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND SO WE KNOW DESPITE. SB
FIFTY FOURTH PASSAGE THAT THERE
STILL IS A GREAT DEAL OF
MISTRUST- IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES- TOWARDS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND- AND SO WE
DON'T WANT THAT TO BE A BARRIER.
TO ROBUST CONTACT TRACING AND I
HOPE THAT THAT- DOES ANSWER
QUESTIONS WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK. WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS. AND INTO
YOUR POINT ABOUT PRISONS MADAM
CHAIR. THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON- SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC AND
SADLY WE HAD. ONE PRISON GUARD
AT SAN QUENTIN SUCCUMB TO- CODE
NINETEEN JUST THIS PAST WEEKEND
WE LEARNED TODAY OF ANOTHER
PRISON STAFF MEMBER AT FOLSOM
WHO PASSED AWAY SADLY INTO WHAT
APPEARS TO BE ANOTHER OUTBREAK
OF COVER NINETEEN AT. YET
ANOTHER STATE PRISON AT FOLSOM.
AND SO WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO PROTECT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS NO MATTER WHERE
THEY ARE IN CALIFORNIA. OUR
STEADFAST FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITH THAT-
MADAM CONSULTANT. HOLD ON ONE
SECOND. MOVE THE BILL YES WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY- CENTER WHERE
I. CAL SKI THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR MAKING THAT MOTION I'M
STILL HAVING A LITTLE TROUBLE
ORIENTING I'M MORE CUSTOM TO
PRESIDING OVER THE FLOOR
SESSIONS THAN A COMMITTEE
SESSION HERE SO. MARYA ON OF
INTUITIVE REACTIONS OR IN NEED
OF A LITTLE HELP HERE AND MY
APOLOGIES SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE COW SKI.
SORRY US SENATOR STERN- DO YOU
HAD I THOUGHT YOU WERE DONE
BUT- OBVIOUSLY HAVE- ANOTHER
QUESTION- SO PLEASE FEEL FREE.
I'M SO SORRY MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WAS TRYING TO GET A MORE
DEFINITIVE ANSWER- WAS THAT I
COULDN'T GET IF THAT WAS A YES
OR NO. IN THAT IN THAT
HYPOTHETICAL. INTENT TO THE
AUTHOR I HEARD THAT. I INTERNET
USERS. CAN USE YES- YOUR
QUESTION SO IF I'M READING YOUR
QUESTION CORRECTLY IS YES THAT
THE IT WOULD HAVE THOSE
ABILITIES THAT WOULD NOT BE
ENGAGED IN. CONTACT TRACING
DATA COLLECTION- ONE ON ONE
WITH THE PERSON WHO HAS BEEN
EXPOSED AND SO THEREFORE. IF
THAT IS MY INTERPRETATION OF
THE QUESTION. THAT IS CORRECT.
AFFIRMATIVELY YES VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU ALL
GREAT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SEEING THE BLUE HAND GO DOWN WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITEHOUSE SKI THE MOTION IS.
DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE- MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL- SO IF SENATORS COULD
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SIX SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. JACKSON HI JACK HI
BORJAS THE- FOURTEENTH NO. DID
ASAL. GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
MELENDEZ NO MELENDEZ NO MONNING
NINE MONNING AYE STERN. YOUR
NINE. STERN BY- BURKE I. I
THINK YOU HAVE TO SAY YOUR NAME
SIR MARGAI THANK YOU- BURKE I
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHITE HOUSE
GATE I. SIX ZERO ZERO. THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIXTY TWO WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE THE MEASURE
WORKING MEMBERS THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT OF FILE ITEM. WILL BE FILE
ITEM FOR AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAU
BEING PRESENTED TODAY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAU IS. OF ILL TODAY
AND NOT ABLE TO PRESENT HIS OWN
BILL BUT WE DO HAVE THE CHAIR
OF ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- MR STONE THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
AND AN MEMBERS FIRST ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING AND YOUR
STAFF WORKING WITH THEM ON THIS
VERY. IMPORTANT BILL BUT IT BUT
ULTIMATELY VERY NARROW BILL
DEALING WITH CONTACT TRACING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD CHAIRS THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE SO THIS IS
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT TO HIM. AND YES
CONTACT TRACING IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO DEAL WITH
THE PANDEMIC AND ULTIMATELY
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
MANAGE THE RISKS THAT ARE HERE.
AND I THINK WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE ALL THE APPROPRIATE
METHODS OF CONTACT TRACING THAT
ARE POSSIBLE INCLUDING THE USE
OF TECHNOLOGY AND THIS BILL IS
APPROACH IS. DEALING WITH
TECHNOLOGY ASSISTED CONTACT
TRACING AND ALL IT REALLY DOES
IS PROVIDE SOME LIMITATIONS. ON
THE USE OF THE TECHNOLOGY BY
REQUIRING AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT
FOR THE COLLECTION USE
MAINTENANCE AND DISCLOSURE OF
AN INDIVIDUAL DATA THROUGH
THESE APPLICATIONS. INCORPORATE
THE BUSINESS INCORPORATES THE
CONCEPT OF DATA MINIMIZATION SO
THAT IT ENSURES THAT IF AN APP
IS BEING USED IT FOR CONTACT
TRACING IT IS BEING USED ONLY
FOR CONTACT TRACING. AND
NOTHING BEYOND. ANYTHING THAT
THAT IS OTHERWISE REASONABLY
NECESSARY TO REVIVE
TECHNOLOGICALLY ASSISTED
CONTACT TRACING AND THEN
PROHIBITS ANY DISCRIMINATION OR
PENALTY BASED ON WHETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL PARTICIPATES IN THIS
TECHNOLOGY ASSISTED CONTACT
TRACING SO SOMEONE IS NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE
APPLICATION WITH THE DATA BEING
COLLECTED THEY CAN OPT OUT AND
NOT THEN BE PENALIZED FOR THAT
THERE ARE NO LIMITATIONS ON
OTHER TYPES OF CONTACT RACING
THERE'S NO LIMITATIONS ON THE
ABILITY TO GATHER AND MANAGE
THE DATA THAT'S ULTIMATELY
NECESSARY. BU THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT WILL HELP
FACILITATE THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY APPLICATIONS IN
CONTACT TRACING AND ENSURE THAT
IT IS BEING DONE IN A WAY THAT
DOES NOT. PUT ANYONE'S PRIVATE.
DATA AT AT RISK OF PRIVACY AT
RISK. SO AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
THIS IS AN AUTHOR SPONSORED
BILL I PRESENT. TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENTED HERE TODAY THERE ARE
TWO LEAD WITNESSES MAUREEN
MAHONEY FROM CONSUMER REPORTS.
AND NEED A WIDER FROM THE A RP
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE- WE
HAVE TWO KEY WITNESSES MAIN
WITNESSES YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES JUST DEPENDING UPON HOW
YOU WISH TO DIVIDED. AND IF WE
COULD START WITH THE- MS
MAHONEY IS SHE ON THE LINE.
YEAH AFTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY POLICY
ANALYST THE CONSUMER REPORTS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO TO PROTECT
THE PRIVACY OF INFORMATION
COLLECTED PURSUANT TO
TECHNOLOGIES THAT THE CONTACT
TRACING APPS. THIS WILL HELP
INSURE THAT THEY HAVE IF THEY
ARE INTRODUCING CALIFORNIA WILL
BE SAFER AND MORE EFFECTIVE FOR
EXAMPLE AND LET THE MAJORITY
CONSUMER UC'S OUT. THEY'LL BE
MUCH USEFUL IN HELPING TO
CONTAIN CODE NINETEEN. ROLLED
OUT NOW SURVEY DATA SUGGESTS
THAT TOO MANY CONSUMERS WILL BE
CONCERNED ABOUT POTENTIAL
PRIVACY HARMS TO PARTICIPATE.
ABOUT HALF OF AMERICANS WITH
SMARTPHONES PROBABLY OR
DEFINITELY WOULD NOT USE THE
THAT. IN LARGE PART DUE TO. THE
POTENTIAL THREAT. POSED TO
CONSUMER PRIVACY. WATER MAKING
SEEN WHETHER STATE OF. WILL AND
WILL THESE UP CONSUMERS NEED TO
CRY. AND SECURE. IN PLACE SO
THAT THERE'S NO GAP IN
PROTECTIONS. IF IT ALL OUT
QUICKLY ALREADY IN OTHER
COUNTRIES IS INFORMATION
COLLECTED THROUGH THESE OUT. IF
YOU THINK COURTS OF WAYS SUCH
AS TO ORPHALI QUARANTINE OR
OTHERWISE LIMIT THE ACTIVITY OF
USERS DESPITE THE THREAT. OF
FALSE POSITIVE. THIS WILL HELP
INSURE THAT. PERSON INTERESTED
UP DEVELOPING TO MARKETING.
WILL BE PROTECTIVE THE SOUTH OF
THE STRONG STANDARD OF DATA
MINIMIZATION OF ANY COLLECTION
SHARING MAINTENANCE AND
DISCLOSURE OF DATA TO ITS
RECENTLY OP. NECESSARY TO
OPERATE THE SERVICE. THIS MEANS
I CAN VIEW MY PRIVACY. IS
ENSURED BY DEFAULT RATHER THAN
LEAVING IT TO THE CONSUMER TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXERCISE
THEIR PRIVACY PREFERENCES. OF
COURSE NOT EVERY CONSUMER WOULD
WANT TO SUBJECT THEMSELVES THE
DATA COLLECTION IN THE FIRST
PLACE SO APPROPRIATELY CONSENT
FOR USE AS REQUIRED. OFTEN IS
IMPORTANT TO CIRCUMVENT. OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH THE TCPA.
COCKTAIL MODEL HAS BEEN THAT.
SOME COMPANIES ARE PUTTING. UP
IT IS A STRONG NOT. PROVISION
TO HELP ENSURE THE CONSUMER
HAVE A MEANINGFUL CHOICE. AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT TO PURCHASE.
ADDITIONALLY WE THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR OF
TO STRENGTHEN. INCLUDE IN THIS
BILL. THIS FROM CONSUMER
IMPORTANT PARTY. AND WE ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEXT
WITNESSNINO LAS FROM A RP
ABOUT TWO MINUTES AND TEN
SECONDS. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BILL WHILE ON WELFARE
HE THE MORNING TERABYTES TERRA.
I'M QUITE PLEASED WITH. THE
FROM THE TOP OF A THREE POINT
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIA
NUMBERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
NINETEEN HAS AFFECTED ALL OF US
I DIDN'T HAVE BEEN HELD
IMPOSSIBLE CALIFORNIA. AB
SEVENTY DIGITAL WILL ENABLE THE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY TO COMBAT THE
PANDEMIC WHILE ENSURING THAT
PROPERTY ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT. THE PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS. I THOUGHT HE NOTED
THAT CAN ONLY GET. YEAH ONE OF
THE- YOU. ONE WAY TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE WILL DOWNLOAD AND
USE THE- IS THE EMPLOYMENT OF
STRAW CREDIT THE MEASURE WHICH
IS. TRUST THE- IN THE OTHER
IMPORTANT POPULATION WHAT
AFFECTED BY COCA NINETY.
ELDERLY THE ECONOMIC DOESN'T.
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR THE PROTECTION ARE
CLOSELY YOU FOR THE POPULATION
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE I CAN I ALL. VANITY
FAIR AND OTHER NEEDS GOVERNOR.
THEY ARE GENERALLY THE ONLY
THING TO BE WITH COMPLEX ONE
AND- THE REQUIRED TO. THOSE
FORTY. THERE ARE ALSO BY ABLE
TO OUR PROFESSIONAL. ASSISTANCE
TO ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE. I
WON'T NOT ALLOW REFUGE FROM
SUPPORT SYSTEM WE DO AREAS FOR
HER THE- BUDGET FOR THE- FROM
THAT ALLOW. TO BELIEVE THAT.
STILL THERE IF YOU THAT SOME OF
THE KAY NOTHING. DATA COLLECT
TECH. BECOME ACTIVE. IN
CALIFORNIA TO BRING MORE ABOUT
PROTECTIONS PEOPLE. ALL. ONE
TWELVE SEEING NO ONE IN THAT
ROOM WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE PHONES. AND TO. WE WILL-
ASK- THE MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO WE
WILL BEGIN. ADRIN GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN EACH QUEUE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD IF YOU ARE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE HE MAY
NEED TO PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
AGAIN. FOR SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EQ YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD LINE FORTY ONE THE LINE IS
HELPING YOU MAY GO AHEAD. BACK
A CREAMER MEMBER ON THE
HAPPENED THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
ONE ONE ZERO NINE ONE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEBERS OF THE SNAPPER
OUT ON ME AFTER THE ENGINEERS
AND SCIENTISTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND COLLEGE AS YOU KNOW THE
LETTER IN SUPPORT WE WILL BE
SUPPORTING EIGHTY SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT PLEASE. NINE
ONE ELEVEN LINE AT ONE ONE
EIGHT ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACCORDING WITH
CORPORATE AND CRAIG ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
ALL IMPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE LINE AT ONE ONE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS AND
RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN LINE
AT ONE ONE TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THE LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU
ARE A THE OF THE HEALTH
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS THIS IS.
ACTIONS ARE IMPORTANT FOR AS
WELL INCOME SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D IN CAR ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. YES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN ET Q.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO. I HAVE NO ENSURING UP
THANK YOU WITH NO MORE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION- I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A SHOW OF THE
MOHAMMED. FROM THE CALCHAMBER
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AS WELL AS LARA CURTIS
FROM COMPTIA- OF IN THE LOOP Q.
WHEN THE OPPOSITION LINE IS
THAT CORRECT MADAM MODERATOR.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD WITH A
MISTER MOHAMMED. S. R. FOR
SWEETNESS AGAIN BETWEEN THE
BOTH OF THE STATE WITNESSES YOU
HAVE FOUR MINUTES SO PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
MAIN SWAT MUHAMMAD AL CHAMBER
WE'RE OPPOSED TO I. EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO AT THE
OUTSET OF PORTENT ANOTHER
CONTACT TRACING DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC IS A CRITICAL PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFETY WITH AN IMPORTANT
PRIVACY COMPONENT. IT'S NOT A
PRIVACY ISSUE IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH COMPONENT WE HAVE NO
TREATMENT FOR KOBE CONTACT
TRACING NEXT TO TESTING SOCIAL
DISTANCING ACCORDING TO ONE OF
THE TOOLS WE'VE GOT WE CAN'T
QUARANTINE EVERYONE TESTING AND
ONGOING ISSUE AND THEREFORE
CONTACT TRACING THE BEST WE
HAVE CLOSED AND- MANUAL
CONTACTING IS. IT TAKES DAYS
REGION BACK IN PERSON REQUIRES
YOU TO DISCLOSE PERSONAL
INFORMATION TO A STRANGER
WORKING FOR THE GOVERNMENT
WITHOUT DISCLOSURES AND WITHOUT
KNOWING WHO WILL SEE IT WORKS
OR HOW LONG IT WILL PROTECT THE
ADVANTAGE TO VISUAL CONTACT
TRACING A SIMPLE IT SAVES LIVES
BUT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TO WORK
AS AN EFFECTIVE PROHIBITION
AGAINST THE USE OF CONTACT
TRACING TECHNOLOGIES. WITH
COMPLEX AND THEY PROVISIONS
ALLOWING FOR ITS USE IN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES GIVEN CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET INCLUDING
THE SURRENDER OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND ALL INVENTIONS TO
THE GOVERNOR. AND EVEN THE
NONPROFIT THAT'S COOL
UNIVERSITY READ A PUBLIC ENTITY
SATISFIED THESE NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES IT WOULD STILL BE
SUBJECT TO COSTLY LITIGATION
INCLUDING ATTORNEY'S FEES WHICH
CAN BE AWARDED INTO QUESTIONS
ONE VIOLATIONS DID NOT EVEN
RESULT IN THE DISCLOSURE OF
DATA. AN ENTITY CAN'T. EVEN
SEND AN EXPLOSION LOCATION
UNLESS IT'S APPROVED BY A CHAIN
OF COMMAND SET FORTH UNDER THE
BILL AND THIS CREATES A
LEGITIMATE INTANGIBLE DETERRENT
FOR USING THIS TECHNOLOGY AT
ALL. FURTHER THE BILL ENABLES
ENFORCEMENT OR CIVIL ACTION BY
THE AGP ANYTHING IT TURNING OR
THE VISUALS THIS IS BROADER
THAN WHAT IS. ALLOWED UNDER
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. WE
DFI CLAIM IT LIMIT TO JUST THAT
JURISDICTION OF THE CAN BE AND
YOU. ANOTHER IN THE TO THAT THE
OR SOME. CLAIM WELL THE MALL
AND FOR ACTIONS THE SAME
VIOLATION AND TO RECEIVE YOUR-
THE BUSINESS OF. BECAUSE I
DON'T. HOW ANNUAL SHOULD BE TO.
AMONG AGENTS WHICH EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BILLS OF ALL OF OUR-
WHICH COULD LEAD TO MORE. AGE
RUN INTO IN. THE BILL FIRST
RECOVERY DAMAGE. SO WE WILL
THAT THERE A PATH THAT IS BEING
THE POKE PUBLIC AND KEEP THE
CURRENT BURGEONING AB SEVEN.
EIGHTY TWO JUST DOESN'T A CHEAP
BALANCE AND ALL THREATENED THE
SAFETY. GUARD STATE THESE ARE
JUST FEW THE RE THAT WE HAVE.
THEM THANK FOR THE TIME THAT I.
THANK YOU I GUESS YOU'RE TO
THANK YOU MISTER. YOU ABOUT
MINUTE AND. FOR FIVE. THANK YOU
MAY CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE-
MY NAME. CORRECT AND HERE I
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING.
INDUSTRY WE ARE RESPECT OPPOSED.
SEVEN EIGHTY. I WOULD LIKE TO
BE THREE IN. POINTS FIRST WOMAN
TO DISCUSS. ABOUT THE BILL
FOCUS ON PRIVACY THE BILL'S
ACTUALLY ABOUT WHETHER
CALIFORNIA CAN CYCLE THAT AND
SAY BY. KOBE NINETY HAD
OBVIOUSLY WRECKED HAVOC ON OUR
STATE SCHOOLS ARE CLOSE TO
DOUBLE BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
DECIMATED. FOR NEARLY FIVE
MONTHS CALIFORNIA HAS ALL BUT
SHUT DOWN. CALIFORNIA HAD TO
PASS THE DENTAL OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND DEATHS DUE TO COVERT
NINETEEN. CONTACT TRACING AS MR
MUHAMMAD SAID IS ONE OF THE
ONLY TOOLS WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
FIGHTING THE VIRUS. TO DATE
THERE IS NO VACCINE AND THERE
IS NO CURE. SECOND AB SEVENTY
TWO DID NOT DISTINGUISH CONTACT
TRACING WITHIN THE EMPLOYMENT
CONTEXT EMPLOYERS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP THEIR WORKERS
SAFE. THIS BILL HINDERS THE
EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO TAKE
PROPER SAFEGUARDS IN OUR
WORKPLACES. AND CREATE POWERFUL
DISINCENTIVES FROM EVEN
ATTEMPTING TO DO SO BECAUSE OF
THE POTENTIAL RISK OF THAT.
ASHTRAY DAMAGES AND CLASS
ACTION LITIGATION. FOR EXAMPLE
THE BILL DISCRIMINATION
LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF OUR ACTIONS
LIKE MOVING AN EMPLOYEE WHO
CHOOSES NOT PARTICIPATE IN TACT.
A LOWER RISK AREA AN ELDERLY
HOME OR PROHIBITING THE
EMPLOYEES FROM WORKING UNTIL
THEY'VE QUARANTINED.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ALLOWS
EMPLOYEES TO OPT OUT OF CONTACT
READING PROGRAMS ANYTIME.
THEREBY PREVENTING PROMPT
WARNING TO OTHER WORKERS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
SOMEONE WHO HAS TESTED
POSITIVE. THIRD AB SEVENTY TWO
COMPLEX IS CURRENTLY BURNING
POINT LOSS WORKPLACE SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AND DIRECTLY
CONTRADICT RECENT GUIDANCE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE TEACHERS
WORKPLACE KIND CONSTRUCTION FOR
YEARS TO DEVELOP MECHANISMS.
FOR TRACKING SUSPECT SUSPECTED
AND CONFIRMED CASES OF INFECTED
EMPLOYEES. I EAT CONTACT
TRACING. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES THE BUSINESS TO DELETE
ANY DATA COLLECTED PURSUANT TO
TAX WITHIN THIRTY SIXTY DAYS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE MYRIAD OF
IMPLEMENT DOCUMENT RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL FAILS
TO CONSIDER. FOR EXAMPLE INPUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
WE'VE GONE EVEN THE TIME TERRY
DEPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. AND
WITH THAT- LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE. IN THE- BILL HERE A- ON
THE FLOOR. TO SEE. IN THE
CHAMBER IS NO. IN ROOM ONE.
THERE IS NO ONE BRING IT TO THE
FULL LINES MADAM. WOULD YOU K.
UP. THOSE WHO WISH. TO A
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO AGAIN NAME
AFFILIATION IN OPPOSITION ONLY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE END IS
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY QUEUE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER. FORTY FIVE
NINE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR IN MEMORY THIS IS
BERROCAL WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. OF THE WAFFLER ON
DISABILITY WELL AND DO NOT
HAVE. AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT
YOU CAN'T CREATE THE INTENT OF
THE BILL AND THANK THE AUTHOR.
OR HIS EFFORTS PROTECT CONSUMER.
AND MY CONCERNS OF THE LANGUAGE
AND ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
TO RESOLVE THEM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO THAT WAS A SORT OF
TWEENER. OF THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR I GUESS WE DIDN'T IDENTIFY
TWEENER SO IF YOU. ARE IN
BETWEEN PLEASE THIS WOULD BE
YOUR TIME TO SPEAK AS WELL BUT
THIS IS PRIMARILY OPPOSITION.
TO AB TWELVE EXCUSE ME
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. AHMED A
MODERATOR NEXT BIGGER PLACE.
YES IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OR A TWEENER YOU MAY
GET INTO THE QUEUE BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
NEVER EASY LINE EAT ZERO THE
LINE IS OPEN. BURKE WITH HELP
OF THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA.
HAS AND CONCERNS BASED ON THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
HAD TIME. TO THE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU NEXT WHAT PLEASE. WHY
NUMBER ONE HOW AND NINE LINE
ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JUSTIN HIGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP IN THE US RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE FIFTY
TWO LINE FIVE TO THE LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN COMING
UP TO THE NATIONAL PAYROLL
REPORTING CONSORTIUM IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASON
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLACE. LINE FIFTY ONE LINE AT
FIVE ONE WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ONE
BIGELOW THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
LINE AT ONE ONE SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CAME IN A MEETING WITH
TECH THAT TECHNIP HAS IMPOSED
POSITION TO EIGHTY SEVEN. YEAH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO OR IF YOU ARE EACH
CLEANER YOU MAY I JOIN THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
NUMBER WAS THE FIRST ONE TO PUT
HIS HAND UP OR MICROPHONE UP WE
WILL START WITH SENATOR NUMBER.
THEN SENATOR BORCHERS AND THEN
CENTER MONNING SO SENATOR
BORCHERS OF EXCUSE ME UNDER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IN IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE- PERHAPS WELL IF YOU CAN
RESPOND THE QUESTION GREAT IF
NOT PERHAPS ONE OF THE
PROPONENTS. SO THIS IS THIS IS
A CLASSIC CASE WERE BOUNCING
VALUES THE- POLICY THE VALUE IN
PRIVACY VERSUS OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE WORK FORCE STAYS
HEALTHY SO. HYPOTHETICALLY IF.
AN EMPLOYEE SAYS YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO CONSENT TO MY
INFORMATION BEING DISSEMINATED
ANY SHAPE. OR FORM- AND I EVEN
DON'T WANT TO TELL YOU WHETHER
OR NOT I HAVE CLOTHES THAT ARE
NOT UP. WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
WORK FORCE IF YOU SUSPECT THAT
PERSON IS CALLED IT DO YOU NEED
TO HAVE ALL THE OTHER ORKERS
ISOLATE THEMSELVES YOU ISOLATE
THAT PERSON HOW DOES THAT
HAPPEN. YEAH YEAH. THE EMPLOYEE
DOESN'T PROVIDE CONSENT THAT'S
ITEM ONE AND ITEM TWO IS IT. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT. WHEN YOU
BECOME AN EMPLOYEE THAT YOU YOU
DON'T GIVE UP- CERTAIN RIGHTS
OR CERTAIN CONDITIONS OF
EMPLOYMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE USE
OF YOUR COMPUTER SHOWING UP AT
A CERTAIN TIME- OBSERVING
WORKPLACE DECORUM THAT THAT
YOU- UNDERSTANDING YOUR
EMPLOYMENTS CONDITION UPON ALL
THOSE. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO IF
YOU COULD RESPOND IF NOT PRESS
ONE OF. THE STATE THANK YOU
CEREMONY TICKET TAKE A CRACK AT
THAT A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING RELEASED BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF. WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IT IT'S TALKING ABOUT ONE
PARTICULAR TOOL FOR CONTACT
TRACING. NOT THE MULTIPLE
MEASURES THAT THAT NEED TO BE
USE IN ORDER TO ULTIMATELY DO
CONTACT TRACING. AND I OPTED.
HERE ARE MERELY AN EMPLOYEE
BEING ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE APPLICATION. AND SAYING I
DON'T WANT TO USE THAT
APPLICATION BECAUSE OF THE
IMPLICATIONS IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF THE APPS THAT ARE BEING
USED FOR CONTACT TRACING. SOME
OF THEM. ARE ASKING FOR
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION THAT WE DON'T
NORMALLY GIVE TO OUR EMPLOYERS
A LOT OF IT BEING HEALTH
INFORMATION. WHERE YOU GO WHEN
YOU'RE NOT ON THE PREMISES. WHO
YOU'RE INTERACTING WITH WHEN
YOU'RE NOT ON THE PREMISES.
NONE OF THE BILL THE COMPANY
THE ORGANIZATION'S BUSINESS.
AND YET. IN FOR AN APP TO BE
LOADED ON SOMEBODY'S PHONE. OR
EVEN ON A COMPANY PHONE. THAT
IS THEN BEING ALLOWED TO BE
TAKEN OFF PROMISES AND USED.
WITH SOME. PERSONAL INFORMATION
AND THAT. HAVING AN APPLICATION
THAT MAY. GO BEYOND WHAT THAT
EMPLOYEES EXPECTATIONS ARE THAT
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
FACILITATE HERE. THAT THERE
COULD BE VERY SIMPLE
APPLICATIONS. THAT THERE COULD
BE VERY COMPLEX APPLICATIONS
AND WHAT THE BILL IS TRYING TO
DO. IS JUST ASK FOR THAT
CONSENT TO BE ABLE TO DOWNLOAD
THAT APPLICATION AND PUT IT ON
THE PHONE. AND THEN ENSURE THAT
THAT THAT THAT APPLICATION IS
AS RESTRICTED AS POSSIBLE. BUT
THAT THAT ULTIMATELY BECOMES
FAIRLY NEBULOUS IS RESTRICTED
POSSIBLE JUST TO. DO CONTACT
TRACING BUT WHAT THIS BILL IS
NOT TRYING TO DO IS LIMIT WHAT
DOES THAT MEANS IT'S JUST
TRYING TO SAY THAT THAT YOU
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
NOT ASKING FOR ANYTHING BEYOND
WHAT'S NECESSARY FOR CONTACT
TRACING NOW. THE APPLICATION
COULD ASK FOR SYMPTOMS. WHICH
IS AGAIN HEALTH INFORMATION IT
IF IT'S VOLUNTEERED BY THE
EMPLOYEE THAT'S A WAY AROUND
HIM FOR PROTECTION. BUT YET
IT'S A PART OF THE APPLICATION.
SO OFTEN PLOY HE THAT IS THINK
I DON'T WANT TO DOWNLOAD THE
APPLICATION. THEY'RE STILL
SUBJECT TO THE QUESTIONS TO THE
CONTACT RACING TO EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SUBJECT TO. AN AND- IF THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SEPARATED IF
THERE'S QUARANTINES THAT'S
THAT'S WELL BEYOND REALLY WHAT.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND SO
FOCUSING ON ON. THE APPLICATION
HERE. AND RECOGNIZING THAT IT
IS A TOOL. BUT IS IT IT'S A
TOOL THAT COULD PROLIFERATE
INFORMATION WELL BEYOND WHAT
THE EMPLOYER WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE A RIGHT TO. WHAT THE
EMPLOYER WOULD REALLY NEED FOR
WHAT THE EMPLOYEES EXPECTATIONS
ARE. THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
LIMITATION AS I SEE THIS AS A
TOOL. TO FACILITATE
APPLICATIONS. AND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL SEE APPLICATIONS IN THIS
SPACE BUT MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE NOT ABUSED AND THAT THEY'RE
NOT. UNNECESSARILY TAKING THAT
THE DATA OF AN EMPLOYEE AND
PUTTING IT TO OTHER USE. AND
THANK. I ASK FOLLOW PLEASE
PLEASE DO. I'M SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT AND I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN WITH FOR EXAMPLE
GEOLOCATION OUTSIDE THE
WORKPLACE. BUT IN THIS TIME OF
CRISIS IT DOES SEEM TO ME THAT
THAT WE WANT TO BE AS-
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE
PARTICULARLY IN WORK PLACES
WITH LARGE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
THAT WE CAN DO CONTACT TRACING
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT EMPLOYEE- DOES
HAVE SOME OF HIS OR HER PRIVACY
RIGHTS- IMPACTED THE THAT THIS
MAY BE A TIME WHERE WE NEED TO
DO STUFF BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT.
UP I HAVE I HAVE CONCERNS
STRONG CONCERNS. IN APPRECIATE
THAT AND I THINK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS VERY WILLING TO WORK
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE AND MAKE
SURE THAT SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS TO GET ADDRESSED
BECAUSE AGAIN I BELIEVE MISTER
CHARLES GOALS NOT TO PROHIBIT
THE APPS OR MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO WORK. BUT TO SET A
CLEAR EXPECTATION FOR THE
EMPLOYEE WHEN THEY DOWNLOAD
THAT APP WHEN THAT HAPPENS
TRACKING THEM. AND IT IN PLACES
THAT THAT IN IN WAYS THAT THEY
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE OTHERWISE
THE ANTICIPATED. AND I THINK
IT'S A DANGEROUS ROAD TO STEP
DOWN AND I KNOW WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO DO CONTACT
TRACING. BUT BECAUSE OF THE
POWER OF THESE DEVICES AND
THEIR ABILITY. TO COLLECT
MANAGE AND DISTRIBUTE
INFORMATION FAIRLY BROADLY.
INCLUDING IF IT IS A THIRD
PARTY. APPLICATION THAT
EMPLOYER NOW IS ASKING TO BE
DOWNLOADED ON SOMEBODY'S. PHONE
IF THAT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE APP PROVIDER AND THE
EMPLOYER OR ARE NOT CLEAR
ENOUGH. THEN THAT DATA CAN GO.
WHO KNOWS WHERE IT COULD IN
FACT BE OWNED BY THE
APPLICATION. AND THE
APPLICATION DEVELOPER AND THEIR
COMPANY RATHER THAN EVEN THE
EMPLOYER. SO IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S CLEAR THEN YES
I WOULD EXPECT A LOT I WOULD
CERTAINLY NOT WANT TO SIGN UP
FOR THAT. BUT I WOULD WANT TO
HAVE THE OPTION TO BUY A PLAYER
CAME TO ME AND SAID WE WANT TO
YOU CONTACT TRACING THIS IS ONE
OF THE TOOLS WE WANT TO USE.
TAKE A LOOK AT IT IF YOU THINK
WE'VE DONE A GOOD ENOUGH JOB.CONSENT TO IT AND THN WE CAN
COVER THAT GROUND IF NOT THE
EMPLOYER MAY NEED TO DO. TO
AUGMENT THE APPLICATION. FOR
THOSE WHO DO NOT WANT TO
SUBSCRIBE. WITH OTHER METHODS
TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION THIS HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH OTHER METHODS. THANK
YOU BYE NEXT UP IS SENATOR
BORCHERS. THIS IS CERTAINLY A
BALANCING ACT I THINK. LAST
YEAR WE SPENT A GOOD AMOUNT OF
TIME ON PRIVACY RELATED MATTERS
IN FACT ON THE CHAIR AND NINE
FIVE SPENT- EVEN MORE TIME ON
RESEARCHING. HOW OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD ARE MANAGING
PRESERVATION OF PRIVATE DATA.
SO WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS WE HAVE.
CONSTITUTIONAL EXPECTATIONS AND
WE HAVE A BONA FIDE EMERGENCY.
I IN I GUESS I'D LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS I MAY THROUGH THE
CHAIR TO. THE THIS IS NOT THE
ALTERNATOR FINE JOB OF MY DAD.
HEY WHY IS THIS NOT MANDATORY
CAN YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU RECITE
JUST A LITTLE BIT ON THE
RATIONALE AS TO WHY THIS WAS
NOT- WHY THIS DIDN'T GO THE
DIRECTION OF A MANDATORY-
POLICY BUT- I GUESS IN A CLEAR
ON THE QUESTION THAT IT'S NOT
MANDATING WHAT WHAT IS IT YEAH
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS IS VOLUNTARY THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL CAN. THE RULES ARE
THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH THIS-
WOULD PROTECT DATA BUT THE
TRACING ITSELF IT WOULD BE
VOLUNTARY FOR THOSE THAT WISH
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS EVENT A
TERRY AGAIN THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH CONTRACT
TRACING PER SE IT ONLY HAS THE
IT'S WITH APPLICATION SO THAT
THE CONTACT TRACING. ITSELF
THIS IS SILENT ON AND DOESN'T
DEAL WITH THAT IT'S REALLY IF
THE IF THE EMPLOYER WANTS TO
USE A PARTICULAR APPLICATION
AGO RIGHT THERERIGHT YOU THINK
IT WOULD USE A PARTICULAR
APPLICATION. THEN THE WHAT THIS
IS SAYING IS THAT CANNOT BE
MADE. OBLIGATORY ON AN EMPLOYEE
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M GETTING
AT YEAH SO WHY IS IT SO YOU'RE
GIVING THE EMPLOYEE THE WITH
THE OPTION TO DOWNLOAD THE APP
OR WHATEVER FORM OF TECHNOLOGY.
THE PRESS. WHY IS IT IS IN THAT.
MADE MANDATORY WHAT HAS BEEN
EMPLOYEE MUST. SUBSCRIBE THEM
SELVES TO THIS TYPE OF SERVICE
THAT WOULD HELP THE PUBLIC FOR
PURPOSES OF TRACING DOWN THE
ROAD OKAY BECAUSE BUT I THINK
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF ALARMING
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYEE NONE OF US KNOW WHAT
THAT APPLICATION IS. THE DATA
THAT IT COLLECTS WHO OWNS THAT
DATA HOW IT'S BEING USED AND SO
FOR AN EMPLOYER WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE DONE THEIR RESEARCH
AND ARE JUST BUYING AN
APPLICATION AND SAY YOU MUST
USE THIS APPLICATION. THREE
DIFFERENT THAT AN EMPLOYER
INSTALLING. THE WORD PROCESSING
APPLICATION ON THE COMPUTERS
AND SAY YOU MUST USE THIS I'VE
BEEN IN THAT SITUATION AND IT'S
BEEN VERY DEVASTATING WHEN IT'S
AN APPLICATION THAT I DON'T
PARTICULARLY CARE FOR. BUT I
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE IN THAT
CASE IN THIS CASE. THE
APPLICATION CAN HAVE SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL ISSUES FOR
THAT EMPLOYEE AND IF THE
EMPLOYER HASN'T DONE THEIR JOB
AND WE MANDATE THAT THE
EMPLOYEE NOW DOWNLOADS. THE
WHATEVER IT HAPPENS TO BE
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SPECIFYING
WHAT THE APPLICATION IS WE'RE
JUST SAYING THAT YOU CAN'T.
HOISTED ON AN EMPLOYEE NOW IF
THE EMPLOYER HAS DONE THEIR
JOB. AND HAS BUILT
INAPPROPRIATE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE APP BELPER AND CAN
ARTICULATE THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. THIS IS HOW YOUR
DATA GETS USED THIS IS WHO OWNS
YOUR DATA. THIS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO DO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY MOST EMPLOYEES
WOULDN'T SAY OKAY I TRUST MY
EMPLOYER I TRUST THE SITUATION.
BUT THIS REALLY IS ASKING THAT
EMPLOYEE THE EMPLOYER TO TAKE
THAT ADDITIONAL STEP. IN ORDER
TO ARTICULATE. WHY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE EMPLOYEE
SHOULD USE THAN THEY CAN OPT IN
AND BE A PART OF IT. I THINK
EMPLOYEES THEMSELVES LIKE ALL
OF US WANT TO STAY SAFE FROM UP.
SO DO I ONE CONTRACT CONTACT
TRACING BEING DONE FOR THOSE
THAT INTERACT WITH YES.
ABSOLUTELY DO I WANT TO HAVE TO
USE THE TOOL THAT IMAY NOT
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THAT HAS
TREMENDOUS PERSONAL AND PRIVACY
IMPLICATIONS ENTER. I'M GONNA
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE RELUCTANT
ABOUT THAT SIR UNLESS I'VE HAD
A CHANCE TO DO MY HOMEWORK SO
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL.
IS SETTING UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND I THINK GOING BACK TO
THE BALANCING ACT THAT- CENTER
HERTZBERG I'M NOT HERTZBERG ON
BURKE HAD TALKED ABOUT. I AM I
BELIEVE THAT WE- ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE CERTAIN
SAFEGUARDS NEED TO BE PUT INTO
PLACE. NGUYEN APPS ARE
DOWNLOADED. I FRANKLY BELIEVE
THAT UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT SINCE WE'RE NOT IN A
POSITION. TO GET A HANDLE ON
THIS PANDEMIC. THAT PUBLIC
EMERGENCY IN THE SAYS CITY
SHOULD DICTATE THAT EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATE IN TRACING. AND
THAT THE INFORMATION DERIVED BE
PROPERLY OVERSEEN BE PROPERLY
DISPOSED OF NOT BE ALLOWED IN
OTHER CIVIL OR CRIMINAL RELATED
CONTACTS WERE DISCLOSED TO
THIRD PARTIES. UNRELATED TO THE
CONTAINMENT EMERGENCY SITUATION
OF THIS PANDEMIC. SO I AM
GIVING YOU CAN KIND OF TELL
THAT I'M I'M HAVING A CHALLENGE
WITH WITH THIS WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS SOME
MERITS BUT IN BUT ALSO HAS SOME
SOME DRAWBACKS BUT I APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING. MY QUESTION SURE
EIGHT EIGHT APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR AND REALIZE THAT THIS
IS REALLY A SUBSET AND A BIT OF
A DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN THAN
YOU'VE DONE INSTEAD OF
MANDATING SOMETHING IT'S JUST
PUTTING IN SOME SAFEGUARDS
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
SOMETHING IS. TO MANDATE WHO
CAN TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
SAFEGUARDS BUILT IN WHO'S GONNA
TAKE. RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ENSURING THAT THAT APPLICATION.
DOES THAT APPLE. DOES WE HAVE
THAT ARGUE A LOT IN THIS LED.
ABOUT WHETHER WE'RE- STIFLING
INNOVATION OR NOT. THIS ISN'T
BECAUSE IT'S SAYING THE
EMPLOYER CAN CAN GET AN
APPLICATION. AND CAN MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE DO CONTACT TRACING.
BYE THERE'S NOT REALLY THE
CONTROLS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEE WHICH I ACTUALLY DON'T
DISAGREE. ABOUT ENSURING THAT
THAT INFORMATION GETS USED
APPROPRIATELY WE'RE PUTTING
SOME OF THAT POWER THE POLICE
HANDS TO SAFETY I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS. AND SO
ALLOWING THEM TO OPT OUT.
UNLESS THE CASE IS MADE THAT
AND THEY'RE COMFORTABLE IF
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE THAT THEIR
DATA CAN BE PROTECTED AND THEIR
HEALTH IS GOING TO BE PROTECTED
BY FACILITATING CONTACT TRACING.
I WOULD EXPECT MOST PEOPLE
WOULD SAY OKAY I. AND I THINK
THAT. AND I THINK TO GET A KEEP
IN MIND THAT HERE IN THE
SENATE- WE- WE DO A GREAT JOB
WITH CONTACT TRACING AND WE
DON'T. FORCE ANYBODY TO USE AN
APPLICATION THERE ARE OTHER
METHODS THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
THIS BILL JUST ADDRESSES IF AN
EMPLOYER CHOOSES TO USE AN
APPLICATION. WHAT THE GUARD
RAILS AROUND THE U. R. AROUND
THE USE OF THAT APPLICATION.
AND YOU AS YOU MENTION OF
TALKED ABOUT THIS WE'RE HAVING
TROUBLE EVEN GETTING PEOPLE
JUST TO WEAR MASKS. LET ALONE
HAVE THEM AGREE. TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THEIR EMPLOYER
AND IF IT'S INFORMATION THAT
GOES WITH BEYOND THE CONTACT
TRACING OR- VIOLATES THEIR
HUMAN RIGHTS AND ALL- I DON'T
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO THE GOAL THAT WE'VE- CHATTED
ABOUT SO. THIS BILL REALLY
TRIES TO- PUT LIMITS AND GIVE
DIRECTION WHEN AN APPLICATION
IS THE APPROACH THAT AN
EMPLOYER WANTS TO USE IT
DOESN'T. PROHIBITED IT CHAU
SHOWED SOME LIMITS AS TO WHAT
THE INFORMATION IS THAT CAN BE
OBTAINED. GIVES THE EMPLOYED-
THAT INFORMATION GIVE SOME
KNOWLEDGE AND GIVES HIM THE
RIGHT TO SAY YOU KNOW I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH IT- IT BUT IT
DOESN'T PRECLUDE ANY OTHER
TYPES OF CONTACT TRACING AND AS
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY. HAS
SUGGESTED IF WHAT THE
APPLICATION CALLS FOR. IS
SOMETHING WITHIN WHICH PEOPLE
CAN FIND THAT COMFORT AND THE
PROTECTION OF THEIR PRIVACY
ULTIMATELY SO THE INFORMATION
IS NOT RETAINED THAT IT ONLY
RELATES TO CONTACT TRACING THAT
IT IS AS- LIMITING ON.
VIOLATING PEOPLE'S PRIVACY AS
POSSIBLE YOU'LL FIND EMPLOYEES
WILL PARTICIPATE AND TO THE
EXTENT THEY DON'T THERE ARE
OTHER METHODS OF CONTACT
TRACING THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
CAN AND WILL BE USED IN AGAIN
I. REFER US ALL TO WHAT WE DO
HERE IN THE SENATE. WITHOUT
USING AN APPLICATION IS AN
APPLICATION HELPFUL. ABSOLUTELY
BUT WHAT WE'RE ASKING IN IS
THAT THE L. BE LIMITED. IN
SCOPE AND IN. IT LENGTH OF TIME
THAT IT IS AVAILABLE IN ONLY BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH THE INFORMATION IS
INITIALLY- OSTENSIBLY BEING
SUCKED AND THAT IS TO ASSIST
WITH CONTACT TRACING SO IT- I
HOPE THAT I'VE ARTICULATED THIS
A BILL THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON AND IN FACT- I AM. HOPING TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF IT I THINK IT
REALLY HAS. STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS AND- IT DOES ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED MEANWHILE WE DO HAVE
OTHERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK MY
APOLOGIES ARE- UP NEXT TO
SENATOR MORNING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. SO THE STRENGTH OF
THIS BILL IN MY VIEW. IS THE
ARTICULATION OF WHAT CAN AND
CANNOT BE DONE WITH THE DATA IN
ITS IT CAN NLY BE COLLECTED
FOR VERY LIMITED USE AND THEN
HAS TO BE DESTROYED AFTER IT'S
TIME OF USEFULNESS FOR THE
TRACING. WE'VE SEEN OTHER AREAS
OF THE LAW OF EMPLOYERS
COLLECTING HEALTH DATA FROM
EMPLOYEES AND THEN- INSURANCE
COMPANIES MINING DATA IN
CHARGING EMPLOYERS MORE BASED
ON CERTAIN HEALTH RISK IN
INCENTIVIZING EMPLOYERS TO
THEN- SCREEN EMPLOYEES WHO
MIGHT HAVE A PRE EXISTING
CONDITION SO YOU OPEN UP A
PANDORA'S BOX. WHEN EMPLOYERS
HAVE ACCESS TO EMPLOYEE HEALTH
INFORMATION SO TO ME THE
STRENGTH OF THE BILLS TO REALLY
PRESCRIBE VERY NARROWLY AND
STRICTLY THE PURPOSE OF ANY OF
THAT DATA COLLECTION AND WHAT
IT CAN AND CAN'T BE USED FOR.
ON THE ISSUE OF. OCT IN. ONE OF
MY CONCERNS ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT THE
NATION IS PEOPLE WHO REFUSE TO
BELIEVE THERE'S A REAL PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK WHO DON'T THINK IT
APPLIES TO THEM WHO DON'T WEAR
MASKS AND WE'VE SEEN IT ALSO IN.
PUBLIC SECTORS OF PRISON GUARDS
NOT WEARING MASKS OF POLICE
OFFICERS NOT WEARING MASKS- WE
HEARD YESTERDAY IN A HEARING.
STATE HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES NOT
WEARING MASKS AND MOVING
BETWEEN INFECTED WARDS IN
UNINFECTED WARD'S- SO ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA. EXERCISE THE RIGHT IN
THIS BILL TOPPED OUT WILL BE
THOSE THAT DON'T CARE ABOUT
THEIR FELLOW NEIGHBORS FELLOW
WORKERS COWORKERS SAID TETRA.
THAT SAID IT IS A BALANCING ACT
AND I THINK. I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS A PART OF THE
INFORMED CONSENT INFORMING AN
EMPLOYEE WHO MIGHT BE ASKED TO
USE THE APPLICATION THIS
EMPLOYER HAVE TO TELL THE
EMPLOYEE. WHAT THE PROTECTIONS
ARE ON THAT INFORMATION. THAT
MIGHT BE COLLECTED. IT'S A
QUESTION TO THE- THROUGH THE
CHAIR THE CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE ACTUALLY FOR THE FREE
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN CERTAINLY GET FOR
YOU I DON'T KNOW THAT THIS BILL
PRESCRIBES. WHETHER I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THE
BILL SAYS EMPLOYER YOU MUST
TELL THE EMPLOYEE HAS BEEN DONE
I MEAN I WOULD HOPE SO I WOULD
EXPECT THAT HAPPENS AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE SEE
WITH MOST APPLICATIONS IS THIS
IS HOW YOUR DATA IS BEING USED
CORRECT AND I THINK THAT WOULD
HELP. TO GET MORE
PARTICIPATION. THIS SUPPORTS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKER
HEALTH OBJECTIVE. IF PART OF
THAT INFORMED CONSENT. REQUIRES
THE EMPLOYER TO SAY COLLECTED
FOR THIS PURPOSE FOR NO OTHER
PURPOSE WILL BE DESTROYED BY
SUCH AND SUCH A DATE. IT CITRIX.
THAT COULD BUILD CONFIDENCE.
THAT EXERCISE OF WHETHER AN
EMPLOYEE CHOSE. TO OPT IN OR
OPT OUT. I WAS ALSO INTERESTED
NOT TO SEE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS. LISTED IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND THEN I DID HEAR
THE PHONE CALLS WHERE THEY SAID
THEY WERE. STILL FORMULATING A
POSITION AND I THINK. ALL THE
PEOPLE- THE INTEREST GROUPS
LARGELY TECHNOLOGY GROUPS FORM
PLAYER GROUPS- I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A PUBLIC HEALTH
VOICE. IN HERE AS WELL BECAUSE-
IT IS A BALANCING ACT. I AM A
STRONG PROTECTOR OF INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS CIVIL LIBERTIES- PRIVACY
RIGHTS. BUT WHEN WE HAVE A
PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC. IN THE
REFUSAL. OF A WORKER. TO
PARTICIPATEIN. AN ASPECT OF
SCREENING THAT COULD PROVE TO
HELP. OTHER CO WORKERS- STAY
SAFE AD HEALTHY FATS FOR ME
WHERE IT GETS KIND OF TOUGH TO
SAY THERE SHOULD NEVER BE AN
EXCEPTION. TO THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION I IT DOES HELP ME
TO UNDERSTAND IT DOESN'T
PROHIBIT OTHER TYPES OF TRACING
THIS IS SIMPLY RELATED IF THIS
PARTICULAR APPLICATION OR- A
COMPUTER APPLICATION. WOULD BE.
RECOMMENDER BY AN EMPLOYER FOR
THEIR WORK FORCE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROTECTING EVERYONE
IN THE WORK FORCE- SO THAT'S
WHERE I STRUGGLE WITH THIS I
WOULDN'T NORMALLY STRUGGLE WITH
THE PRIVACY RELATED BILL- I CAN
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
BUT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR ME
TO HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR- IF AS
PART OF THIS IF IT MOVES
FORWARD AND MOVES INTO LAW.
THAT ANY EMPLOYER SEEKING TO
USE SUCH AN APPLICATION WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE. AN EMPLOYEE AWARE
OF THE PROTECTIONS IF THEY WERE
TO OFTEN- SO THAT I'M JUST KIND
OF CLOSING WITH THE STATEMENT
NOT REALLY A QUESTION THAT IN
AND IF YOU WANNA COME IN YEAH
IT WELL. FROM MY STANDPOINT I
WOULD TEND TO AGREE AND THAT'S
PART OF THE EMPLOYER BEING ABLE
TO ENSURE TO SIMPLY THAT THIS
IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO AS I
THINK MOST EMPLOYEES IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT ARE GOING TO
WANT TO BE PART OF CONTACT
TRACING SOME AREN'T. BUT
HOPEFULLY THAT'S A REALLY
MINIMAL. MOST WILL END PART OF.
ENSURING THAT THAT EMPLOYEE
DOES OPT INTO THIS PARTICULAR
METHOD OF CONTACT TRACING.
THAT'S IMPORTANT AND I KNOW
THAT THAT. I'M SORRY I CAN'T
ANSWER ALL THE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT THAT MR CHOW
COULD BUT ONE THING THAT I DO
KNOW HE'S HE'S VERY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN
WITH YOU. ON AREAS THAT CAN
HELP CLARIFY AND SOLIDIFY TO
ENSURE THAT THIS GETS DONE
MISTRUST. NOT TRY TO PREVENT
THESE APPS FROM BEING USED.
JUSTIN THAT THAT THEY'RE BEING
USED IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY SO
THAT'S WHAT FACILITATING. SO
THIS BILL IS MEANT TO
FACILITATE SIDE I KNOW THAT HE
IS OPEN. TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND I WAS STAFF. IS WHAT ONE IS
AN- ABERRATION I APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE AUTHOR AND
MAY BE THE COMMITTEES FOLLOW UP
WITH THE AUTHOR. IS AGAIN I
THINK THE STRENGTH OF THE BILL.
IS BEING EXPLICIT ABOUT. WHAT
CAN BE DONE WITH THAT TRACING
DATA AND WHAT CAN BE DONE. AND
HAVING- ANY INFORMED CONSENT
SHOULD ALSO PROVIDE THE
EMPLOYEE. WITH MAYBE EVEN A
WRITTEN ARTICULATION. OF WHAT
THAT INFORMATION. CAN BE USED
FOR AND NOT AN AND A SPECIFIC.
WARRANTY IF YOU WILL IT WON'T
BE SHARED IN- SHE THE HUMAN
RESOURCES INFORMATION EMPLOYEE
FILE ATTACHMENT CENTER.
PROTECTING HIPPER RIGHTS AS
PART OF. INFORMING A TRACING.
PROTOCOL SO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING AND
THE BILL DOES REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO DISCLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PURPOSE. FOR THE
DATA. IN THE CATEGORIES OF DATA
TO BE COLLECTED SO THAT IS
REQUIRED IN THE BILL AS A
DISCLOSURE RELEVANT OF COURSE
WE KNOW WHENEVER. WE REQUIRE AN
OPT IN. THE ENTITY WERE
REQUIRED REQUIRING OR SEE IF I
SHOULD SAY SEEKING THE OFTEN
TRIES TO GIVE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AND ASSURANCE TO
THE PERSON IT'S TRYING TO GET
TO AGREE- AS POSSIBLE SO. AS AN
OPT IN PROGRAM BUT IT WILL
REQUIRE THE EMPLOYER TO. GIVE
THE ASSURANCES TO THE EMPLOYEE
THAT THE EMPLOYEE WOULD THEN
FEEL COMFORTABLE PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM AND THUS. THAT
SHOULD ASSIST IN AGAIN CREATING
SOME PARAMETERS LEGITIMATE
GUIDELINES TO THE COMPANY BUT
AGAIN IT'S NOT THE ONLY AVENUE
WE'VE BEEN DOING CONTACT
TRACING OF FOR DECADES- IN THIS
HEALTH ISSUES WE DO A FOR
TUBERCULOSIS FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT FOR YEARS.
WHICH ARE NON APPLICATION BASED
SO THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS- BUT
WE DO WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THE PEOPLE ARE-
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS AND I
WOULD. SUBMIT THAT IF THEY ARE.
IN IN SHOULD BE THAT THAT THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING POSITIVE THE
TRYING TO ASSIST THEM. IN THEIR
HEALTH THAT THEY WILL AGREE BUT
WE KNOW. YOU KNOW THAT THE
FOLKS WHO THINK OF IT AS A HOAX
AS I MENTIONED THEY- THAT THEY
WON'T EVEN. WEAR MASKS. SO SOME
PEOPLE YOU'RE GOING TO GET SOME
NOT BUT THIS JUST ONE TWO.
AVENUE IF WE DO SEE A GREATER
USE OF APPLICATIONS AND I THINK
THIS DOES BALANCES PRIVACY
ISSUES BUT AGAIN THIS IS A BILL
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
STILL BEING DISCUSSED. I THINK
THE PURPOSE THE FOCUS IN THE
PARAMETERS THAT ARE SET FORTH
HERE CERTAINLY GET US- PRETTY
CLOSE TO THAT- THE SWEET SPOT
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR SO- WITH
THAT WE HAVE A SENATOR TO
RUSSIAN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I JUST WANTED TO.
PICK UP ON WHERE SENATOR OBAMA.
MONEY WAS FOCUSED ON AND THAT
IS YOU KNOW IN THAT WORKPLACE.
WE REALLY HAVE TO DO MORE TO
PROTECT ALL THOSE WORKERS. WE
ARE FINDING EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
THE NEWSPAPER- WORKPLACES
WORKED AS HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE-
YOU DON'T GET THE- INFECTED
AND- WE HAVE TO DO A MUCH MUCH
TIGHTER JOB. AND I AGREE THERE
IS OF COURSE A PRIVACY ISSUE
BUT THERE IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE AND THERE'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE FOR PEOPLE IN YOUR
WORKPLACE YOU GO TO WORK. YOU
EXPECT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PROTECTED YOU EXPECT THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE SAFE AND HEALTHY
FOR YOU- AND IT'S SO- IT SEEMS
TO ME WE HAVE TO HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT COVERS ALL THE WORKERS OR
ELSE IT'S- USELESS. YOU KNOW AS
FAR AS WHAT WE WHAT WE NEED FOR
TO PROTECT THOSE WORKERS SO. IF
AN EMPLOYEE REFUSES TO SIGN THE
HIP A RELEASE AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE SOME SYSTEM LIKE A THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE UP FOR IT.
THEN THEN YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BE TRACED. AT ALL AND- ALL THE
WORKERS ASSEMBLY IT'LL BY
PATHETICALLY GET FURLOUGHED AND
GETS SENT HOME SO I HAVE SOME
REAL CONCERNS I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT ALL THE ANSWERS I'VE
SEEN- IDEAS ABOUT AMENDMENTS TO
THIS ABOUT MAKING IT SURE THAT
IT'S LIMITED TO THE WORKPLACE
SO IT DOESN'T GO BEYOND THAT SO
OUR PRIVACY IS PROTECTED OF. SO
I THINK THAT THERE ARE
DEFINITELY WAYS TO AMEND THIS
IN SUCH A WAY THAT WILL GIVE US
WHAT WHAT WE ALL ARE LOOKING
FOR- SO I'D LIKE TO URGE. THE
AUTHORED THROUGH THE PRESENTER
TO PLEASE LOOK AT A MORE
SERIOUS WAYS OF AMENDING THIS
BILL FOR THE COULD HAVE OUR
FULL SUPPORT AT LEAST WITH
REGARDS TO ME. THANK YOU.
SENATOR STERN AND I THINK THAT
IS THE LAST INCREASE CENTER
STERNECK NO. CENTER GONZALEZ
WILL GO NEXT TO CHEDDARS DURING
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. OKAY THANK
YOU MANAGER- THANKS FOR THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ABATE IT
SORT OF DAWNED ON ME THAT THIS
COMMITTEE. IS REALLY THE FIRST
MEANINGFUL PLACE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE'VE READ
STARTED WRESTLING WITH THESE
HUGE AND CRUCIAL ISSUES SO-
APPRECIATE THE RIGOR WITH WHICH
YOU'VE ALLOWED THE DEBATE TO
TAKE PLACE MADAM CHAIR AND- YOU
KNOW I. THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK THROUGH THIS BILL ABOUT.
THERE WILL BE AMENDMENTS OR
CONSIDERATION OF AMENDMENTS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL POINT I'M
TRYING TO GET A SENSE. IF THIS
BILL IS AMENDED- IN SOME
SUBSTANTIAL WAY GOING FORWARD
ARE WE GONNA HAVE A CHANCE TO
SEE THIS AGAIN- OR IS THIS. I
DON'T KNOW TIMING WISE ARE THE
IS GONNA WORK BUT I'M A LITTLE
WORRIED ABOUT TAKING A VOTE
TODAY AND THEN. YOU KNOW WE
COULD LOOK ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
LATER ON WE DON'T GET GET A
SECOND BITE AT THE APPLE. YEAH
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THE BILLS
CAN LOOK ENTIRELY DIFFERENT I
THINK THAT THE AUTHOR AND- THIS
COMMITTEE ARE PAYING VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED. I THINK
THAT THE BILL HAS IT HAS MOVED
HAS BEEN TIGHTENED
CONSIDERABLY- THE BILL'S NEXT
JOURNEY IS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WERE OF COURSE YOU KNOW.
AMENDMENTS CAN AND ARE LIKELY
TO BE TAKEN THEN WE ARE IN A
RATHER CONSTRICTED TIME FRAME-
BUT- I THINK AT THIS POINT WITH
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE ON
THIS BILL. THE HARD WORK BY THE-
BY THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF OF
THIS COMMITTEE I THINK WE HAVE
MOVED ALONG- TO A POINT WHERE-
I WON'T SAY IT PROTOCOL TO
TWEAK. BUT I THINK WE'RE CLOSE
TO THE POINT WHERE WE JUST NEED
TO- PERHAPS- CLARIFY A LITTLE
BIT MORE- SIGNIFICANTLY JUST
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND DOESN'T
DO BUT IN TERMS OF RE WRITING
THE BILL. AND GOING IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION- THAT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPENOKAY I BET THAT'S
YOUR HELPFUL I'M CAN I JUST
ASK- IT JUST A SUBSTANTIVE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR HERE.
WELL WITHOUT OBJECTION TO THE
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JIM
REMEMBER STONE SURE YES. PLEASE
RATE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SO THE- I'M I'M TRYING TO
SQUARE THIS I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
THE AUTHOR OF SIX SIXTY BUT THE
DEFINITION WE JUST WENT THROUGH
LOOKING AT CONTACT TRACING
WRITTEN LARGE AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO USE THAT INFORMATION
FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSES OTHER
THAN CONTACT TRACING. THAT SEEM
TO BE COMPREHENSIVE- YOUR THE
BILL HERE AS YOU RIGHTLY POINT
OUT DEALS WITH JUST THE
TECHNOLOGY ASSISTED CONTACT
TRACING RIGHT THAT SUBSET THAT
ACT SET. I I'M I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHY WE NEED TO START
A SECOND LAYER OF PROTECTION IF
WE'RE ALREADY SAYING YOU CAN
ONLY USE THAT CONTACT TRACING
ANY KIND OF CONTACT TRACING
INFO FOR CONTACT TRACING
PURPOSES ONLY WHY WE HAVE TO
HAVE A SECOND SET OF
RESTRICTIONS IN HERE. JUST FOR
A TECHNOLOGY SPECIFIC KIND.
SURE CENTER AND I THINK THE
REASON IS BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF APPLICATIONS AND HOW THOSE
GET USED I THINK THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THAT
INFORMATION THAT IS BEING USED
DURING KIND CONTACT TRACING AND
MOST OF THE BILLS DEALING WITH
THAT ARE DEALING IN THE LARGER
SENSE OF CONTACT FACING ANY OF
THE TOOLS THAT MIGHT GET USED
FOR CONTACT TRACING. THIS IS
INCOMPATIBLE WITH THAT BUT IT
IS CLARIFYING. THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO USE AN APPLICATION AND
REMEMBER THE APPLICATION BY ITS
NATURE. IS COLLECTING MORE
INFORMATION. THAN SOMEONE
NECESSARILY WOULD THROUGH USING
OTHER TOOLS BECAUSE IF IT IS
DOING IF IT IS TRACKING THE
MOVEMENTS OF AN INDIVIDUAL FOR
EXAMPLE. THEN THAT INFORMATION
IS BEING COLLECTED AND STORED
SOMEWHERE AND YES WHICH ONLY
SUPPOSED TO BE BEING USED FOR
CONTACT TRACING. BUT BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T SPECIFIED WHO OWNS THAT
WHERE DATA IS COMING FROM. AND
IT MIGHT BE THE COMPANY WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OR AN
ORGANIZATION WITH
RESPONSIBILITY OF DOING THE
CONTACT TRACING AND YET THE
DATA THAT COMES OUT OF THE
APPLICATION ITSELF. MAY RESIDE
IN B. OWN SOMEPLACE OUT. WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO DO. A LITTLE BIT
OF BELT AND SUSPENDERS HERE.
ENSURING THAT ANY INFORMATION
COLLECTED THROUGH THE
APPLICATION BECAUSE THAT'S ALL
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS THE
APPLICATION ITSELF. IS BEING
MANAGED IN SUCH A WAY AS WE
WOULD EXPECT. SO I DON'T AS
LONG AS THOSE DEFINITIONS AND
THE PROTECTIONS ARE SIMILAR
THERE'S REALLY NO HARM HERE BUT
THERE ARE OTHER. WHO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION
POTENTIALLY DEPENDING ON HOW
THE APP GETS WRITTEN. AND WHOSE
IT IS AND WHERE IT RESIDES IN
AND HOW IT FUNCTIONS. THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT ALL
OF THOSE PARTIES ARE BROUGHT IT
INTO SENATOR MUNNINGS POINTS.
THAT IT IS ART OF THE SELLING
POINT FOR ANY ORGANIZATION
ASKING SOMEONE TO YOU IS AN
APPLICATION LIKE THIS. THE PART
THAT SELLING POINT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THE LIMITATIONS ARE
ON THAT DATA. BECAUSE YOU'RE
SITTING ONE ON ONE AND
COLLECTING CONTACT TRACING
INFORMATION. YOU CAN SAY I THIS
IS ONLY GOING TO BE USE A LAWS
GOING TO SAY THIS CAN ONLY BE
USED IN THE SENSE. BUT AS WE
USE APPLICATIONS WE'LL DO THAT
HE JUST CLICK ON THE DOWNLOAD I
WANT TO USE THE APPLICATION. DO
YOU AGREE TO THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS THAT'S JUST A CLICK
THROUGH. HAVE YOU READ AND
READ. I GUESS I'M I'M I'M
CURIOUS THOUGH IF THE IF THE
APP DOESN'T. REQUIRE OR IF WE
BAR THE APP FROM SAY DOING
GEOLOCATION. AT ALL OFF THE
WORKSITE. THE YOU DO THAT JUST
TRICKS INSTANCE IN THE- IN THE
SNIFFING HEALTH CONTEXT HERE
BUT- THEN THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
DATA TO WORRY ABOUT THAT IN
THAT IN THAT CASE I DON'T KNOW
I MEAN IT DEPENDS ON WHAT ELSE
IS BEING COLLECTED BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T RESTRICTED THE
INFORMATION. BEING COLLECTED
WORDS SAYING THE INFORMATION
YOU'RE GETTING HAS TO BE USED
FOR CONTACT TRACING. AND YOU'RE
NOT JUST SAYING THAT YOU'RE
ALSO SAYING WHETHER OR NOT YOU
CAN USE THE TOOL AT ALL RIGHT I
MEAN YOU ARE SAYING. THAT
YOU'RE NOT JUST REFINING. THE
NATURE OF THE TOOL YOU'RE ALSO
SAYING AND YOU HAVE TO OPT INTO
THIS TOOL. AND YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT AT ANY TIME TO OPT OUT OF
THAT TOOL AND I GUESS I DON'T
SEE THIS THE SAME WAY AS LIKE.
A CONSUMER GOING ON THE
INTERNET NOT WANTING TO HAVE
ADS SERVED ON THEM WERE YOU
KNOW. THAT KIND OF CONSUMER
PRIVACY CONTEXT YOU KNOW MINE
RIGHT TO. NOT WEAR A MASK OR
NOT BE CONTACT REYES AND THEN
GO IN FACT ALL MY EMPLOYEES
INHIBITS THE RIGHTS OF OTHERS
SO I. I DON'T SEE THIS IS THE
SAME KIND OF. FRAMEWORK THAT
THAT LIKE THE CZ WE HAD THERE'S
A LOT OF. TALK ABOUT THIS THE
CPA IN THE- AND THE ANALYSIS
AND IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE SORT OF
USING THAT AS THE BASELINE
FRAMEWORK THIS IS NOT A
CONSUMER. FRAMEWORK AT ALL THIS
IS ABOUT. THE FOR MY FREEDOM TO
GO TO WORK AND FEEL SAFE- IS
CONTINGENT UPON OTHER PEOPLE
PLAYING BY THE SAME RULES AS ME
AND I DON'T WANT THOSE WHO WANT
TO BE REBELS. AND GO GET
COVETING COME INTO WORK.
BECAUSE THEY EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHT TO PRIVACY TO THAN EVER
HAMMER OVER ALL THE REST OF US
WHO WANT TO. LIVE OUR LIVES
SAFELY SO THAT THAT'S MY
CONCERN IS NOT JUST THE
MECHANICS OF THE TOOL. IT'S THE
RESTRICTION OF USING THE TOOL
AT ALL IN THE FIRST PLACE BUT
BUT IF WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE
WITH PEOPLE. TAKING ON MASKS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE AN EVEN HARDER
TIME GETTING PEOPLE TO. TAKE ON
CONTACT TRACING SO. ACT RIGHT
YEAH SURE OF IT BUT SHOULD I
SUBMIT THE RESUME HIS OUT THOSE
WHO DELIVERS A COUPLE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES HERE. THERE ARE
THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO WANT
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS
STUFF AND THEY TRULY ARE
PUTTING ALL OF US AT RISK AND-
INCLUDING PORTLAND POLICE.
THEIR CO WORKERS AND OTHERS.
THE ARE THEY LIKE TO BE THIS
OUT YET THEN THAT'S NOT REALLY
THE TARGET AUDIENCE HERE. THERE
THERE ARE ANY EMPLOYER ANY
ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE USING
MULTIPLE MEASURES TO DO THE
CONTACTORS. THIS HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH ANYTHING OTHER THAN A
TECHNOLOGY ASSISTEDCONTACT
TRACING AND HALF A CENTURY. AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT APP HAS BEEN APPROPRIATELY
VETTED AND APPROVED WE THOUGHT
ABOUT INAPPROPRIATELY USING IN
IN THE IDEAL CONTEXT YES THAT'S
PROBABLY FINE. AND IF SOMEONE
IS SUPPOSED TO CONTACT TRACING
WEARING A MASK AND ALL THAT.
WELL UNLESS WHICH IS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THIS UNLESS WE SAY
THAT WE SHALL TO. THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY IF NOT REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. THEN THOSE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE A THREAT TO THOSE AROUND
THEM THAT'S FINE IN THIS CASE.
IT'S NOT INVALIDATING THE TOOL
BECAUSE THE ORGANIZATION CAN
STILL USE THE TOOL. BUT AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS THE ABILITY HERE
TO SAY WAIT A MINUTE. THIS GOES
BEYOND WHAT I WOULD EXPECT I'M
HAPPY TO DO CONTACT. YOU CAN
ASK ME WHATEVER YOU WANT I WANT
TO SEE WHAT THAT INFORMATION IS
WORK OUT. BUT THE FACT THAT
THAT INFORMATION IS NOW BEING
UPLOADED AND DISTRIBUTED
DISSEMINATED GOD KNOWS WHERE.
THEN I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT. I WANT TO BE ABLE TO OPT
OUT THAT'S REALLY ALL THAT THIS
BILL DOES IS PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY SO IT'S NOT
INVALIDATING THE USEFULNESS OF
THE TOOL BUT IT IS GIVING AN
INDIVIDUAL THE ABILITY TO SAY.
YOU HAVEN'T MADE THE CASE FOR
ME DAY THIS IS PROTECTIVE
ENOUGH. FOR ME TO BE
COMFORTABLE. USING THAT
APPLICATION NOT ONLY LAST
LONGER WHICH IS A SUBSET OF
THAT QUESTIONS THE JUST SAY AND
THANK YOU FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
OF THIS CONVERSATION- IF THEY
DON'T USE THAT TOOL AND THEY
DON'T SIGNED HIPPA RELEASE. YOU
CAN'T CONTACT RACE AT ALL I
MEAN. PLEASE STOP WHAT DO WE DO
KNOW THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE
BECAUSE ALL FOCUSED ON. WE'RE
NOT DEALING WITH THE LARGER
PROBLEM OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
GOING TO BE COOPER THAT ALL.
ENDED THAT'S THAT'S A BIGGER
QUESTION HERE. ALL WE'RE SAYING
IS. IF ONE OF THOSE TOOLS.
SORRY ONE OF THOSE TOOLS. IS AN
APPLICATION. THAT'S BEING USED
AND GIVEN THE IMPLICATIONS OF
WHAT APPLICATIONS CAN COLLECT.
WITHOUT EVEN. ANY CONTROLS
BECAUSE THAT'S THE NATURE OF
THE APPLICATION. THEN THEY CAN
THE EMPLOYEE NEEDS TO BE
COMFORTABLE ENOUGH WITH THAT TO
SAY YEAH YEAH OKAY THAT IS A
FINE MATHIS. THAT INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S NOT GONNA SIGNED HIPPA
RELEASE NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING
ELSE WELL GOOD LUCK I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO BUT THAT THAT
THAT'S NOT THIS BILL. THIS BILL
IS REALLY ABOUT LOOKING AT ONE
SPECIFIC TOOL ENSURING THAT IT
IS USED. APPROPRIATELY THAT'S
ALL IT IS HI THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION- SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND THEN WILL ASK YOU TO CLOSE
CENTERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
S. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
ANSWERING A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND FOR THE INSIGHTFUL
DISCUSSION AS WELL- JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS I DIDN'T SEE
IT EXPLICITLY HERE- BUT- THE-
AT MISUSED WITHIN THE BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
BUT- WHAT ABOUT. OUTSIDE OF
THE- BUSINESS ENVIRONMENTS A
CYBER SECURITY AND ANY
BREACHES- AND ANY BREACH
SAFEGUARDS THAT COULD BE.
INCLUDED AS WELL HAVE THERE
BEEN. WELL I DID IT AGAIN
BECAUSE THIS THIS BILL IS
DEALING WITH THE APPLICATION
ITSELF. ANY OF THOSE BREACHES
OR VIOLATIONS BASED ON THE USE
OF THAT APPLICATION IS REALLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS TALKING. JUST
ON THE APPLICATION YEAH NOTHING
OUT THERE YET NOTHING NOTHING
OUTSIDE THE APPLICATION. OKAY
AND THEN- YEAH AND THEN I ALSO
SEE THERE AREN'T ANY
REQUIREMENTS FOR UPDATES AS
PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH
INVOLVES. SO IF THERE'S MORE A
NEED FOR MORE THAN JUST
SOMETHING ELSE TYPING THINK
ABOUT AS MORE DATA AS WE MAY
NEED MORE DATA OR MORE-
INFORMATION- TO INCLUDE AS-
THIS CRISIS EVOLVES AND AS
WE'RE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THIS
CRISIS I THINK WOULD BE-
ANOTHER THING TO THINK ABOUT
THE ONLY. REASON I BRING THESE
TWO UP IS THAT THERE HAVE BEEN-
DISCUSSIONS OF COURSE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL- THROUGH THE AT.
THE NOTIFICATION- ACT THERE BUT
DO INCLUDE INCLUDE THOSE TWO-
ITEMS YES I JUST WANTED TO. ASK
ABOUT THAT YEAH IF YOU GET THIS
IS NOT ABOUT WHAT DATA IS BEING
COLLECTED SHOULD THAT IT IS
BEING PROTECTED AND THAT THE
THIRTY. MINIMUM SO IF THERE IS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
THAT IS REQUESTED. OR NEEDED
pTO THE APP SAYS IT WOULD BE
ADDED TO THE INTERVIEW
QUESTIONS FOR SOMEBODY ELSE.
USING A MORE FACE TO FACE TYPE
OF. CONTRACTORS RIGHT OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT TACTIC
CONTRACTS ARE REQUIRED- BY THE
BILL TO HAVE DATA BREACH
REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED. WELL WITH THAT
INTERVIEW REAL DISK. PAVIA VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE- CENTER Y.
CASKEY HOW MOVE THE BILL THE-
BILL- NO NO CANCER OFF- THANK
YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION AND- I
JUST LIKE TO SAY IT'S IMPORTANT
WITH THESE APPLICATIONS. THAT
WE RECOGNIZE WORK IN A CRISIS
AND WE TRY TO USE SOME AFFECTED
FULLY. AND NOT AS AN EXCUSE TO
DO MORE TO GAIN PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION TO VIOLATE PRIVACY-
THEN IT IS ABSOLUTE. SURRENDER
THE STATE. BELIEVE THIS BILL
ABSOLUTELY DOES THAT IT SETS
GUIDELINES- FOR THE
APPLICATION. IT ALLOWS THE
EMPLOYEE TO GET INFORMATION SO
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS AND
IS NOT BEING COLLECTED IT IS
ONE OF A TOOL MANY TOOLS AGAIN
HERE IN THE SENATE CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF. WE HAD TO SIGN ON
TO THESE APPLICATIONS THAT WERE
FOLLOWING US EVERYWHERE WE
WENT- WE MIGHT. WE MIGHT REJECT
THAT NOTION- SOLUTION IT DOES
HAVE TO HAVE SOME RESTRICTIONS
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE-
THERE IS A MOTION. THE MOTION
IS I BELIEVE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
WITH THAT- OF THE FOR SERVICE
FOR YOUR CLIENTS THANK YOU
MISTER TECH GAVE ME ABOUT THREE
PAGES OF CLOSING STATEMENTS.
BUT WITH THAT ARTICULATE
STATEMENT OF YOUR OWN MADAM
CHAIR. I WILL LET THAT STAND AS
MY CLOTHES I JUST LAST WEEK I
KEPT. THANK YOU SO MUCH- THERE
IS A MOTION- DO PASSED WAS SENT
THE SENATE APPROACH- MADAM.
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOR AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JACKSON. JACKSON AYE JACKSON
AYE BURGESS. PORGES NOT VOTING.
DID ASAL. GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I MELENDEZ. MELINDA'S NOT
VOTING MONNING HI MINING AYE
STERN. JOURNALING STERN NOT
VOTING BURKE NUMBER NOT VOTING.
AMBURGEY NOT VOTING WHITE HOUSE
SKI HI. WIECKOWSKI AYE YOU HAVE
ONE TWO THREE FOUR RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE SUPPOSED SENATOR DRAWS SO
HAS JUST RETURNED FROM HER
OTHER COMMITTEE WOULD YOU CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THAT
MEASURE THIS ITEM DID ASAL. THE
RUSSELL I. FOR OKAY ALL MEMBERS
ARE HERE ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE HIS. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
MEMBERS NOT VOTING. ALL RIGHT-
ICE FIVE THE NEW ZERO FOUR
NONVOTING THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND WE'RE GOING TO GROW YOU ONE
MORE TIME HERE APPARENTLY- YOU
HAVE THE NEXT BILL UP THERE WE
WERE CITED FOR THE BEGINNING WE
WOULD BE HEARING BOTH YOUR
BILLS. AND THEN GOING BACK TO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEEKS BILLS-
YOUR BILL COMING UP AT THIS
POINT IS FILE ITEM EIGHT AB.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO ANOTHER
EASY ONE AND- WILL ALLOW YOU
TO- TO OPEN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS IN
YOUR STAFF'S WORK ON THIS AS
WE'VE RIED. TO REFINE THIS
BILL IN INDIA WITH A LOT OF THE
ISSUES IS AS WE KNOW
MANUFACTURED HOMES IN OUR
DISTRICTS ARE SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SOURCES OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BUT WHAT
OFTEN HAPPENS IS PARKS ARE
PURCHASED AND- INVENTORY FOR
AWHILE UNTIL THERE THEN TURNED
INTO SOMETHING THAT WAS MORE
LUCRATIVE. FOR THAT THE PARK
OWNER AND TO BE DEVELOPED AND
WHAT THE DATA SHOWS VERY
CLEARLY IS THOSE CONVERSIONS.
READ THE RESULT IN A REDUCTION
IN HOUSING. AND TO TAKE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GENERALLY
OFF THE MARKET SO THAT HAS A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON. OUR
ABILITY ACROSS THE STATE TO
MANAGE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE'VE WORKED THESE THIS ISSUE
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW IN
TRYING TO. ENSURE THAT THE-
RESIDENTS THE OWNERS OF THE
MANUFACTURED HOMES GET
APPROPRIATE NOTICE WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT. AND
ASKING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO.
ADOPT SOME FINDINGS. ON THE
IMPACT TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN SOME AMENDMENTS RECENTLY
TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE FINDINGS
BUT SAID AFFECT OF THE WITH THE
ACTUAL LOCAL JURISDICTION
EFFECTIVELY PRECLUDED THE
ABILITY CONVERT THE PARTIES
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE AFTER
THIS NOT WITH THE INTENT WAS.
WE KNOW THOSE CONVERSIONS ARE
GOING TO GO FORWARD WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE-
OWNER OF THE MANUFACTURED HOME.
GETS FAIR MARKET VALUE GETS
APPROPRIATE NOTICE AND EIGHT SO
THAT THAT THEY CAN THEN BE
PLACED INTO. HOUSING IN THEIR
COMMUNITY INSTEAD OF LOSING
THEIR CONNECTION WITH THE
COMMUNITY TODAY THEY HAVE BEEN
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE IN MY DISTRICT
SOME THESE PARKS PEOPLE BUT IN
THESE PARTS FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS. AT WHEN THE MARKET
CONVERTED THEY THEN CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD TO BE IN THAT
AREA. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS. AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
THOUGHTFUL WORK WITH US ON
AMENDING THIS BILL AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AS MANY OF THE ISSUES
WE CAN. WE HAVE ALSO I WILL
NOTE THAT SENATOR AMBER CAME TO
US BECAUSE HIS BILL SENATE BILL
NINE NINETY NINE WHICH CLOSED A
LOOPHOLE OF MULTI YOUR MOBILE
HOME LEADERS NOT HAVING TO BUY
BY LOCAL RENT CONTROL. MEASURES
THAT BILL WAS STRUGGLING IT IS
A PART OF A PACKAGE THAT'S WHAT
IS A PART OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
THAT IS GOOD POLICY TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO. KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES IN THESE
MANUFACTURED HOMES TO THE BEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THE SO WE ARE CLEAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF STONE- YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED ON PAGE SIXTEEN YEAH
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS. AND THAT
IS ATTACHED TO THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL ALL RIGHT SO AND AT THIS
POINT TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU HAVE
A BROUGH STANTON GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR CALIFORNIA'S. GSM
WELL OR GIZMODO ONLINE IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR'S SEKARANGDO
WE HAVE A MISTER STANTON ON THE
LINE. YES MISTER STANTON IS ON
THE LINE VERY GOOD MISTER
STANTON- MY UNDERSTAND IS
YOU'RE THE SINGLE ACTUAL
WITNESS- SO YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE
IT ALL BUT YOU DO HAVE UP TO
FOUR MINUTES. FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BETTER
SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
STATIC CACKLE COURTEOUS- WELL
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL EDGE WAS
WELL OUTLINED BY IF WE DON'T.
DISTLLATE DRESSES THE ISSUE
OCCURRING WITH THE LAND
UNDERNEATH THE VOCAL HALL. IT'S
CONVERTED TO ANOTHER USE OR
EVEN PERHAPS TO NO USE AT ALL.
BY THE MOBILE HOME PARK OWNER
IT IS A SITUATION. OCCURRING
WITH INCREASING FREQUENCY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AS
LANDOWNERS RECEIVE HIGHER AND
BETTER USES FOR THE PROPERTY.
DIFFICULTLY NOTHING IN THIS
BILL PREVENTS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM ENACTING
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIVE MEASURES.
BILLS DOES NOT DICTATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OUTCOMES RELATED TO
A PARK OR CLOSER THAT POWER
WILL BE RETAINED BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I DO THIS BILL. IT
PORT PLEADED DOES HOWEVER ACT
RESIDENTS CONCLUDING EQUITY AT
MARKET VALUE WITH THEIR HOMES
WHICH OFFICE YOU ARE MOST
EXTENSION ONE THAT'S DUE TO
LANDOWNER INVESTMENT DECISIONS
THAT ARE MADE COMPLETELY
OUTSIDE OF THEIR CONTROL. IT
DOES THAT BY MINIMUM.
GOVERNMENT STANDARDS. THE
MARKET VALUE PER. WHICH IS
REALLY CRITICAL TO THIS ALREADY
EXIST OR IN OVER FIFTY LOCAL
CITY AND COUNTY ORDINANCES AND
HAS PROVEN AS RESULT TO BE. A
REASONABLE. A REASONABLE
PROVISION OF THOSE APPS
JURISDICTIONS. THE BILL ALSO
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE WHICH WOULD
PREVENT BOTH BLOCKED RESIDENTS
FROM RECEIVING THE BENEFITS OF
WHAT THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HATCHET TO LOG REGARDING THE
ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY. IT
RESTORE LOCAL CONTROL ALLOWING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS STAND WITH
ALL THEIR IT CAN'T PROTECTIONS
FOR THE VULNERABLE. RESIDENTS
RESIDING JURISDICTION. YEAH IT
ALSO- WITH RESPECT TO THE
SENATE DROPPERS PORSCHE BUILT
IS NOT PREVENTED. PARTIES FROM
ENTERING INTO USUALLY AGREED
UPON RENTAL AGREEMENTS
INCLUDING ALL TAKE YOUR LEASE
AGREEMENTS ORDERS THE BILL
ANYWAY INTERFERE WITH ANY
EXISTING ALL ALL. GRANT
AGREEMENT OR LEASE. SO ON THAT
BASIS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- NOW WILL LET'S GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBER DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES. I SEE
SOMEONE POINTING BUT NO ONE'S
MOVING TO THE MIKE. ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT- DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO WE WILL BEGIN AND-
AFTER YOU PROMPT WOULD YOU LET
US KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU
HAVE IN THE QUEUE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN ET QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND IF YOU ARE. USING A
SPEAKER PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN EDT YOU YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER. NINETY
SEVEN NINE NINE SEVEN WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN. THIS IS A LITTLE
FOR THANKSGIVING. I AM
REPRESENTING THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY RESIDENTS. OF RANCHO YO
OF SENIOR MOBILE HOME COMMUNITY
IN DAVIS. CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WINE FOUR NINE
FOUR FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE PROCEED. WHEN HIS DAD
DISCONNECTED WE GO TO LINE
NUMBER EACH LINE EACH EACH
CHRIS GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE ZERO FOUR ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY DAM
KERRY MEMBERS MARKET CARRILLO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE ARE AS STRONG SUPPORT OF. AB
TWENTY SEVEN EACH YEAR WE
ORIGINALLY LISTED AS FOSTER
WHICH WAS LISTED UNDER AT NINE
NINE NINE BUT WE ARE IN THE
COURT TROPICAL THAT HE BE.
SEVEN EIGHTY YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. PLEASE WHY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY LINE AT ONE AT
ONE. THE LINE IS A- HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OFFERED TO
YOU I MET HOUSING AND TENANTS
RIGHTS ACTIVIST. AND I HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL ONE OF
MY FRIENDS CURRENTLY IN A
MOBILE HOME PARK. RIDGE CLOSER
IN IN A HUGE. VARIETY THANK YOU
SIR ARE YOU NOT THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND LINE.
ONE ZERO ONE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER MY NAME IS LANDFILLS AND
IT DOES GET MANAGER FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAP FROM LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE AMATEUR
MOBILE IN STATE THE SENIOR
COMMUNITY AND TWELVE OTHER
MOBILE HOME PARKS IN THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH WITH MORE THAN
TWO THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY AN
EIGHTY YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX LINE OF ONE TWO SIX
THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LISA ARONSON
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION AND
CORPORATE OUTLOOK LAWCENTER AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EACH YEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE LINE ONE EIGHT TWO
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MOLLY FINAL DOMESTIC
WORKERS ASKING THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MY NUMBER TWENTY NINE
NINE TWO NINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL BRINKMAN
I LIVE IN L. NEEDLE MOBILE HOME
PARK IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I'M
THE GUEST WILL STATE SECRETARY
CHAIR THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
AND PRESIDENT OF OUR LOCAL
DESIGN CHAPTER IN BPO MIGHT
PARKS H. O. H. AND I IN THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX RESIDENTS
OF MY PARK STRONGLY SUPPORT. AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE AND
THIRTY ONE NINE ONE THREE ZERO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR OF LESLIE
WESTBROOK I RESIDE IN BEAUTIFUL
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN EIGHT TWO ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY NEIGHBORS AND
SEVEN MOBILE HOME PARKS IN THE
CITY OF CARPINTERIA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE NINETY ONE LINE AT
NINE AT ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HI I'M JOHN HARDIN HUNTINGTON
BEACH ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE P.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS. WHY
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN NINE SEVEN
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
LARRY GRANDDADDY'S GUN I'M HERE
FROM THE WORLD VICE PRESIDENT I
LIVE IN RANCHO SANTA BARBARA
MOBILE HOME PARK IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
STRONG SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE LINE AT ONE
EIGHT THREE ONE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ERIN COLLOCATED. I LIVE AT
TWELVE OAKS ARENA MOBILE HOME
PARK AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE METALLIC YES THEM- WELL
ONLY IF DRAWING SUPPORT. HERE
IS THE MOMENT COUNTY WE HAVE
SPOKE IN ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
MOBILE HOME PARK. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BYE EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
NAME AFFILIATION. AND POSITION
PLEASE. THANK YOU I SEVEN FIVE
SET FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MARK
O'CONNELL REGIONAL MANAGER FOR
GSM- WELL I'M CALLING FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA THE HOME OF
FIFTY NINE MOBILE HOME PARK. I
AND- OVER TEN THOUSAND MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS IN SAN JOSE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK. YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
EIGHTY FOUR LINE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SPEAKING TO
MYSELF TODAY I AM JUDY PABRIK
FOUNDER SUNNYVALE MOBILE HOME
PARK ALLIANCE. LOCATED IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. TWELVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN TWELVE
MOBILE HOME PARK STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. BY NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR LINE TO FOR YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KATHLEEN MADDEST AGS TURMOIL
CHAPTER PRESIDENT. IN
CARPINTERIA CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MANUFACTURED HOMEOWNERS
LIVING IN MOBILE HOME PARKS IN
CARPINTERIA IN SUPPORT. OKAY SB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WHEN I NUMBER
SIXTY THAT'S LINE SIX ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHELLE MONNING PRESIDENT OF
THE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND
I'M QUE ESTATES MOBILE HOME
PARK IN ROSE HILL PLASTER
COUNTY CALIFORNIA. MYSELF AND
RESIDENTS OF THREE NINE MOBILE
HOME PARKS IN PLASTER COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER
TWENTY THREE LINE TWO THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN MULHEARN I LIVE IN
A ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX STAY
IN YOUR MOBILE HOME PARK IN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. ADMIN
ASSISTANT MANAGER WITH GSM EL
AL. SANTA CRUZ COUNTY RESIDENTS
VERY CUTE CORD EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MY NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
LINE FIVE FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS
ROGER JOHNSON I AM THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SACRAMENTO AREA
COALITION OF THE MOBILE HOME
OWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
REPRESENTING OVER TEN THOUSAND
MORE HOMEOWNERS IN SEVEN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. COUNTIES
AND I- IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
LINE ONE EIGHT THREE THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAVID
WHELAN IN OUR LIVING SAN MARCOS
MOBILE HOME OF STATE IN SAN
MARCOS CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NUMBER SEVENTY SIX LINE AT
SEVEN SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JUDY PURPLE I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE H. AWAY AT
RANCHO SANTA PAULA IN VENTURA
COUNTY. BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
THE THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT RESIDENTS IN OUR PARK WE
SUPPORT EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE LINE AT
ONE TWO ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HIGHLINE ONE TWENTY ONE WE HAVE
TO LIGHT OPEN FOR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE LINE EIGHT ONE
THREE NINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
MOVE ALONG. THE LINE HAS
DISCONNECTED LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN-
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT IS ONE OF THEM ZERO. I
WILL GO BACK TO MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THE LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES.
THIS IS BRIAN I GOT DONE BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PLEASED
TO CO SPONSOR IT ALSO ON THE
OTHER PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT IN THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. OR THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE LINE
ONE THREE FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
LUCINDA LEHMAN GEOTHERMAL WELL
PREPPED. FOR THE DALLAS GARDENS
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS IN
CONCORD CALIFORNIA WE FULLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE MATAMATA
WRITER AND IF SO HOW MANY WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. JUST A MOMENT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY NUMBER
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TO. HI MY NAME IS BOBBY
MAGNUSON AYE NGS AND ALLOW
REGIONAL MANAGER OF ORANGE
COUNTY. I'M OFF OF THAT DOWN
THERE AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CITY. OF ORANGE MOBILE HOME
COALITION WHICH HAS ELEVEN
MOBILE HOME PARK. AND ONE
THOUSAND AND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR MODEL HOMEOWNERS
AND WE ARE ALL IN FAVOR AND
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE QUEUE AND IF NOT WOULD YOU
PLEASE REMIND THEM LAST LAST
CALL. ASIAN GENTLEMAN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAKE IT INTO THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EQ YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION.
OF LET'S SEE DO WE HAVE ANYONE
IDENTIFIED AS WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A JASON I KURD
OF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME
PARKS A PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE
AND ANDREW GOVERNOR OF THE
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND- I
REALLY BOTH ARE HERE IN PERSON-
TO- TESTIFIED PLEASE. FEEL FREE
TO GO AHEAD IDENTIFY YOURSELF
AND COLLECTIVELY OR FOUR
MINUTES. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- AFTER
GOVERNOR ABOUT THE WMA
RESPECTFULLY MUST OPPOSE TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO. UP UNTIL LAST
WEDNESDAY TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO WITH A BILL THAT DEALT WITH
MOBILE HOME PARK CLOSURES- BUT
ON WEDNESDAY IT WAS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE SENATOR BURKE SB NINE
NINE NINE DIED IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. BOTH BILLS THE PARK
ASPECT INTERESTING BECAUSE
APART CLOSER ASPECTS CONTENTION
IS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
INCAPABLE OF SETTING THE
STANDARDS THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO. ADJUDICATE APART CLOSURE.
AND S. B. NINE AT NINE I'M
BURKE ON THE LEAST BILL SAYS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT TO DO IN TERMS OF RENT
CONTROL AND THEREFORE DON'T
WANT THE STATE TO VOTE ON THEIR
BUSINESS OF TWO. CONTRADICTORY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STATE POLICIES
IN THE SAME BUILDING OBVIOUSLY
WE SEE THEM IN SEPARATE BILLS
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE A
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. IN TURN OF.
CLOSURES I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE EXAMPLE ACTUALLY FOR
BOTH BILLS. THERE'S NEVER BEEN
AN EXAMPLE THAT SHOWS A PARK
CLOSURES ACTUALLY. HARM TO
RESIDENTS. IN MR STONE'S
TESTIMONY THERE'S NO EXAMPLE
THE DEPARTMENT OF RESIDENT
HOUSING RECEIVE ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION. IN THE TWO YEARS
SINCE THIS BILL HAS BEEN ALIVE
NO EXAMPLES OF COME FOR. AND SO
WE BELIEVE THE BILL ACTUALLY
ISN'T NEEDED BECAUSE CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ENACT AND ENFORCE CLOSE
ORDINANCES FOR WHICH THEY DO.
AND IF YOU BELIEVE IN THE
PROMISE OF THE NINE NINE NINE
BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AMERICAN
SOLDIERS JURISDICTIONS KNOW
BEST HOW TO DO THIS. AND WHAT
DO YOU HAVE THAT SAME STATE
THAT THE SAME JURISDICTIONS
WILL BE ABLE TO DO A PARK
CLOSURE ORDINANCE. WE DON'T
KNOW WHY THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES
TO MOBILE HOMES WHY WOULD YOU
SIMPLY APPLY TO ONE TYPE OF
PROPERTY WHEN A PART. WENT OUT
WALMART'S ONE NOT LIQUOR STORES
IF IT'S SO CRITICAL THAT WE GET
LOW INCOME AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IMPORTANTLY WHY SHOULD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THEIR
HANDS TIED AT THE MOMENT IN
TIME WHEN THEY GO TO CLOSE THE
PARK. VERSUS BEING ABLE TO FILL
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT WHICH
LASTS FIVE YEARS. AT THE END OF
FIVE YEARS IF THEY'RE HOUSING
ELEMENT DOESN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT LOW INCOME AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING. WOULD BE. YOU
CAN. I'M FINE WORKING WITH ONE
OF OUR ATTORNEYS WHO IS THE
PERSON THAT DOES PARK CLOSURES
AND HER SIXTEEN YEARS OF DOING
THIS SHE HAS NEVER WORKED ON A
PARK CLOSURE THAT HAS RESULTED
IN A COMMERCIAL CHANGE EVERY
SINGLE PART BECAUSE SHE'S
WORKED ON HAVE BEEN FOR HOUSING
AND SO IN THAT REGARD WE
BELIEVE IT'S INCORRECT THAT
EVERY PART CLOSURE THAT OCCURS
AS BEEN FOR HOUSING. AND
FINALLY PART CLOSURES TAKE FOUR
TO FIVE YEARS I'M KNOW OF ONE
PART CLOSER ON IN THE ENTIRE
STATE RIGHT NOW NOT TO MEET.
TWO SEVENTY. THAT MOVE TO NINE
NINE NINE BECAUSE WE'RE LIMITED
THE REASON I KNOW NINE ONE
KILLED IN THE US COME WAS
BECAUSE WE SHOULD THAT INTO
LIKES STERN AND IT'S UNDER AND
THUNDER WERE IS THIS BILL WILL
BE TO RENT INCREASES AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RESIDENTS GET
CPI PLUS 1% FOR FIVE TEN
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY YEARS UNDER
THE L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROMISE WE'RE
SIMPLY ON JANUARY FIRST OF NEXT
YEAR GOING TO WRITE ONE YEAR
LEASES AT 3% AND PEOPLE CAN GET
3% LEASES AT ONE ONE HERE FOR
TWENTY YEARS IT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE. IT'S BAD PUBLIC
POLICY IT'S BAD POLITICS AND
FOR THIS WE ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU YOUR
NEXT WITNESS HAS A MINUTE. AND
TEN SECONDS. PERFECT THANK YOU
MATT CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON I
COULD WITHOUT A- GILBERT
ROSSMAN SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE. I WILL
BELIEVER THE POINTS MISTER
GARNER JUST MADE BUT JUST TO
SAY ON THE CONVERSION ISSUE.
ARE MAJOR CONCERNS REMAIN THE
SAME EVEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SOME
INSTANCES IN WHICH A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL EFFECTIVELY.
NOT HAVE A CHOICE TO ALLOW PARK
TO CLOSE. THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT WAS PROPOSING TO
CLOSE APART PLAY THE IN PLACE
MARKET VALUE OF EVERY HOME IN
THE PARK IF AND IF A RESIDENT
CAN'T FIND A REPLACEMENT
HOUSING IN ANOTHER PART. THAT
WILL ALWAYS BE THE CASE. NOT
ALL PARKS ARE CREATED EQUAL
SOME PARTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
OUR PARK OWNERS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PAY THAT IT'LL BE COST
PROHIBITIVE. AND IN THAT
INSTANCE AS MR GOVERNOR SAYS
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO THIS TODAY. TO
REQUIRED TODAY AND THEY OFTEN
DO- BUT THEY WILL HAVE NO
OPTION EVEN IF THEY BELIEVE THE
EXISTING PARK IS UNSAFE FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND LASTLY ON THE
LONG TERM LEASE PROVISIONS ON
TO SAY THAT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THOSE LEASES. YOU HAVE A
RIGHT. TO REJECT THE LEASE
AFTER THIRTY DAYS YOU HAVE A
RIGHT TO AVOID THE LOOK AT
LEAST AFTER THREE DAYS WE ARE
ALSO REMOVING THE INCENTIVE FOR
A PARK HONOR TO OFFER THAT AS
WELL. SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE URGE A NO VOTE ON THE THINK
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER WHO
WISH TO GIVE THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY IN OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL OTHER. IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES SHOULD MATTER MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO. WE CAN
BEGIN AND AFTER YOU TO PROMPT
THEM WOULD YOU INDICATE HOW
MANY THERE ARE IN THE QUEUE.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN ET QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. IF YOU ARE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE MAY NEED
TO PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS AGAIN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO. I HAVE
ONE PERSON IN THE QUEUE WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY LINE ONE TWO ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MA'AM CARE NUMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF TO SECURE
INVESTMENT COMPANY WE'D LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
SPEAKER FROM BELLEVUE AND A IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION-
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PROMPT THEM AND IF NOT PLEASE
ADVICE. AS A REMINDER IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION. OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN ET QUEUE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU LOOKS SO
THEN BRING IT BACK TO ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR WE'LL
START WITH SENATOR BURKE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO NUMBER
STONE THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING
IN YOUR BILL PROTECTIONS FOR
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS. SO THAT
THEY MAY BE A FOR THE SAME
KINDS OF PROTECTION THAT WOULD
BE AFFORDED OTHERS YES BUT
LOCAL. ORDINANCES PASSED
PROVIDING FOR RENT CONTROL IS
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR GOOD JUDGMENT
INCLUDING THESE ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS. THANK YOU SO. I'M
SORRY WAS AT A STATEMENT OR A
QUESTION. BOB. WELL I SUPPOSE
IT WAS A STATEMENT BUT THE- THE
QUESTION COULD BE WASN'T SMART
OF YOU TO INCLUDE THOSE
PROVISIONS THANK YOU SO MANY
MEMBERS. YEAH IT IT IS BUT IT
WAS NOT MY BRILLIANCE I HAD TO
RELY ON GOOD COUNSEL FROM. THE
SENATOR FROM SOUTHERN-CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO KNOW TO
BRING THIS INTO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE A
SENATOR WHITE CASKEY. MANAGER
OF QUESTION A VALUATION THE
OPPOSITION INDICATED THAT THE
BEST PRACTICE SIR. IS THAT WHEN
THEY VALUE THESE UNITS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE IN
PLACE MARKET OR VALUES COULD BE
USED THIS BILL REQUIRES SAID
CAN I HAVE A- CLARIFICATION
FROM THE AUTHOR ON. THROUGH THE
CHAIR CERTAIN JIM. YES WE ARE
REQUIRING THAT THE IN PLACE
MORE COULD VALUE D. WHAT IS
RECEIVED IF THEY CANNOT BE
PLACED IN ANOTHER MOBILE HOME
PARK OF THE LEAST SIMILAR
QUALITY IN THE SAME CITY OR
TOWN OR WHATEVER WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT MANUFACTURE
HOMEOWNERS GET APPROPRIATE
VALUE FOR THEIR- FOR THEIR HOME.
MADAM CHAIR IF I CAN FOLLOW UP
FRONT PAGE SEPT SIXTEEN OF OUR
THIRTY TWO PAID STAFF ANALYSIS
ON THIS BILL HE POINTS OUT THAT
THEIR EXPLOSIVELY REMOVING
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
HOMEOWNER TO OBTAIN A SECOND.
APPRAISAL UNTIL OF THE DECISION
MAKING- AGENCY TO HAVE TO
REVIEW THIS WHEN I GO TO PAGE
THIRTY OF OUR THIRTY TWO PAGE
STAFF ANALYSIS- WHICH IS AN
AMENDING SECTION FOUR OF
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION SIX
FIVE EIGHT THREE SIX. POINT
SEVEN BABY. E. R. BABY OUR BABY
BE TO IT THE LEADS ALL THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS IN IN THERE
ABOUT THAT THIS IS SECOND
APPRAISAL BUT WHEN WE GO DOWN
THIS SUBSECTION HE- HAS
AMENDMENTS TAKING OUT THE
APPRAISAL SUBMITTED. IN AND
PUTTING IN ADDITIONAL RELEVANT
DOCUMENTATION. IN MY READING OF
THAT MADAM CHAIR IS THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL RELEVANT
DOCUMENTATION THIS COULD BE ALL
SORTS OF INDICIA ABOUT
VALUATION ON THE- MOBILE HOME
VERSUS. A TRADITIONAL PRESIDENT
MUST BE DONE BY AN APPRAISAL SO
I'D LIKE CLARIFICATION. WITH
REGARD TO THIS ISSUE A
VALUATION WHAT THE OWNER OF THE
UNIT WOULD RECEIVE AND WHAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE. AVAILABLE
FOR THE- DECISION MAKER. THANK
YOU WITH THE MARKUP THAT'S AT
THE END AND THAT'S THE SECOND
PART THAT YOU REFERRED TO IS
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO PUT IN HERE AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO IT SURE IS THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY AS IT IS. BUT
STAPP CHING WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT IS THAT THEY
USE ALL RELEVANT DOCUMENTATION.
AND THAT THEY MAKE A FINDING.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GIVE.
FLEXIBILITY TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION IN ORDER TO MAKE
THE APPROPRIATE DETERMINATIONS
ON. WHAT THE FORMAL HOUSING
THERE LOSING BUT ALSO HOW THEY
PROTECT THAT PARTICULAR
HOMEOWNER WHO MIGHT BE LOSING
THEIR HOME AND NOT BE ABLE TO
BE THIS PLACE TO ANOTHER PARK
SO THIS IS AN EFFORT TO BUILD
IN SOME FLEXIBILITY AND ALLOW
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTION TO DO
WHAT IT CAN DO IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS. IN THEIR
OWN CITY MANAGER MANAGER WITH
THAT EXPLANATION ABOUT THE
EXPANSION OF DATA OR
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE USED
AND SUBMITTED BY THAT THE
OWNERS OF THE COACHES I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR Y. CASKEY SENATOR
BOARD USE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MAN POSE THREE ZERO A
QUESTION TO ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
I THINK- IF I CAUGHT HIS NAME-
WAS THE TOURNEY EICHER LAST
LAST NAME CURTAINS. HOME AGO.
YES I THINK- YOU STILL PRESENT
WITH US PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
POST YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU I
WANTED TO. JUST GOT OF UP ON
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IT WAS
YOU THAT MENTIONED. WHEN YOU.
WHEN YOU HAVE IT YOU HAVE AN
APARTMENT COMPLEX. THEY GETS
CONVERTED THE TAPE TO CONDOS.
IS THERE A MANDATORY RELOCATION
PROGRAM IN PLACE IN SUCH A WAY
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE OWNER OF
THE CONVERTING APARTMENT SYSTEM
TO PAY FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
RENTS ELSEWHERE OR ANY SORT OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT THAT IS
MARKET RESPONSIVE. YEAH I
APOLOGIZE CENTER YOU GIVE ME A
BIT OF A PROMOTION I AM NOT
MYSELF AN ATTORNEY I TO MY
KNOWLEDGE I I'M NOT AWARE OF
THAT BUT ALL DEFERRED MISTER
GOVERNOR HE DOES NOW HELLO SIR
I THOUGHT YOU WERE YOU WORK AT
A LAW FIRM. FIVE I JUST HEARD A
BUNCH THE LAST NAMES I JUST
ASSUMED IT WAS A LOFT. IF IT'S
ANY KIND. SOME WOULD CONSIDER
THAT A PROMOTION IT AND SOME.
THAT ARE TO DEMOTION SO. BUT MR
GOVERNOR SHOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
TO THE QUESTION WOULD YOU
REPHRASE IT THE BRIEFLY SO THAT
WE COULD- TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
IS IT BECAUSE OF MOBILE HOMES
ARE. A BIT OF A DIFFERENT BREED
IN SO FAR AS- THEY ARE NOT AS
PLENTIFUL. AS APARTMENTS. THAT
IN AN APARTMENT CONVERSION
SCENARIO- IT. IS EXPECTED THAT
THE OWNER OF THE APARTMENT THAT
IS CONVERTING THEM TO CONDOS.
TAKES ON THE RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
THIS BILL MMHM. ACTUALLY WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS SET THE NEW
STANDARD FOR MOBILE HOME PARK
CLOSURES ONLY PRIOR TO THIS
BILL IN CURRENTLY IN LAW MOBILE
CLOSURES ARE THEY ARE FOR
MOBILE HOME PARKS IN THEIR
SPECIFIC TO IT- IN TERMS OF
MOBILE HOME PARKS WE HAVE NOT
FOUND ONE THAT DOESN'T TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT RELOCATION CLASS-
WE HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN AN
EXAMPLE RESIDENTS WEREN'T
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED AND
MOVED IN SO I CAN'T REALLY
SPEAK TO THE APARTMENT CONTACTS
IN ITSELF BUT I DO KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO RELOCATION COSTS IN
MOBILE HOME PARKS AND THEY'RE
ADEQUATE AND FOR INSTANCE IN
SAN JOSE ON THE WINCHESTER
MOBILE HOME PARK. RESIDENTS
WERE GIVEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THEIR COACH AND WERE GIVEN THE
RIGHT TO MOVE TO AN AFFORDABLE
APARTMENT BUILDING ON THAT VERY
SAME PROPERTY AT THE EXACT SAME
RENT THEY WERE PAYING BEFORE.
ALRIGHT THAT HELPS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MY OF MY LAST MY LAST
FALL OR I THINK YOU HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT. THERE
ARE SUFFICIENT LEGAL SAFEGUARDS
THAT EXIST WITHIN THE STATE AND
CERTAINLY AT THE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. IN YOUR OPINION THAT
THIS LEGISLATION IS NOT. NEEDED
CAN YOU EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON. YOUR POINTS EARLIER
BECAUSE I WASN'T CERTAIN I
CAUGHT ALL OF THEM. THANK YOU
YES. WE WOULD EXPECT BASED ON
THE CONTENTION OF THE BILL THAT
THERE WOULD BE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHERE PARK CLOSE AND RESIDENTS
WEREN'T GIVEN ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION OR RELOCATION
COSTS. TO GET THOSE EXAMPLES
WERE NEVER GIVEN WHICH MEANS
THAT OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES
OF MOBILE HOME PARK CLOSURES
THAT ARE TURNING TO THE WORKING
ON THE REALLY HASN'T BEEN A
PROBLEM BECAUSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REALLY DO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF THE RESIDENTS
NOT THE PARK OWNER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT. FIVE HUNDRED
RESIDENTS ON THEIR DOORSTEP
COMPLAINING ABOUT COST AND SO
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THOSE EXAMPLE
SO WE'RE NOT SURE WHY THIS BILL
IS EVEN NEEDED BECAUSE
NOTHING'S BEEN SHOWN TO BE
BROKEN OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS. OKAY THANK YOU. I THINK
AND ALL IT ALL IN HERE THAT.
WE'VE DEALT WITH RENT CONTROL.
ISSUES IS- THIS YEAR AND
CERTAINLY LAST YEAR. AND IT
COMES DOWN I THINK PHILOSOPHY
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT. EITHER
DIRECTLY FROM THE STATE OR
INDIRECTLY FROM THE LOCALITY.
THAT RENT CONTROL WOULD HELP-
OUR HOUSING STOCK. I THINK
BASED ON THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
I'VE HAD WITH WITH BUILDERS.
WITH FOLKS THAT CAPITALIZE.
THOSE IN DEVELOPMENT- AND THOSE
THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE BE
INTERESTED IN. INCREASING THE
HOUSING STOCK. IS THAT. WHEN
YOU DISINCENTIVE VISE THE
MARKET IN SUCH A WAY IT WILL
ACTUALLY COMPOUND THE PROBLEM I
DON'T MEAN UNDERVALUED THAT THE
ISSUES AND- IN AREAS THAT I
THINK HAVE OUT PRICED. OF
VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY AND I THINK
WE KNOW THE EXAM OF SOME OF THE
BARE AND ELSEWHERE WHERE PEOPLE
JUST SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
THE OUTRAGEOUS RATES. BUT I
WOULD CAUTION. AS A MATTER OF
POLICY. THAT THOSE LIMITED
INSTANCES. ON THE COAST BE
APPLIED STATEWIDE AS POLICY.
RENT CONTROL IS A DISINCENTIVE
TO INVESTING IN OUR HOUSING
STOCK. AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN
ENOUGH STUDIES- ON THE SUBJECT
THAT. IT COMES DOWN TO A
PHILOSOPHICAL STANDPOINT BUT
IT'S NOT A FACTUAL ONE SO MY
OPINION- WHEN YOU ADD IN. ALL
THESE DIFFERENT CONSIDERATIONS
WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES ARE WE
ACTUALLY HELPING OUR HOUSING
STOCK. BY THIS TYPE OF PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OR THOSE SIMILAR
AND I THINK THE ANSWER'S GOING
TO PROVE- THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IN WAYS THAT WE
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE IMAGINED
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S A IT'S A
DOOMED- ALMOST IRREVERSIBLE
PROCESS. THANK YOU SEEN NO
OTHER HAND UP THE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE POINT OUT THE MOBILE
HOME PARKS ARE NOT THE SAME AS
APARTMENT BUILDINGS YOU ARE THE
MOBILE HOME IS REALLY NOT VERY
MOBILE. AND SO THEY ARE IN A
BIND IF THE PARK CLOSES IT'S
NOT LIKE AN APARTMENT BUILDING
THAT. SHUTS DOWN BECAUSE UNLIKE
TENANT IN AN APARTMENT BUILDING
THE MOBILE HOMEOWNER LOSES A
MAJOR ASSET WHICH IS HIS OR HER
HOME. SO AND IT'S OFTEN THEIR
ONLY MAJOR ASSET- SO I THINK
THIS BILL DOES A BETTER JOB OF
COMPENSATING THEM FOR THAT LOSS
AND I THINK THE AMENDMENTS MAKE
CLEAR WE ARE NOT TYING THE
HANDS OF THE LOCALS WHEN THEY
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT TO
APPROVE A PARK CLOSURE TO CALL
THE PARK OWNERS BUT NINE IS
PROBABLY A FIRST IN MY- CAREER
HERE AT THE- THE BATTLES
BETWEEN THE A PARK OWNERS IN
THE HOMEOWNERS ARE LEGEND- AND
CONTINUE. TO THIS VERY DAY- THE
QUESTION OF RENT CONTROL.
NOTHING IN THE BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS- TO IMPOSE
RENT CONTROL. ON MOBILE HOMES-
AND IF THEY DECIDE TO DO IT
NOTHING REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO APPLY THAT
RENT CONTROL TO LONG TERM
LEASES SO- I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE CLEAR WITH THIS BILL DOES
AND DOESN'T TO. AND I SEE THIS
BILL ALSO IS RETURNING LOCAL
CONTROL ON ON THIS ISSUE AND-
IF THE OPPONENTS THINK THAT
EXEMPTING LONG TERM LEASES FROM
LOCAL RENT CONTROL IS BETTER
POLICY- I INVITE YOU TO
CONVINCE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF
THAT I KNOW THAT THE LEADERSHIP
IN THE CITY OF CARPINTERIA
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT- FEELS
VERY DIFFERENTLY AND STRONGLY
ACTUALLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
AND I AM HAPPY TO DO SO AS WELL
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND SEE
THE SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS
AND WHAT HAVE YOU PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I REST ON YOUR ARTICULATE
STATEMENT. AND ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION WE HAVE
THEN THE BEFORE US IS THERE. IS
THERE. A MOTION BY SENATOR
AKOWSKI THANK YOU THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MADAM CONSULTANT
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YES THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO STONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE BURGESS. BARGES NO THE
RUSSELL. HI THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I. MELENDEZ
NO COULD COULD COULD EVERYBODY
TURN THE MICROPHONES ON I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO THE RUSSELL. I
THINK HE JUST LEFT. I DID I SO
I THINK YOU. MELENDEZ NOW LINDA
SAID NO THANK YOU MONNING HI
MONNING HI THANK YOU STERN.
STERN AYE. CAN YOU SHOW SORRY
ONE SECOND STERN STERN AYE
STERN I THINK YOU I'M BURKE-
BURGER HI CAN YOU SHOW HIM ON
THE SCREEN CAN NEED A BURKE. I
AM BERG I THINK YOU WHITE HOUSE
HIGH. CASKEY I HE FOR HER TIME
EXCEPT THAT SEVENTY SENATOR
VERY GOOD THE BILL IS OUT OF
THE VOTE COUNT TO SEVEN I USED
TO KNOWS- NO NEED TO PUT ON
CALL THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU
SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AND BEFORE
WE GO ON TO OUR NEXT BILL I'D
LIKE TO GO BACK AND LIFT THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IF WE COULD DO THAT. ADAM
CONSULTANT THE CA CALENDAR
PLEASE YES- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DITOMASSO I DID US SO I AM
BURKE. AMERICAN HI AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THEIR BURKE.
AMERICA HI- BURKE I THANK YOU
THAT IS NINE TWO ZERO SENATOR
ALL RIGHT NINE TWO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND OUT- AGAIN COLLEAGUES-
BECAUSE MOST OF THE PEOPLE
OBSERVING ARE OBSERVING.
THROUGH A TELEPHONE OR THROUGH
COMPUTERS AND ALSO WE HAVE TO
SPEAK UP SO THAT THAT WHATEVER
IT IS IT'S BEING DISCUSSED OR
VOTED ON CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO THEM AS WELL. ADJUSTER
REMINDER WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO FILE ITEM. SEVEN TO HAVE AN
AUTHOR HERE. SENATOR MORNING
WILL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB. TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY THREE AND THE CENTER
MORNING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT- IS THERE ANY WOULD BE
OF ASSISTANCE TO HAVE BEEN
PRESENT AT THE AT THE PODIUM OR
IS I THOUGHT WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO PRESENT FROM MY DESK I'M
GLAD TO GO TO THE PODIUM I
THOUGHT THE PROTOCOL. STAY HERE
IS THAT. AGAIN JUST FOR THE
VISUALS FOR THOSE WHO WERE OF
THE SERGEANT JUST INSTRUCTED ME
TO PRESENT FROM MY DESK. VERY
GOOD THEN THE FLOOR'S YOURS
FROM YOUR DESK SENATE MONEY YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE SHE
APPRECIATES THEIR TIME AND
FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL. WITH THE
INCREASED UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS EMERGING FROM
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY ALREADY BE
IN DEBT ARE LIKELY TO FIND
THEMSELVES IN EVEN GREATER
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. AS A RESULT
OF OUR CURRENT RECESSION SOME
LOCAL CONSUMERS AND HOMEOWNERS
MAY ALSO BE FACING THE THREAT
OF LOSING THEIR HOMES. THE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
RECENTLY COMPLETED A REPORT
THAT INVESTIGATED THE PROCESS
WHERE CREDITORS HAVE BEEN
SEEKING TO FORECLOSE UPON HOMES
FOR SMALL AMOUNTS OF DEBT. THE
PRACTICE OF FORCED HOME SALES
BASED ON SMALL AMOUNTS OF DEBT
IS PROBLEMATIC IN EXACERBATES
THE EXISTING HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN PARTICULAR THIS
PRACTICE HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE WILL ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL NOT LOSE THEIR HOME. THERE
A DAY. IN WILL FORECLOSURES ON
A PERSON'S PRINCIPAL PLACE OF
RESIDENCE IF THE CONSUMER DEBT
IS NOT TIED TO THEIR HOME. THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
SUBMITTED A LATE FORMAL
OPPOSITION LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY. ON BEHALF
OF THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE I'D LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE POINTS RAISED IN
THEIR LETTER. THE CHANGE TO
PREVIOUS LANGUAGE WAS TO
ADDRESS QUESTIONS RAISED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS WELL AS
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED IT IS THE
AUTHOR'S PERSPECTIVE THAT THE
CHANGES MADE WE'RE NOT
EXPANDING THE BILL BUT WE'RE
DESIGNED TO CLARIFY ITS INTENT.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL WAS TO
LIMIT FOR CLOSURES TO DEBTS
SUCH AS MORTGAGES AND HOME
EQUITY LOANS THAT WERE SECURED
BY THE BORROWER'S HOME AT THE
TIME THAT THE DEBT WAS
INCURRED. IF FORCED HOME SALES
ARE PROHIBITED ONLY IN THE CASE.
OF UNSECURED CONSUMER DEBT THEN
SECURED CREDITORS SUCH AS A
PAWN SHOP LENDERS HOME
APPLIANCE AND FURNITURE LENDERS
AND SECURED CREDIT CARD LENDERS
WOULD RETAIN THE RIGHT TO
FORECLOSE ON A DEBTOR'S HOME.
THAT WOULD MEAN CREDITORS WOULD
TAKE A PERSON'S HOME FOR DEBTS
OF A FEW THOUSAND OR EVEN A FEW
HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT IS
PRECISELY WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO STOP. THE LANGUAGE
HAS BEEN REVIEWED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WHICH IS
INDICATED THAT IT ADDRESSES ITS
QUESTIONS THIS LANGUAGE WAS
ALSO REVIEWED BY COMMITTEE
STAFF IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY CALIFORNIAN LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS COALITION AND
SUPPORTED BY LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS AND CONSUMER
JUSTICE GROUPS. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY-
FIRST WE GET TOTO FROM THE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
FOLLOWED BY PROFESSOR PRASAD
KRISHNAMOORTHY FROM UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF LAW. THROUGH THE
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO PRESENT ARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORNING OUR FIRST
WITNESS MISTER MIGUEL SOTO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD BETWEEN THE TWO
OF YOU YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES. TO BE DIVIDED AS YOU
CHOOSE THAT MR SODA THE FORTY
EIGHT. HI GUYS. HELLO MY NAME
IS NATASHA I'M A SECRETARY A
CLINICAL INSTRUCTOR AT THE
STATE COMMITTEE LAWCENTER WHICH
IS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THE EXTENT OF
TIME JUST PUT INTO THIS BILL.
CAN YOU LAW CENTER SERVICE
LOOKING. EACH THAT COALITION.
THE SINGLE OF HOME. FOLLOWING
MOSTLY SENIOR IN. AND PEOPLE
COLOR. LISTEN FOR SMALL AND
SECURE DEBTS. AND CREDIT CARD
WITHOUT HIS AROUND BY DOLLARS.
MANY OF YOU HAS TO PER MONTH
AND EVEN YOU. THAT MORE THAN
ONE CLIENT GETTING AND MEDICAL
CARE TO BE HELLO. BECAUSE OF
HIGH INTEREST RATES IMPACT ON
PEACE THE CLIENT CAN NEVER
CATCH UP AND THEY OPEN THE SUIT.
RIGHT NOW. ASSEMBLY MIGHT LOSE
THE OF IT HAS ALREADY BILL OR A
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR CREDIT CARD
DEBT. HIGH SCHOOL TEACHERS AND
PATIENT ON. WORKER AND OTHER
VULNERABLE HAVE HAD TO LEARN
MOST OF RIGHT NOW. CALIFORNIA
ANY ON YOUR CONSUMER OUT LIKE
COMPACT LITTLE. YOUR CALL LET
ME HOMEOWNERS. IN THE COMP.
MOTOR A. RIVER. COVER NAY.
WHICH IS WHAT. HIGH LOW IN
COMMUNITY THANK YOU OF COLOR
IT'S ONLY GONNA MAKE IT WORSE.
I MANY OF OUR LOCAL HOMEOWNER
AT LEAST THEIR INCOME JUST JOB.
TRAIL. AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
OF THE SUBJECT. A LOT OF RISK
COMMANDER FINANCIAL. BY CABINET.
THE JUDGMENT UNDER THE FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT FAMILY HOME SHOULD
NEVER LOST BECAUSE THE HOMER
NOT PAY UP ON THE- CREDIT CARD
DEBT. PAYDAY LOAN. AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY OF THE CHANCE TO
HELP NEIGHBORS AT HOME AND
PEACE OF MIND. FINALLY THE
LETTER THANK AGAIN COMMITTEE. A
LETTER CONTAINS THAT NOT PRETTY
X. US WHAT THE FACT WILL
REVIEWING THE LETTER EVEN.
THANK YOU FOR THE- OF THIS BILL
AND WE ARE DRIVE. BETTER
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE- PROFESSOR
KRISHNAMOORTHY WITH US IF YOU
ARE WITH US YOU ARE ON MUTE WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU. HELLO THIS IS A
COMPETITORS MARKET. HI MY NAME
IS YEAH COMMITTEE THAT'S
WRITING THIS ABOUT
KRISHNAMOORTHY AND I'M A
PROFESSOR OF MINE USED TO
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW RATE HE
CAN CONDUCT RESEARCH IN THE
AREA THAT REGULATION CONTRACT
AND ECHO. I ONLY DID YOU CAN BE
A LAW SCHOOL AT THE EIGHTEEN
MAKES THE BERKELEY BOB OF THE-
AND MY READERS BEEN PUBLISHED
IN THE JOURNAL WHO NOTHING. I
AM SEEKING A THE COURT OF AB
TWO COURSES. THE I BELIEVE IT
WILL MAKE. BETTER OFF. FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE BILL JUDGE
DEBTORS KEEP THEIR HOMES. WHICH
IS BOTH MALE. AND ECONOMICALLY.
YOU COULD NOT BE DONE MORE DIRE.
OUTSPOKEN THE BOOK PEOPLE ARE
THEIR DEBT AS A RESULT OF THE
NINETEEN. AND MORE DEFAULT ON
THE OR- AT ONE BENEFITS PAID
OUT. BUT THIS IS THE KIND
CONCERN YEAH. THANK AB TWO FOUR
SIX ON. HOW EVEN. EFFECT ON
MARKETS BECAUSE COURT BUT I'M
STILL OUTSIDE OF TRADITIONAL.
AND ARE RARE. EIGHTY POSTED
THREE. MOST CREDIT OR- MORTGAGE
LENDERS CAN. ARE IN HIGH TO
THEIR- SECURED LENDERS RETAIN
THE RIGHT TO PROVISIONAL. OR
BANK. AND THOSE ARE MORE CALM
THAN ORDERS. OTHER BY. ARE YOU
YOU CAN TELL FOR NOW. THEM.
WHAT WOULD BE THE BROADER
CREDIT MARKET EFFECT EIGHTY TWO
POINT SIX THREE. MOST
IMPORTANTLY DECENT THAT ARE
LIKELY TO BE SMALL BECAUSE OF
THE RARITY OF COURT ORDERED
SALE BUT STILL POSSIBLE TO
ESTIMATE THAT. YOU DIDN'T
CRITICAL RESEARCH AND ECONOMIC
BASED ON INCREASES IN A
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION LEVEL THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT. APART
EIGHTY TWO BECAUSE THEY'RE WE
WOULD ACTUALLY. INCREASE THE
TOTAL. IT INCREASE IN THE
TICKET OF LOCAL HOMEOWNERS. WHY
EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX WE WOULD
ASK THINK CRIME DEMAND. BUT
BORROWER VAL AT YOUR. READ IT
BACK TO OUTWEIGH ANY IN WHAT.
OKAY EIGHTY TWO POINT THREE
WOULD HELP CONSUMER ENSURE BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF THE FOR THE
JOB BECAUSE THEY WILL NO LONGER
HAVE TO GO VITAL TO MAKE THE
REQUIRED TO AVOID. AB TO PUT IT.
I LIKE HAD ANY EFFECT ON THE
LAKE. OF THE CARE CREDIT MARK.
IT MAY RESULT IN LOSS. THANK
YOU IT FROM BARTLETT YOU FOR
YOUR TOTAL. YES SIR THE YOU FOR
YOUR TEST OF GOD. QUITE A BIT
OVER WILL HAVE TO GIVE THE
OFFICE. PEOPLE TO IT OF FORM
AND FOR. SO THEY YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR TEST
MOVING UP OVER ALONG. EIGHT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE GOT BY.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME. LET'S
CHECK AND SEE IF ANY OTHER
WITNESS IN. IN THE CHAMBER. A
SEEING NON ARE THERE ANY
WITNESS WHICH TO TEST IN ROOM
TWELVE SEEING NO IN ROOM ONE
TWO. WE WILL TAKE IT NOW THE-
PEOPLE ON THE PHONES MOTOR. IF
YOU TO A PROMPT IN. WAITING TO
TEST OF. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU ARE A PART
PROJECT ONE ZERO AT THAT TIME.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH A LINE
NUMBER ONE FORTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS TYLER
TRODDEN ON BEHALF OF CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE FORTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON AND MEMBERS
DANIEL CAMPBELL CARTER ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSORS AS WELL
AS THE NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW
CENTER IN STRONG WORK THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ALFRED I LIVE IN
BERKELEY AND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MATAMATA WRITER HOW MANY
WITNESSES ARE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. WE
STOPPED SIX THANK YOU. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED WITH THE NEXT
NEXT PERSON. NINE ONE FORTY
NINE. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE THIRTY NINE. THAT
AFTERNOON. THAT ARE LIKE OUR
NEIGHBOR HE'S NOT SURE THE
PARTICIPATION SAMPLE DISCOUNT
CALLING ON CONGRESS TO MAKE
WORKING THREE I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR EYES OUT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE.
ONE FIVE ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ROBERT NINE KENDRICK
ATTORNEY AT OLDER LAW AND
ADVOCACY I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. THOUGH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE ONE FORTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS STACY CUT AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER LAW
CLINIC AT UC IRVINE AND ON
BEHALF OF MY CLIENTS I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
ONE TWENTY SIX. I DO BELIEVE
THERE AND THE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION AND COMBINE IT WITH
THE PUBLIC LAST CENTER IN
ORANGE COUNTY CALLING IN DRUNK
REPORT IS AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE AND AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE ONE FIFTY ONE CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MARKKULA HOUSE THERE'S ONE MORE
IN HERE RIGHT NOW ONE MOMENT
APPLYING ONE FIFTY FIVE. HELLO
JERRY MEMBERS OF THE BENEFIT
AND I'M BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE MATTER
MODERATOR. THERE IS NOT A RIGHT
WOULD YOU CHECK ONE MORE TIME
SO THAT WE CAN BE ASSURED THAT
WE HAVE HEARD FROM EVERYONE WHO
IS IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE. IF YOU AREN'T
A PART PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU- AT THIS POINT
WE WERE UNAWARE OF ANY WITNESS
OR ANY OPPOSITION WE DID NOTE
THERE IS SOME LATE OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE. WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE MATTER MODERATOR ON
THE WITNESS LINE. S. N.
OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION
CORRECT. I'VE BEEN IN A PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME RIGHT
BEFORE WE GET TO THOSE WHO JUST
WISHING TO GIVE THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESS. WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE WHO IS
IN THE CHAMBER. SEEING NO ONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THE WITNESSES. AND INDICATE HOW
MANY THERE ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE
IN THE QUEUE. NOT GOING TO BE A
LION ONE EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MATT AND SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MELANIE CUEVAS WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
YOUR MAIN AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SENATE ANYWAY OUT BUT I'M NOT
AS AN OFFICE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE. ALREADY WE WILL
BRING IT BACK THEN TO THE
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THE BILL AND SENATOR MONNING
FOR PRESENTING IT. YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN FACING A HOUSING
CRISIS FOR LONG BEFORE COVERT
NINETEEN AND- THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN CAUSED BY THIS VIRUS
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
DENIAL ABOUTTHE SCOPE OF THAT
DOWNTURN IS REALLY WREAKING
HAVOC ON CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
ENFORCING A FAMILY FROM THEIR
HOME IS EXTRAORDINARILY
DISRUPTIVE AND DEVASTATING WE
KNOW THIS SO DEBT COLLECTORS
KNOW CONSUMERS WILL TAKE
DRASTIC STEPS TO AVOID A FORCED
HOME SALES SUCH AS TAKING OUT
HIGH INTEREST LOANS
UNCONSCIONABLE LOANS- OR MAKING
EARLY WITHDRAWALS FROM
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS. THAT'S
GOING TO DRIVE CONSUMERS INTO
FAR MORE DEBT- IN THE LONG TERM
AND THE PROHIBITION IN THIS
BILL ON FORCED HOME SALES- IS
AN ESSENTIAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURE- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS SO I WON'T GO
ANY. FURTHER AND WILL THE
SIMPLY CALL UPON IT WILL ASK A
CENTER WHERE CASKEY AND THEN MR
CENTER BORCHERS- TO GO AHEAD IF
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. OR WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A STATEMENT. MAN EARLIER
ASKING MANAGER I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THE IS AN AND MEASURE.
CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURE I
DID HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR- PROFESSOR CHRISTIAN COME
MURPHY- IN AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION MANAGER RIGHT ONE OF
THE EXCEPTIONS DEALS WITH
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE OVER SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS- WORTH OF UNSECURED
DEBT. EXCEPT FOR STUDENT LOANS
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT ALL
STUDENT LOANS ARE CONSECUTIVE
CONSUMER DEBTS FOR PERSONAL
FAMILY AND HOUSEHOLD VIEWS
REGARDLESS OF THE AMOUNT THAT
THEY HAVE JUST. IN A BUN SORT
OF AN EASY QUESTION THAT IF THE
PROFESSOR COULD IGNORE HER
THANK YOU FISHER YOU STILL ON
THE LINE. I'M STILL HERE WOULD
YOU MISDIAGNOSIS WORKED OUT
DEFENDER SAID CRAP. ALL RIGHT
SO AND STE PAGE OF OUR STAFF
REPORT WE TALK ABOUT THE AUTHOR
IN THE PROPONENTS ABOUT THIS
BALANCING ACT BETWEEN THE
INTEREST TO CREDITORS IN THE
INTERESTS OF CONSUMERS MY
QUESTION PROFESSOR IS THAT. YOU
KNOW SO THE DEBTS THAT YOU'VE
EXCLUDED EXEMPTED ARE NON CASH
CHARGE FULL DEBTS IN BANKRUPTCY
YOU KNOW WAGES FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS TAXES YOU KNOW CHILD
SUPPORT AND FEES THE GOVERNMENT
ARE ALREADY NOT. DOES EXEMPTION
IN A IN A BANKRUPTCY ISN'T THAT
ENOUGH THAT RATHER THAN IF YOU
REALLY GO TO TRY TO. HELP
CONSUMERS THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE FOR SALES AND I AND I
KNOW THAT I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
THE FOR SALES ARE- REAR SOME
PERHAPS YOU'RE NOT THINKING
THAT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
COUNTY. TAX COLLECTORS ARE
GOING TO GO AFTER PEOPLE'S
HOUSES BUT HE MY COMMENT IS NOT
GIVEN THE NON DISCHARGE ABILITY
ONE WHY WOULD WE WANT TO EXEMPT
THOSE TYPES OF. UNSECURED DEBT.
WHY DON'T I WILL- AT STATE YOU
WORK ON THAT BUT I DON'T LIKE-
MIGUEL TO THAT TO ME IN ON THIS
QUESTION. AS YOU MENTIONED WE
TRIED TO STRIKE. A BALANCE
BETWEEN- DOES THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO GET EXEMPTIONS ARE
WORKING THIS BILL AND THOSE
THAT WHICH WE THOUGHT. THERE
WOULD BE STRONGER- POLITICAL
OPPOSITION TO. REMOVING THE ART
OF COURSE IN EXISTING AND
PORTABILITY PROVISION AND THAT
LIST WITH BLACK OUR JUDGMENT.
ON THE DIFFICULTIES WE WOULD
ENCOUNTER IN TRYING TO- FOR
THAT THOSE OPERATORS FROM BEING
ABLE TO. ATTACH A LIEN ON THE
HOME AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY.
FORCES SALE BUT PERHAPS THE GAL
WOULD LIKE TO WAIT ON THIS
BECAUSE HE HAS GREATER
EXPERIENCE I WOULD NEED THAT.
WORK AND YOU CAN SEE UP. THE HI
THIS IS MICHELLE. THIS IS RIGHT
NINETY WITH THAT WE H. IN AND
BEEN AT BOTH CHECKED IN WITH
SEVERAL BUT STICKLE. AND
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE GENERAL
OFFICE HAD. THE COMPANY CARE
AND PER SE BUT INTEREST IN THIS
MEASURE AND IT BEING THE WAY
TO. ADDITION I THE HEART OF
THIS. COMES TO ONE OF BASIC AN
EXTRA ONE OF PER. TAKES OF
CONCERN LOAN IT NOT UNDER OR BY
THE MAJORITY OF THEM THAT
FAILURE PAY THIS ONE HAPPEN ON.
BECAUSE ALL AND SO WHAT WE ARE
ABOUT WARRANT WITHIN THAT FIELD
PER SE. OUR FOCUS HERE IS ON
HELPING PEOPLE. IF THEY- ARE.
TERMS OF THE LOAN MEET. THAT
THEY HAD WHEN IT PROBLEM IN
THIS. MADAM IN I GUESS THE GETS
ME MY FACE. CARVE OUT WE WERE
TALKING OF LARA ON SECURE DEBT
IN THESE ARE FINANCIAL AND I
KNOW THAT THE BAY ARE TO THESE
ARE YOU CAN'T FIND A MORE
SOPHISTICATED CREDITOR IN THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
OPERATING IN THIS IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE IN THE- IN THE- STATE N.
THEY HAVE ALL THE OTHER TOOLS
REMEDIES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LAW APPEALS TO THEM. AND WAGE
GARNISHMENT LEVYING OF BANK
ACCOUNTS THEN IN GETTING A
JUDGMENT AND PLACING A LIEN ON
THE PROPERTY- IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IT'S- UNFORTUNATE THAT
THAT WERE OPENING UP THIS DOOR
TO ALLOW THESE FOR SALES TO
CONTINUE WITH THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED CREDITORS. THAT
DEBT THAT HOLD LARGEST AMOUNT
OF DEAD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M WORRISOME ABOUT
WELL IT'S NOT USE NOW. D.
REMEDIES IN MY- OPINION WOULD
BE ADEQUATE FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE TO GO ABOUT OTHER THAN
OPENING UP THE DOOR AND I'M
WONDERING WHY. I MEAN I GUESS I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE POLITICAL
SIDE BUT ACADEMICALLY YOU KNOW
AND THEN SECURITY IT IS AN
UNSECURED DEBT THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE AND- THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
THAT STATUS. REGARDLESS OF
SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN DOLLARS OR
ORDERS SEVEN CENTS. SO DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE. THROUGH THE CHAIR
YET THROUGH CHAIR TO A
PROFESSOR AT KRISHNA KUMAR FEE.
HI I THINK WE BROADLY AGREE
WITH THAT SENTIMENT- WHAT YOU
SAID WHAT WE TRIED TO DO- YOU
KNOW TO GO SHE ASIANS WITH THE
OTHER SIDE WITH TO- YOU KNOW
PROTECT CONSUMERS- TO THE
DENTIST AND I WE THOUGHT
POSSIBLE NOW AND WE LOOK AT THE
BIGGEST CATEGORY DID THAT
MEDICAL DEBT FOR EXAMPLE IS NOT
GOING TO COME UNDER THAT.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION EXEMPTION
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HOLD MEDICAL
DEBT- STUDENT LOANS WHICH ARE
LIKELY TO BE OR CAN BE AN ACT
THAT THE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AS FAR AS YOU
MENTIONED- EXCLUDED FROM THAT
EXEMPTION AND SO WHAT WE'RE
LEFT WITH IS PERHAPS- CREDIT
CARD DEBT OR OTHER CATEGORIES
BUT IF YOU KIND OF LOOKED AT
THE FEDERAL RESERVE- DATA ON
WHAT THE CREDIT BALANCES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE. IT EXCEEDINGLY
RARE FOR THERE TO BE SOMETHING
LIKE A BIG I THINK YOUR
CONSUMER DEBT FACT SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT WE THOUGHT
WE WERE LARGELY COULD. WE HAD A
BY THE. HELLO ALL GET. I WOULD
NEED FEEL THE- DID NOT BY. A
CONSUMER DATA THAT WE'RE ACT.
AT THAT LEVEL WE THOUGHT. THAT
THAT LEVEL BE ADEQUATE. WE'RE
WE HAVE IN MY WHILE COMPETING.
TO THE OTHER SIDE TO LOOK
FORWARD THE BILL. MAN OF. IN
PARIS IS THOUGH THE- ADVOCATES
HAVE CHOI THE WHY HE'S ALL ON
THIS BILL RATHER THAN SOME THAT
MIGHT NOT WANT. COMPROMISE THIS
OF SEVENTY ISSUES AND WITH THAT.
THANKS FOR. I WILLING TO MOVE
THIS. THANK YOU SENATOR WORK
SKI. I'M SURE THE AUTHOR THAT
COMMENT OTHER QUESTIONS SOCIAL
BOARD. I WOULD FISHING MADAM
CHAIR. IT I WAS HOPE TO POSE A
QUESTION TO OUR STAY TO CALL
BEFORE YOU HAVE TIME. VENTURES
OUT OKAY WELL GIVEN THE FACT
THAT SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEYS
ONE THAT ASKED THE OTHER
QUESTIONS AND HAS A LITTLE
BACKGROUND IN THIS FIELD IT
WILL WILL GO AHEAD AND ACCEPT
THAT EVEN THOUGH GENERALLY
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THIS WORKS
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IN IF HE HAS
TO LEAVE. I'LL JUST LEAVE IT ON
THE QUESTIONS FOR SOMEBODY ELSE
TO ANSWER- I'M TRYING TO
REMEMBER BACK PLEASE SPEAK INTO
MICROPHONES- I'M TRYING
REMEMBER. BANKRUPTCY BANKRUPTCY
PROTECTIONS WHEN SOMEONE FILES
FOR BANKRUPTCY PROTECTIONS.
THEY'RE STILL ALLOWED TO
MAINTAIN THEIR THEIR PRIMARY.
RESIDENCE AS EXEMPTS FROM WHAT.
CAN BE. UGH GOING AFTER IS THAT
CORRECT OR IS THAT DATED. FIVER
OR MULTI THE EXTENT THAT YOU
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA EXEMPTION
IS FOR SINGLE PERSON SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
EQUITY IN YOUR HOME SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU HAVE SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OF EQUITY
THAT'S PROTECTED FOR SALES IN A
JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE AS A STAFF
REPORT POINTS OUT IT PROTECTS
THE SAME SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS MEAN. THIS IS SAID THIS
IS ON TOP OF THE- MMHM THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION WHICH- I
HAVE AN OPINION ON THAT ALSO
PUT YOUR CORRECT OKAY. WELL I
THINK WHAT I WAS. TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS WHAT ABOUT
RESTRUCTURED DEBT BECAUSE I
THINK THE ROUTE IT SAYS HERE
THAT ON A DEBT THAT WAS SECURED
BY THE DEBTORS PRINCIPAL PLACE
OF RESIDENCE AT THE TIME IT WAS
INCURRED. SO WHAT HAPPENS. IN A
SCENARIO WHERE THE DEBT IS
RESTRUCTURED SO THAT IT WAS IN
KURD IN ONE SCENARIO BUT
RESTRUCTURED THEREAFTER DOES
THAT CHANGE THE NATURE OF THIS
THROUGH THE CHAIRED BY READING
A SAID IT'S THE LATTER DAY IT
IS IT'S AS IT MOVES FORWARD
BECAUSE YOUR VALUE OF YOUR HOME
WOULD GO UP. BUT THE PROFESSOR
OR MISTER SAID I DISAGREE. LET
ME REPHRASE THE QUESTION IF I
HAVE A SECURED IF I MAKE A
TRANSACTION. AND I SECURE THAT
DEBT THROUGH MY PROPERTY. I
FALL INTO ARREARS LATER IN TIME.
BUT THEN RESTRUCTURE THE DEBT
IN ITS NOT ARE COLLATERALIZED
BY MY HOUSE DOES THAT CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC AT ALL. WELL I
WOULD ASSUME SO SENATOR MONNING
DE ARE YOU ABLE TO RESPOND TO
THAT AND IF NOT WE CAN ASK NINE
PREFER TO GO TO OUR EXPERTS ON
THIS EITHER. MISTER SOTO. WHERE
THE PROFESSOR. OR THAT OUR IN
HOUSE PROFESSOR OKAY. CASEY
OKAY SERIOUSLY GATHER LET'S GO
TO GO TO OUR EXPERTS- MISTER
SOTO OR THE PROFESSOR EITHER
ONE OF YOU PREPARED TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. AND I AM READY
TO SIGN IF YOU WANT BECAUSE
FIRST. GO HEAD TO GET THE- IN
GENERAL WHEN YOU REFINANCE OR-
BASICALLY RESTRUCTURE A LOAN.
YOU USUALLY END UP CREATING A
NEW CONTRACT AND SO IN THIS
PARTICULAR SCENARIO THAT I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY. SB FIRST
LOAN WAS SECURITIZED. UNDER OF
BE SECONDS ALONE DID NOT
EXECUTING THE SOON TO COLLECT
ON THAT SECOND LOAN AND SO
WHATEVER RATES THAT THEY HAVE
NEGOTIATED FOR THEMSELVES
THEY'RE REPLYING. SO THEY WOULD
BE A GREAT HOPES ARE GOING.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO FOLLOW
THE SECOND CONTRACT AND NOT THE
UN SECURITIZED CONTRACT BECAUSE
THAT HAD BEEN THAT PREEMPTED
THE EARLIER CONTRACT THEY HAVE
TO GO WITH THE ONE THAT IS
OPERATIVE AT THE TIME WHICH
WOULD BE THE SUBSEQUENT
CONTRACT GOT IT. IN MY WRITING
BUT MY LAST POINT. I HAVE A
SOFT SPOT ON THIS ISSUE. BUT
I'M NOT CERTAIN WHY WE CAN'T.
CONSIDER. THE TAX ISSUE ALL
PRETTY TAX ISSUE WHO WAS A
BATTLE OF ANYBODY CAN. CAN
COMMENT ON WHY BE COUNTING
ASSESSMENT. WAS EXCLUDED FROM
THIS IS A RETIREMENT SMALL
DOLLAR AMOUNTS. WITHIN THIS BE
PROBABLY WON THE MOST CREDIT
CARDS IN PROPERTY TAX ARE
PROBABLY THE MOST APT.
SCENARIOS ARE THEN I WOULD
ASSUME SENATOR MONNING WHICH I
LIKE I THOUGHT I HAD AN ANSWER
TO THAT BUT AGAIN I'M GOING TO
DEFER TO THE EXPERTS- BECAUSE-
LIST I HAVE I'M READING IT.
FROM A SEPARATE LIST SO LET'S
ASK THE EXPERTS THEIR RESPONSE
TO THAT QUESTION ON PROPERTY
TAX. WHY IT'S BEEN EXEMPTED
FROM THIS BILL IS THAT THE
QUESTION OR DO WE HAVE AN
ANSWER FROM OUR EXPERTS. I CAN
THINK OF ONE. SIMILAR TO THE-
ADVANTAGE OF THIS. MOST
ANTIPERSPIRANTS CHEN NEVER A
LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT
CHECKED IN AND THERE WAS A VERY
STRONG CONCERNS. ABOUT WHAT
THEY CAN'T THINK PROPERTY TAXES
AND HIGHLY WOULD DO FOR THE
ROHINGYA OF THE SIX CALIFORNIA-
I AGREE WITH YOU ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL THAT IT WOULD BE NICE-
THE RIGHT WORD. WE DO HELP
SENIOR CITIZENS ESPECIALLY THE
INTERFERES WITH PROPERTY TAXES
AND IN DANGER AND HAVE LOST
THEIR HOMES. BECAUSE OF UNPAID
PROPERTY TAXES IN THE LOCAL
POLITICAL DOLLAR RANGE. BUT. WE
WERE. IT'S A COUNCIL. TO TAKE
ON ONE THING A TIME. I THINK
THAT TELLS PROBABLY UP ISSUE I
THINK THE FIRST THING A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE PAYING
TAXES WOULD DO BE TO NOT PAY
THEIR PROPERTY TAXES WE NEED
THE THAT KIND OF CONSISTENCY TO
KEEP OUR GOVERNMENT GOING OUR
SERVICES GOING I SUSPECT THAT
WAS THE BASIS BOARD WE'RE
TALKING PRIMARILY. CONSUMER
RELATED DEBT NOT TAX RELATED
DEATH I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
CLEAR FAITHS ANSWER THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT- I'M SEEING
THAT THE NO BLUE HANDS UP. ON
THE SCREEN. SEND MONNING IF YOU
LIKE CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
THOSE WITH MORE EXPERTISE THAN
I HAVE ON THIS FOR. WEARING IN
I APPRECIATE THE EXPERT
WITNESSES WHO JOINED US- I DO
KNOWN ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT. THE
POLICY OBJECTIVES OF THIS BILL.
ARE PARTICULARLY- URGENT AT
THIS TIME OF COVERT NINETEEN
WHERE PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST JOBS
LOST INCOMES IN MAY BE CARING
WHAT WE DEFINE IN THIS BILL AS
SOME LEVEL OF CONSUMER DEBT. DO
NOT LOSE HOME THAT THEY'VE
BUILT SOME EQUITY IN. TO
SATISFY WHAT. ON THE SCALE OF
THE VALUE OF THE HOME IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL DEBT. IT
SHOULD NOT FORCE OF FAMILY TO
BECOME HOMELESS- SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE. AN AYE. VOTE
ON THIS TO PROTECT THEM OF ALL.
BY THAT THOSE WHO ARE FACING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP CAN KEEP
THEIR HOMES I AM ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS I THINKER
FOR CRAFTING THIS BILL AD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MORNING TO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS BILL. I'M
SORRY. I'M SORRY CENTER Y.
CASKEY MOVE THE BILL BEFORE HE
LEFT ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I SENATORS PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE BY FAMILY
MEMBER WICKS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JACKSON JACKSON HI JACKSON I'D
BURGESS. DID AWESOME I DID ALSO
I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
MELENDEZ. MINING NINE MINING I
STERN. TOURNOI THAT WHOLE
HOLDEN HAVE TO GET YOU ON THE
SCREEN ST I GOT IT OKAY WE GOT
STERN AYE STERN AYE BURKE.
BURKE I AM BURKE I WAKE CAL SKI
HI WHITE HOUSE GATE FIVE. SIX
THAT'S- SEVEN WITH TWO MILLION
MEMBERS SEVEN ALL EYES NO NOSE
TO STANCHIONS THAT BILL IS.
REALLY THE ROLE OPEN BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT HERE WE WANT OUR-
YES THEY'RENOT HERE AREN'T
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN TILL
THE END OF OUR HEARING- AND
INVITE THEM TO COME BACK. IF
NOT BEFORE I WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN TILL THE HEARING COULD.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO.
A FILE ITEM NINE. WHICH IS ALSO
A MEASURE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEEKS AB THIRTY NINETY TWO. AND
I BELIEVE THAT- CENTER MINDING
YOUR ALSO PRESENTING THAT SO
WITH THAT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY NINETY TWO ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN WAKES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOMAN WICKS
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE SHE
APPRECIATES THEIR TIME AND
FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL. UNDER
CURRENT LAW A VAST MAJORITY OF
CASES CONNECTED TO DR HEAPS A
PHYSICIAN EMPLOYED BY UCLA WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED WOMEN IN THE COURSE OF
HIS THIRTY FIVE YEAR CAREER ARE
TIME BARRED BY THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS. LAST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE OPENED A
BRIEF ONE YEAR WINDOW IN THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
PATIENTS WHO'D BEEN A SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY FORMER
GYNECOLOGIST DR GEORGE TYNDALL
AT USC. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
CHANGE IN LAW ONLY APPLIES TO
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS EXCLUDING
PUBLIC ENTITIES. YOU SEE L. AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO WOULD
TEMPORARILY REVIVE THOSE TIME
BARRED CASES FOR ONE YEAR.
CLAIMS SUCH AS SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR OTHER INAPPROPRIATE CONTACT
COMMUNICATION OR ACTIVITY OF A
SEXUAL NATURE MAY BE RESTORED.
THIS BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY ARE TRULY WALLICH.
CARA CAYGLE AND REBEKAH MARCUS-
THROUGH THE CHAIR I'D LIKE 2%
THOSE PRIMARY WITNESSES TO
DIVIDE THE TIME ALLOCATED. VERY
GOOD THAT- WILL BE. A FINE-
JULIE WALLET KARA- CAYGLE AND
REBECCA MARKETS- YOU HAVE FOUR
MINUTES TO SHARE AMONGST
YOURSELVES AS YOU SO CHOOSE
AND- IF THEY ARE LINED UP IN
THE QUEUE MADAME MODERATOR
WOULD YOU GO AHEAD AND- INVITE
ONE OF THOSE THREE TO GET
STARTED. YES WE DO HAVE AS WELL
AGAIN THIS CABLE ON THE LINE.
ALL RIGHT HI JULIE WHILE IT.
THANK YOU PLEASE RECORD YOU CAN
BE HEARD AND YOU CAN PROCEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
MY NAME IS JULIE BALIK AND
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF AB THIRTY
NINETY ZERO. USING THE PAST
TENSE OF THE WORD HARM IS
MISLEADING AS THE HARM DR HE'S
CAUSED ME AND HUNDREDS LIKE ME
IS PERMANENTLY ETCHED IN OUR
PSYCHES OUR BODIES AND OUR
SPIRIT. DR HE SEXUALLY ABUSED
ME IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AT
THE HARM HE CAUSED AT LEAST
ARMENIAN NATIONALLY AND
PHYSICALLY RIGHT NOW. AS I
SPEAK WITH ALL OF YOU. IN MARCH
OF NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I WAS
REFERRED TO DOCTOR HE'S FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS YOUR- LEADER I
CAN TRUST UCLA AND DOCTOR HE TO
PROPERLY CARE FOR ME. THAT IS
NOT AT ALL WHAT HAPPENED. DR HE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ME USING HIS
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. BECAUSE SUCH
EXTREME PHYSICAL HARM. THAT I
COULD NOT HAVE CHECK THAT YOUR
CHILD BIRDS. HE STRUCK MICHAEL
AND IT'S BOTH SUBJECTIVELY TOLD
ME I WAS CUTE AND WRAPPED HIS
HAND ON THE INSIDE OF MY
SILENCE WHILE I WAS ON THE
STAND PEOPLE. I HAVE HAD
ONGOING FLASHBACKS NIGHTMARES
EPISODES OF CRYING AND INTENSE
ANGER AT NOT BEING HEARD OR
CARED FOR. BY THE VERY STATE
AGENCIES THERE'S A CONCERT
PROTECTION IN. IN JANUARY
NINETEEN NINETY NINE I FILED A
COMPLAINT WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA EACH
SHOWING THE SEXUAL ABUSE.
ADDITIONALLY AT THAT TIME I
CALLED UCLA'S CHIEF OF STAFF ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS TO DISCUSS
WITH DOCTOR HE DID TO ME. I
NEVER RECEIVED A RETURN PHONE
CALL. SHOULD DOCTORS HEED HIS
OFFICE I WAS LEFT ALONE WITH
THE DOCTOR DESPITE PLEADING
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF CLEATS
HELD A DOCTOR TO START CLEARING
WITH THE PATIENT. RATHER THAN
PROTECT ME SHE LAUGHED AND LEFT
THE ROOM WHEN I ASKED HER HOW.
PEOPLE REFER TO ME AS A
SURVIVOR NOT A VICTIM WE HAVE
SOUNDS NICE AND I APPRECIATE
THEIR SENSITIVITY. BUT THE
TRUTH IS I AM A VICTIM OF DR
HEAT AND UCLA. NO AMOUNT OF
TIME OR HEARING WILL CHANGE
THAT FOR ME OR ANYONE ELSE. BUT
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY NINETY TWO
WILL HELP STEER THE SHIP A
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS FROM
INSTRUCTORS. PASSING THIS BILL
COULD POSSIBLY HE'LL AT EAST
SOME OF THE DAMAGE THAT HAS
BEEN DONE TO ME AND OTHERS LIKE
ME BY GIVING US CONFIDENCE THAT
WE CAN BE HEARD BELIEVES AND
CARED FOR IN THIS PROCESS. WHY
IS IT THAT THE ACCUSED DOCTOR
HE IS A FOR THE RIGHT TO A FAIR
TRIAL BUT A VICTIM OF CRIME
ISN'T. EIGHTY THIRTY NINETY TWO
WILL SOLVE THIS ISSUE FOR
MYSELF AND WOMEN LET ME. YOUR
HE HEARD AND I. OR WHEN WE
ENTERED THE CHURCH ABUSED THANK
TOM DOES NOT CARE ABOUT TRYING
AND TIME KNOWS THAT OF THE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HERE AGAIN
I HAVE CARE AND MEMBERS
LISTENING. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. OUR NEXT WITNESS
CARE CAKE AND YOU'VE GOT. IN A
HALF. OKAY THANK YOU HELLO MY
NAME IS KERRY KATONA SPEAKING
IN FAVOR OF AB THIRTY NINETY Q.
I THANK THE AND I THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU'RE A GREAT STATE AND
COUNTRY ON MARCH TENTH TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN I WAS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY DR PETE
UCLA I REPORTED TRON
IMMEDIATELY TO A NURSE AT UCLA
AND A FORMER. EIGHT THREE
LETTER. TO UCLA AND CALIFORNIA
BOARD INFORMED HER OF WHAT. AT
FORTY YEARS OLD I WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH TRIPLE NEGATIVE BREAST
CANCER BRONCO ONE POSITIVE.
BECAUSE THE RARE FORM OF BREAST
CANCER IN THE FOLLOWING TWO
YEARS I WENT TO A BILATERAL.
CHEMOTHERAPY RADIATION REMEMBER
MY OVER TO. RECONSTRUCTION AND
THIRTY FIVE RADIATION
TREATMENTS. IT INTERNET SERVICE
TIME THAT I DR JAMES HE-
BECAUSE I WAS BACK ALONG. I A
GREATER CHANCE OF OVARIAN
CANCERS WELL. IT WAS DECIDED I
WOULD HAVE MY OVARIES AND TUBES.
MY UCLA DOCTOR WHO JUST. HE
FEELING. DOCTOR JAMES HE-
HARDEN SURGERY. WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE JUST A CONSOLE
TO POINT INTERNET A HORRIFIC
SEXUAL ASSAULT. I THINK COUNTY
LAST NAME HERE. I'M VERY
FAMILIAR. MY DECISION FOR ME
FEELING WITH TO LET THEM KNOW
HOW IMPROVE IT FROM TO SOMEONE
OUT. UCLA'S STATED EIGHTEEN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN INCLUDED THE
FOLLOWING COMMENT. I'M SORRY
THAT YOU HAD SUCH A NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCE THAT THIS IS BECAUSE
YOU SUCH CONCERN TRANSACTION.
THE LETTER WENT ON TO TELL ME
THAT THE EXECUTIVE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY. MY CONCERN THEY
STATED THEIR FINE CONFIDENTIAL
AND. PROTECTED THE INSTITUTION
I THINK. TO SAVE MY LIFE AND
JUSTICE IT THAT OF THEIR OWN
ACTUATED. ITEM PARTNER THEM. I
FELT BRUSHED OFF LIKE I DIDN'T
MATTER. TO ADD INSULT TO. I'VE
LEARNED THAT IF THE U. WOULD
HAVE ACTED PROPERLY- PRIOR
COMPLAINT AGAINST DOCTOR JAMES
HE- I WOULD NEVER MET THE MAN.
AND THEN HAPPENED AGAIN OTHER
VICTIMS WERE HURT BY DR HEAT.
WHEN I FOUND OUT I WAS
HEARTBROKEN IF ONLY UCLA HAS
LISTENED TO ME AND DONE
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. I'M BEING
TOLD THAT YOU SEE. SOME ICE OR
WITH THE COURT SIX YEARS AGO
THAT MY TIME IS RUNNING OUT. I
LOOK TO YOU FOR HELP YOU WIDELY
OPENED A WINDOW IN THE STATURE
LIMITATION FOR SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ABUSE AT USC THANK YOU
MY- NAME. THANK YOU I'M SO TO.
INTERRUPT I SAID I SORRY DID
YOU WE HAD FOR MINUTES WHY. ARE
GONE ON TO OVER FOR. LET ME
JUST SAY THAT IS A BROKER
BREAST CANCER SURVIVOR MIGHT. I
JUST CAN'T IMAGINE HAVING
INSULT TO INJURY THE CHIU. OF
AN EXPERIENCE SO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE TWO OF YOU
WOULD STAY ON THE LINE- IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS TO ASK
YOU I'M SURE YOU'D BE YEAH.
AVAILABLE AND WILLING TO ANSWER
THEM WE ALSO HAVE A REBEKAH
MARKETS. OF WHO IS HERE TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL SUPPORT
AFTER ANY QUESTIONS- TO BE
ASKED TO. AND A NAP. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES- IN THE CHAMBER TO
TESTIFY. ON BEHALF OF THIS ITEM
DO WE HAVE A- SOMEONE IF YOU
WOULD STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE
GIVE US YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IMPOSITION PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATED. ALL RIGHT MADAM.
ELEGIES ANYONEIN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SHE NOBODY LET'S GO
AHEAD TO THE PHONES AND MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE
PROMPT- THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO. WE WILL
BEGIN. AND ACTUALLY IN GENERAL
ANYIF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
NINETY QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING. IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY THAT IS NINE
ONE SIX ZERO. THE LINE IS OPEN.
JANUARY CARE IS ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU EN MADAME MODERATOR HOW
MANY FOLKS DO WE HAVE ON THE
LINES AT THIS POINT. I HAVE A
THREE ALL TOGETHER THE PERSON
THAT- WE JUST SPOKE WITH INTO
MORE THANK YOU VERY MUCHYOU'RE
FREE TO GO AHEAD WITH THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT LINE ONE FOR
EACH THE LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ALFRED CHIU AND I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE LINE ONE SIX ONE THE
LINE IS OPEN. THE NUTCRACKER
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. I ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE'RE GIVING THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER THANK YOU THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY NINETY TWO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT NINE
ONE FIVE EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HENRY
OCHRE POINT FROM SANTA CRUZ IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE'RE GETTING
THERE LINE NUMBER. NINE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU. YES MY NAME IS STORED UP
IN AND I STRONG SUPPORT THE-
ADULT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY NINETY Q.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR KEYPAD PHONE KEYPAD AT
THIS TIME ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO LINE TWO
TWO THE LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD I MEAN I DIDN'T SEND. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY NINETY TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU OF
WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE IS OF ANY WERE NOT AWARE
OF IT THERE WAS NO OPPOSITION
SUBMITTED- IS THERE ANYONE. IN
THE CHAMBER WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
ITEM. IS THERE ANYONE ON ONE OF
THE WITNESS LINES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. MADAME
MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY NINETY
Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE PHONE KEYPAD AGAIN-
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY NINETY Q. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IN WORLD THEY'RE
QUEUING UP IF THERE ARE ANY
LE'S CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE
IS NOT. META MODERATORS FOR
ANYONE LINED UP TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY NINETY
TWO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME RIGHT WE'LL GIVE
IT ONE MORE SECOND TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO. ASIAN
GENTLEMAN IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY
NINETY TWO PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPD.
THAT IS ONE BAND IS ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU WITH THAT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE FLOOR JUST DON'T
WANT TO MAKE ONE OBSERVATION OF
LAST YEAR OF COURSE WE HEARD-
AB FIFTEEN TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS WHICH ADDRESSED
THE HORRIFIC ACTS TAKING PLACE
OVER THE COURSE OF DECADES AT
USC- AND THERE WAS CONCERN
THAT. OF THIS NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED ON A STATE LEVEL AS
WELL AND- JUST SHOCKING. THE
TRULY SHOCKING THAT AFTER THESE
COMPLAINTS FOR DECADES HAVE
BEEN RAISED AT USC AND NOW YOU
SEE AAY. THAT THE SCHOOLS DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WHY IS IT
THAT WHEN WOMEN EXPRESS THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT BEING IN THIS
VULNERABLE SITUATION AND BEING.
ABUSED WENT. ON DEAF EARS IS
JUST A VERY DISCONCERTING
STATEMENT OF TO SAY THE LEAST.
I THINK FOR ALL WOMEN AND
SHOULD BE FOR ALL OF US THESE
ARE SOMEBODY'S CHILDREN. IS OUR
STUDENTS AT OUR SCHOOLS WHO ARE
ENTITLED TO AN EXPECTED TO WIN
A SHOULD BE RECEIVING. THE KIND
OF ARE THAT WE WOULD WANT FOR
OURSELVES AND OUR OWN LOVED
ONES IN THE FACT THAT THEIR
CONCERNS WERE IGNORED. BY IS
JUST. INCOMPREHENSIBLE AND SO-
I WANT TO THANK OUR WITNESSES.
FOR THEIR STRENGTH AND COURAGE
IN COMING FORWARD- HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL HELP WITH THE HEALING
PROCESS THESE THINGS COURSE CAN
NEVER BE UNDONE- AND THEY
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN IN THE
FIRST PLACE SO IF WE NEED TO
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE. ARE YOU
ALL OF OUR HERE IT IS- BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE THIS SHOULD
NEVER HAVE HAPPENED AND NEVER
BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN AGAIN I
THINK THAT'S THE STATEMENT THIS
BILL MAKES. END UP WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING FORWARD AND- MISTER
BOETTCHER CENTER BORCHERS IF
YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION
PLEASE PROCEED I THINK MADAM. I
THINK YOU SAID IT VERY WELL ON.
THIS THINGS LIKE THIS ARE
ABSOLUTELY UNCONSCIONABLE- AND
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BUT
MY CONCERN IS THAT WE ARE
ISOLATING ONE INSTITUTION. WHEN
WOULD IT NOT BE BETTER AS A
MATTER OF POLICY. TO CHANGE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ISSUES
MORE BROADLY. HAVE IT APPLIED.
TO WHAT ALL SCHOOLS. AND THEN
WE DEAL WITH S. C. BEFORE NOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH UCLA BUT
THIS KIND OF PIECEMEAL APPROACH
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT JUST
CONCERNS ME THAT IT COULD BE.
BETTER ADDRESSED IF THERE WERE
IF THERE WERE REFORMS ACROSS
THE BOARD IN TERMS OF SEXUAL
IMITATIONS SO I'LL CERTAINLY BE
SUPPORTING IT BUT- IF WE IF WE
HEAR ANOTHER SCHOOL. WHETHER
IT'S IN THE UC SYSTEM THE CSU
SYSTEM OR A PRIVATE SYSTEM IF
WE HEAR THAT A SITUATION LIKE
THIS OCCUR AGAIN ARE WE JUST
GONNA GO SCHOOL BY SCHOOL BY
SCHOOL OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEARS I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
MORE POLICY I THINK WE SHOULD
BE EVALUATING- SUCH LIMITATIONS
REFORM. THANK YOU I WILL NOTE
THAT WE HAVE EXPANDED THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS ON THESE.
OFFENSES ARE GOING FORWARD I
THINK WE DID THAT A FEW YEARS
AGO TO TEN YEARS- WE'VE DONE IT
WITH COURSE WE HAD THE
SITUATION WITH THE CHURCH.
CATHOLIC CHURCH AND- EXPANDED
THAT STATUE LIMITATIONS I MEAN
THE BOTTOM LINE THIS IS GOT TO
STOP. THIS JUST CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN AND I THINK
WE HAVE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. A TAKEN A VERY
STRONG POSITION ON THIS. AND IT
IS MY HOPE. THAT THE MESSAGE IS
OUT THERE YOU JUST CANNOT
EXPLOIT PEOPLE LIKE THIS- AND I
THINK THIS ADDRESSES BUT WE
KNOW TO HAVE BEEN A LONG
STANDING PROBLEM- AND IS AN
APPROPRIATE RESOLUTION. AT THIS
POINT IN TIME I HOPE WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO THIS EVER AGAIN-
BUT- THAT BEING SAID- SENATOR.
MORNING WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I. TWO ONE I THINK.
THE WITNESSES MISS WHILE I CAN
MISS CAYGLE. VICTIMS WHO SHOW
GREAT COURAGE IN STANDING UP TO
MOVE FORWARD NOT ONLY IN THE
EXERCISE OF THEIR OWN RIGHTS
BUT ON BEHALF OF OTHERS. WHO
ARE ALSO VIOLATED AND I WOULD
JUST CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL
DOES MORE THAN SEND A MESSAGE
IT CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEEK LEGAL REDRESS I THINK THE
MESSAGE PART OF THIS BILL.
SHOULD BE TO ALL ADMINISTRATORS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION IN
WORKPLACES IN MEDICAL CENTERS
WHERE EVER THIS TYPE OF
EGREGIOUS CONDUCT MIGHT TAKE
PLACE. WHAT THIS BILL SHOULD DO
IS SAY THAT YOU WILL NOT ESCAPE
THE LAW BUT THE GOAL SHOULD BE
TO PREVENT THIS CONDUCT. IN THE
ANY HINT OF IT SHOULD BE
AGGRESSIVELY INVESTIGATED. WITH
THE GOAL OF PROTECTING. FUTURE
VICTIMS SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I AM
HONORED TO CARRY THE BILL TODAY
IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL AS MOVED BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. BATUM
BE A CONSULTANT COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI YEAH
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB THIRTY NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
JACKSON JACKSON FIVE JACKSON I
PUT YOUR MARK STONE EVERYBODY I
THINK IT ACTION ON. JACKSON I'D
BORDERS FIVE BRIDGES I DID ALSO
I THAT I SAW I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I MELENDEZ. MORNING
NINE MONNING AYE STERN. STERN
AYE STERN AYE- BURKE. NUMBER
GUY AMBERG I WAKE HOUSEKI WHITE
HOUSE KIII. EIGHT TWO ZERO CAN
YOU CAN PART OF THE VOTE COUNT
IS EIGHT OUR EYES NO NOSE ED
ONE OF THOSE NOT VOTING OR
ABSTENTION- WE WILL AGAIN LEAVE
THAT ROLE OPEN DO ONE LAST RUN
THROUGH AT THE END OF THIS
SESSION ON ALL THESE ITEMS OUR
LAST ITEM TODAY IS FILE ITEM
TEN. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
IT IS AB. THIRTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE WE HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS BEING SOUGHT SO WITH
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES- FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT BRIEF
I HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
MADAM CHAIR AND I DO WANT TO
JUST THANK YOUR INCREDIBLE
STUFF FOR A JUST AT THEIR VERY
THOROUGH AND THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS YET AGAIN. AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT PROVIDES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT IN
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES IN OUR STATE THE
BILL DOES THIS BY REQUIRING
PRIVATE OPERATORS TO ADHERE TO
THE MINIMUM STANDARD TODAY
VOLUNTARILY AGREED ON IN THEIR
OWN OPERATIONS CONTRACTS.
PROVIDES FOR A LEGAL MECHANISM
FOR VIOLATIONS OF THOSE
STANDARDS SPECIFICALLY A CAUSE
OF ACTION BY THE CALIFORNIAN
HARMED BY THE CONTRACTUAL
VIOLATION IN THE TORTIOUS ACT
BY PROVIDING A CAUSE OF ACTION
FOR VIOLATIONS OF THESE
FACILITIES TO AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT. WE'RE SENDING A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW AND THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL ENSURE THE
HUMAN RIGHTS HEALTH AND SAFETY
WELFARE AND DIGNITY OF
EVERYONE. IN OUR STATE AGAIN WE
ARE MAKING SURE THAT FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE DETENTION CENTERS ARE
COMPLYING WITH THEIR OWN
CONTRACTS THANK YOU. WE I VOTE
WITH ME OVER THE TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT ISN'T JACKIE
GONZALEZ. POLICY DIRECTOR
IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATES.
THANK. SHORT AND SWEET
APPRECIATED I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HOPING TO HAVE
SOMEONE. WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS- JACKIE GONZALEZ YOU
HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES BUT WE
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CONSIDER A SHORTER SEASON
TATIAN BUT REGARDLESS THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU- CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND YOU KNOW I WILL
JUST START BY SAYING GIVEN THAT
A FEW MINUTES HAVE BEEN
ALLOTTED TO THIS ISSUE I'M-
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
DIRE NEED OF THE JEWISH AND I
WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
TIME- ADD. AS I DID YOU DO
JACQUI GONZALEZ POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR IMMIGRATION AND ADVOCATES.
ICON BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AT A
TIME WHEN YOU'RE A THINKING
COLLECTIVE SOLUTIONS TO
SAFEGUARD PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
STATE OF A DEADLY PANDEMIC. NOT
MANY OF YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
STATE INDICATOR REPORT BY
GOVERNOR PLANTED FAITHFULLY RE
OPENED THE STATE IS THE ABILITY
TO PREVENT KOBE NINETEEN
OUTBREAK INSTABILITY WHICH ARE
VULNERABLE TO WIDESPREAD
INFECTION. WALKING ATTENTION
HAS PAID A CAR. AND PRIVATE
HOME WE REGRETTABLY. TO ADDRESS
PLIGHT OF. READ THE CAN FIND HI
WE ARE. TO PENSION. AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT SOLUTIONS THE
CRISIS THAT HAS UNFOLDED BEFORE
IT. ALTHOUGH THE LEGISLATURE WE
TWO LAST YEAR FIVE PRIVATE
FACILITIES ARE MADE IN
OPERATION UNTIL THEY CONTRACT
EXPIRE. A. B. THERE HAVE BEEN
COPING NINETEEN IS FOR AT ALL
HI THE ABILITY WITH A LARGE
BEING OF OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIX IN. CATTLE TIGHTENING. AND
I WILL NOTE THAT FOR TO OF THE
LAR OUT ANYTHING DETENTION
FACILITY IN THE IN COUNTRY. I'M
OUTBREAK OF COLD NINETEEN
ANOTHER IN CURRENT OPERATE BY
THEN TORIES GOP. PROVIDES A
VERY CLEAR OF WHAT IT TAKING
PLACE IN THE- OUR- FEDERAL
JUDGE OVERSEEING CONTENT THAT
WE NEED NOBODY JUST FOR WEEK
THAT SHE'LL CALL. PUT THE DID.
READ COVER ABOUT GLOBAL ARM
JEFFREY THE SAFETY THEIR OWN
INCOME AND ENGAGE TO CREATE AT
LARGE. MARCH NUMERO REPORTS
EMERGED TO CRYING IN INTIMATE
CONDITION WHICH INCLUDE THE
UNLOCK FOR YOU SUPPORT THE LADY
VIOLATIONS EIGHTY GUIDANCE THAT
I PREVENT SPREAD OF COMMITTEES
AND LET ME OF OTHER DETENTION
STANDARDS AT THE FACILITY
ARTICLE TO ABOUT BY. REALLY
GREAT SEPARATE ACCOUNTS ABOUT A
LACK OF INTENTION TO BELIEVE
REVEAL THAT HE NEEDS HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS
IN HEALTHCARE. THIS BRECHER
DISREGARD HUMAN LIFE WE THAT
HAPPENED THAT CHICAGO FOR OUR
STATE IT WILL OVERWHELM LOCAL
HOSPITALS RAPIDLY PHILIP I FEEL
IN THE ALREADY CASH STRAPPED
CITIES WERE DISABILITIES ARE
LOCATED AT THIRTY TO TWENTY
EIGHT PROVIDE CLEAR MANDATORY
GUIDANCE TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS IN
ATTENTION AT A TIME WHEN IT IS
MOST NEEDED I THINK MISTAKENLY
IT DOESN'T AT NO COST EIGHT.
EIGHT CLOTHING I NEED YOUR
CORRECTIONS STATEMENT ISSUED BY
INDIVIDUALS. AT THE MISGUIDED
THEY- CALL THE NIGHT HAD
ARRIVED AT HAVE BEEN. READY
WHILE. DOESN'T APPEAR IN OUR
DORM ARE SHOWING SYMPTOMS OF
COLD AT NIGHT. AND THEY ARE
DONE FOR. IT TAKES DAYS COULD
BE DOCTOR AND THEN THEY OFTEN
GIVE IT WILL NOT EXTEND THE
BACK TO DORM. INVERSE TO BE OUT
SHE GROUP HAS BEEN. BY REFUSE
TO CLEAN OUR DORM NEEDS THIRTY
AND CRAPPIE TAKING AWAY OUR
COMMON CAL. USED BY. AND
HYGIENE PRODUCTS AND THE COLOR
FAMILIES EVEN LIMITING OUR
ABILITY TO REQUIRE PEOPLE DR
APPOINT. DESPITE OUR COUNTLESS
WARNING THEY DID NOT HAVE THE
IN PLACE CREDIT IN MEDICAL. AND
THEY ARE NOT DOING YOUR ENOUGH
TO PREVENT GREAT THE ONLY AND
DEATH HERE ON THIS PROGRAM THAT.
I WAS APPLICANT TO STAND WITH
THE WHO ARE ON THE- AND LATER.
I FOR THEIR IN THE- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE TIME CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES. ARE IN THE CHAMBER.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TEST VICE NO
WE OR INTO AT ALL IN THE CHIU
LET'S GO TO ROOM ONE TWO.
SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM ONE. OF
GO TO MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE- MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT WE CAN BEGIN IN A
FEW WOULD INDICATE THE NUMBER
IN THE QUEUE THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AS WELL. GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO- WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN- PARTIES IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO
FIRST TO THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX POINT ONE
FIVE SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THE
SHE CARE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ETONLINE
AT ONE THREE EIGHT YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. NOT SURE MEMBERS RUNNING
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S HM WERE STRONG
OPPONENTS AS PER THEM IN
DETENTION PRIVATIZATION AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR HIGH
VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN LINE ONE FIVE SEVEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. BACK IN BOTH
NATIONALIZATION OF SOCIAL
WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO
CALLING IN FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE LINE
ONE SEVEN THREE THE LINE IS
OPEN. BUT AFTER HEARING MEMBERS
ANDREA RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO LINE
ONE SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND HE HAS DONE IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ACTIVISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTYFIVE LINE ONE SEVEN
FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS WHEN
THIS YEAR WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LINE NUMBER FORTY
ONE LINE FOR ONE THE LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY QUICK REMINDER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND PART. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE LINE ONE
FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAU
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE LINE ONE SEVEN ONE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. WHICH IS THE AND
CARRY ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR ONE SEVEN FOUR
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS
OF THE BAND WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
FORTY NINE FOUR ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. YOU HAVE YET NEW YORK
FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA CALLING FROM
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX ONE
SEVEN SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERYL NUMBER.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT NINE
ONE SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON ARRIVAL TORY
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY ON BEHALF
OF THE LOWER STREET COMMUNITY
SERVICES A NONPROFIT IN THE-
BAY AREA IN CHUNKS OF EIGHT
NINE THREE TWO TWO EIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT. WITNESS PLACE. ONE
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR NINE
ONE SIX FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE YOU DOWN WAIT THE SINGLE
SERVICES I MEAN IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING LGBTQ
ASYLUM SEEKERS. AND WORKING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE LINE
ONE FIVE NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VALERIE AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE IMMIGRANT LEGL
RESOURCE CENTER AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND ON THE
BILL AND I JUST WANT TO PAY
HAVING WORKED PERSONALLY WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION DETENTION.
BURKE IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTELY VITAL
THINKING A LEVEL OF PROTECTION-
COMMITTEE ON APPRECIATE ME
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
RIGHT NOW ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE AT LINE ONE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CRAIG SCOTT WITH DESERT SUPPORT
FOR ASYLUM SEEKERS OF THE
COACHELLA COACHELLA AND
IMPERIAL VALLEY WE SUPPORT
PEOPLE AND I'M CARILLO REGIONAL
DETENTION FACILITY IN BASED ON
WHAT WE'VE SEEN THANK YOU NEED.
BE AN EXCELLENT WORDS PLEASE
PLEASE NAME AFFILIATION AND
INTERPRETATION ONLY. PLEASE
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS. ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE NINE ONE
SIX FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE KIND OF LEAN
ON MARTIN BROWN MORE. DIRECTOR
PROGRAM IN ALBUQUERQUE WAS SENT
A LINK OUT THAN THAT SO WE
CALLED INTO A BURKE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVEN
LINE ONE SEVEN SEVEN GO AHEAD.
HI LINE MONITORED AT. ON YOUR
GARDEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO LINE AT
ONE EIGHT FIVE TWO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. SORRY THIS IS MUDDY
NATURI QUALITY INTERNAL AFFAIRS
OF THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AND VERY MUCH. LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. DO WE HAVE
AN ONLINE NUMBER ONE PLEASE
GIVE OUR ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN A LINE ONE SIX SEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. NO IT BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU'D IKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE ZERO. NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
THIS POINT IN TIME- WE WILL
INVITE TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OF WHO MAY BE IN
THE CHAMBER. WE'RE UNAWARE THAT
THERE IS ANY OPPOSITION BUT
WILL CERTAINLY GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SEEING NO ONE IN
THE CHAMBER LETS GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NO IN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND- LET'S MOVE NOW TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
OF MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF D. B. THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU LET'S GIVE IT ONE
MORE CHANCE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB. THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT. GENTLEMEN IF YOU
ARE TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE- OF AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ALREADY HAVE
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WILL START
WITH SENATOR MONNING AND FALL
BY SENATOR DOORASHO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD FOR HIS CONTINUED WORK
IN CHAMPIONING HUMAN RIGHTS
AND- PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY. I ALSO JUST WANNA
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO MISS JACKIE
GONZALEZ AN IMMIGRANT DEFENSE
ADVOCATES FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND TO ALL THE
SUPPORTERS FOR THEIR HARD WORK
DAY BY DAY. AND TO USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS A REMINDER THAT
THERE ARE STILL CHILDREN
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AS A RESULT OF US IMMIGRATION
POLICY. THEIR HUMAN RIGHT TO
FILE A POLITICAL ASYLUM
APPLICATION AND HAVE THOSE
APPLICATIONS PROCESSED BY THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION- SO WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS BILL. THANK ALL THOSE
WHO CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE AND
REPRESENT IN AGAIN TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS STRONG
LEADERSHIP. IN DEFENSE OF THE
DEFENSELESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MONNING SENATOR
RAZA. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
ALSO RISE TO. THANK THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA THIS IS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
STOP. IT NEEDS TO STOP THEIR
HUMAN BEINGS WHO ARE DYING IN
THOSE DETENTION CENTRES HUMAN
BEINGS WHO ARE DEEMED BEING
DENIED THE MOST BASIC SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED CHILDREN BEING
SEPARATED IT IS OUTRAGEOUS. IT
IS COMPLETELY IN HERE. THAT
WITHIN OUR BORDERS MEN AND
WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND BEING
TREATED THE WAY THAT THEY ARE
IN THESE DETENTION CENTERS THEY
ARE NOT CRIMINALS WE ARE NOT
BEING DETAINED BECAUSE THEY
COMMITTED A CRIME. IT IS THIS
CIVIL ISSUE. THAT THEY ARE
BEING HELD FOR SO AGAIN WE HAVE
TO COME OUT IT IN ALL KINDS OF
WAYS TO MAKE THE POINT CLEAR
THAT IT'S THIS IS NOT TO BE
TOLERATED. ARM AND DIE. I HAD
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR THIS YEAR
I HOPE THIS IS WHAT MAKES IT
ALL THE WAY AND GETS THAT
SIGNATURE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
BONTA. THEY YOU AND I ALSO WANT
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
FEELS A LITTLE LIKE DEJA VU.
LAST YEAR YOU WERE HERE
PRESENTING IT THERE WAS A B.
THIRTY TWO. WHICH WAS- BILL YOU
AUTHORED TO PHASE OUT THE
TENSION FACILITIES OPERATED BY
FOR PROFIT PRISON CORPORATIONS
THAT HOLD BOTH CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL DETAINEES AND THAT BILL
WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. NOW
WE'RE LOW AT TO THE SEARCH AND
PRESENTED HERE TODAY- I ALSO
NOTE AND APPRECIATE THAT THIS
BILL DOES INCLUDE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION WHICH I BELIEVE
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
ENFORCING RIGHTS. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY IN A
RIDE WITHOUT A REMEDY IS NOT
RIGHT AT ALL. AND SO I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BY THE WAY
WE GET THESE CORPORATIONS TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR DUTY OF CARE
IS THROUGH THE THREAT OF
LITIGATION. ASSEMBLY FREQUENTLY
WITH THERE ARE NO OTHER OPTIONS
AND THERE'S NO SERIOUSNESS
TAKEN TO THESE CLEAR DIRECTIVES
FROM THE STATE THE POLICY OF
THE STATE TRIPPY WITH DIGNITY
FIVE. THE GO STRAIGHT THE BAR
LINE WITH WHAT WE ARE ALL TOO.
SO WITH THE THERE ARE. I SEE NO
OTHER MY- UP WE A MOTION BY
SENATE MONNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR KIND
WORDS YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT THE
BILL- ANY YEAR- KINDNESS
TOWARDS ME GENERALLY. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO HELPING THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN CALIFORNIA THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED THAT BE FINE
APARTMENT COMMUNITIES AND TO
MAKE SURE WE PROTECT THE HEALTH
SAFETY WELFARE OF THOSE. IN FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION
CENTERS CENTER DRAWS I WANNA
CALL YOU UP SPECIFICALLY FOR
YOUR YOUR BOLD IMPACTFUL WORK
IN THIS SPACE. AND HELP IT IS
STILL GET OUT OF THIS WEEKEND
GET OFF THE FLOOR AND UNDER THE
GOVERNOR TO PROTECT THOSE WHO.
ABOUT I WANT TO SHOW UP. SO THE
SENATE DID READY GET A PROPER
NOURISHMENT AND ARE YOU TO GET
A LOT UP. WITHOUT ALL THE
SAFETY YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION CHECK THE- OF.
THANK SO MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION
BY THIS. MOPPING MOTION TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR. AND WITH.
CONSOLE WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE- THIS IS FOR I'D NUMBER. AB
TWO TWENTY EIGHT BYE BYE. THE
MOTION IS DEEP TO SENATE FLOOR.
JACK JACKSON I JACKSON HI
BURGESS. THE RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I MELENDEZ
YOU KNOW MINING AYE MONNING AYE
STERN. STERNIDAE STERN I AM
BERG. NUMBER I AM BERG I WHITE
HOUSE HIGH WHITE HOUSE GATE I
THAT SEVEN TWO ZERO IN I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE COMING BACK RIGHT
MARCH SEVEN OUR EYES NOSE THE
ZERO TWO STANCHIONS I'VE BEEN
INFORMED OF THAT NEITHER OF OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WILL BE
BACK SO WE CAN ACTUALLY CLOSE
THE ROLE ON ALL ITEMS I BELIEVE
EVERYONE HERE HAS NO THEIR SON
THAT. THEY NEED TO TAKE OUT.
I'M SORRY HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
HOUSE CAN. WILL THAT BILL IS
OUT BUT WE WILL GO THROUGH EACH
OF THE ITEMS JUST FOR CLARITY
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT THESE BILLS THANK YOU
MEASURE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU STAFF THE- I'M SO
SORRY THANK YOUS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA YOUR BILL IS
SHOCKED- WE ARE GOING TO GO
BACK- TO FILE ITEM ONE- AB SIX
SIXTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TO TWO WITH
THAT SURE VOTING I. A MATTER
TOLD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ADDED ASAL. I THE
RUSSELL I ALL RIGHT SIR TO TWO
FILE ITEM ONE IS OUT WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM SEVEN. WHICH IS AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN TWO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF BORJAS.
MELENEZ SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NINE AB THIRTY
NINETY TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORKS THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS A TWO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ RIGHT
EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
AND THAT DOES CONCLUDE OUR.
CALENDAR FOR TODAY THE. WE HAVE
THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AS WELL IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE FOR ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO SUBMIT A
COMMENT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CAR
PARTICIPATE. AND TO- ADD THE
SHELF WHICH IS NOW EMPTY
HOPEFULLY EVERY IS GOING TO GET
THEIR LUNCH BUT TO THOSE- WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING SO HARD TO
MAKE THIS LOOK EASY WE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE SERGEANTS THE
DGS STAFF BEEN WORKING TO KEEP
THE HEARING ROOMS AND OFFICES
CLEAN SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THE PEOPLE'S WORK IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS UNPRECEDENTED
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
PARTICULARLY TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY STAFF
FOR YOU CAN AND OTHER UPSTATE.
F. TO PASS COULD LEAD TO. INTO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
POLICIES THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO US HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT WE HAVE CONCLUDED
TODAY'S AGENDA AND THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY IS
ADJOURNED.